bonjour à tous La séance est ouverte
donc conformément en première alinéa de
l'article 28 de la Constitution j'ai
pris acte de l'ouverture de la session
ordinaire de 2022-2023 au Journal
Officiel du dimanche 2 octobre 2022
tout d'abord en votre nom à tous je
souhaite la bienvenue à nos 10 nouveaux
collègues qui ont remplacé à compter du
5 août 2022
des députés membres du gouvernement donc
il s'agit de Monsieur Christopher
Wiesberg qui remplace Monsieur Roland
Lescure madame Charlotte goetchi
bolognaise qui remplace Monsieur Olivier
Becht Monsieur Philippe Guillemard qui
remplace Carole Grandjean Madame Agnès
Carrel qui remplace Madame Agnès Firma
le Bodo
monsieur Fabien Laney qui remplace
Madame Geneviève dariussec Madame
Chantal boulot qui remplace Monsieur
Hervé Berville monsieur Luc Guémar qui
remplace madame Sarah elle Aeri Monsieur
Philippe Sorez qui remplace madame
Patricia miralez Monsieur Frédéric
zinski qui remplace madame Bérengère
Couillard et enfin Monsieur Laurent
esquenné gox qui remplace madame
Dominique Faure
et par ailleurs j'informe l'Assemblée
nationale que Madame Anne Grignon qui a
remplacé le 5 août dernier Monsieur
Jean-Noël Barrault nommé au gouvernement
à démissionné à compter du 12 août 2022
de son mandat de député
donc bienvenue à ces nouveaux collègues
donc l'ordre du jour appelle la
déclaration du gouvernement relative à
la guerre en Ukraine et aux conséquences
pour la France suivi d'un débat en
application de l'article 50-1 de la
Constitution je vous demande un peu de
calme mes chers collègues madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mesdames et messieurs les
députés chers collègues
la semaine dernière j'ai conduit à
Varsovie puis à Kiev une délégation
transpartizane de notre assemblée avec
Valérie rabot que je salue ma première
vice-présidente chargée des affaires
internationales avec Monsieur Jean-Louis
bourlange
il est là avec Monsieur Jean-Louis
bourlange président de la commission des
affaires étrangères Monsieur Thomas gas
filou président de la Commission de la
Défense et Pierre-Alexandre Anglade
président de la commission des affaires
européennes sans oublier Anne jeûnte
député des Français de l'étranger
singulièrement des Français du crâne
nous sommes nous sommes allés dire
l'appui indéfective de l'Assemblée
nationale française à l'Ukraine et à son
peuple cette appli existe depuis le
premier jour certains ici ont encore en
mémoire le visage du président elinski
s'adressant au Parlement sur les écrans
de cette émission
il nous a accueillis deux jours durant
et accompagnés à ses côtés notre
délégation s'est rendu sur le terrain au
contact des Ukrainiens représentant de
nos nations respectives notre place est
auprès des gens car nous avons en commun
tous quel que soit nos pays et quel que
soit nos bancs le fait de les aimer de
devoir les servir à tcherniv nous avons
vu les immeubles éventrés les visages
creusés les vies brisées mais nous avons
vu aussi la formidable résistance des
Ukrainiens leur détermination à se
battre contre l'agresseur russe et déjà
les premiers efforts de reconstruction
auxquels la France sonore de participer
nous avons promis d'en être les témoins
et les messagers
comme nous avons promis au président
Zelinski au président Stephen chouk de
mener avec la bataille avec eux la
bataille de l'opinion publique en Europe
en tant que responsable politique nous
avons le devoir de rappeler
unlassablement à nos concitoyens que le
combat que mène les ukrainiens et celui
de nos valeurs celle de la démocratie de
l'humanisme de la liberté et de la
civilisation européenne notre assemblée
notre pays notre Europe tous nous avons
le devoir de les soutenir tous nous
avons le devoir de condamner fermement
cette intolérable agression militaire de
la Russie qui a fait bien trop de
victimes et d'exilés tous nous avons le
devoir d'empêcher d'autres récits que
celui de la vérité prospéré parmi nos
concitoyens pour que le soutien de
l'Assemblée nationale à l'Ukraine
continue de s'inscrire dans la durée
j'ai souhaité nous avons souhaité que
nos deux chambres signent un protocole
d'accord pour développer des
coopérations techniques et des échanges
d'expériences des échanges qui seront
utiles également dans le cas du
processus d'ail desion de l'Ukraine à
l'Union européenne j'invite
solennellement chacun d'entre vous à se
saisir de ce protocole et à faire vivre
cette coopération renforcée avec nos
amis de la radar et avant de laisser la
parole à madame la Première ministre je
voudrais saluer monsieur Vadim au
melchenko qui est présent ici et qui est
ambassadeur d'Ukraine en France Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur ces
applaudissements montrent que la
représentation nationale que nous sommes
assure au peuple
ukrainien que vous représentez son
entière solidarité son entière
mobilisation à vos côtés et aux côtés
des Ukrainiens merci beaucoup
donc madame la Première ministre vous
avez la parole
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés
il y a un peu plus de 7 mois dans une
attaque illégale
brutal meurtrière la Russie a tenté
d'envahir l'Ukraine
beaucoup alors penser que le pays ne
tiendrait pas et que la puissance russe
l'emporterait rapidement
cette mois plus tard les combats durent
toujours
l'Ukraine progresse et la Russie se
retranchent dans le cynisme la menace et
le chantage
mesdames et messieurs les députés cette
guerre n'est pas un n'est pas seulement
un conflit entre deux pays
c'est tout l'ordre mondial
d'après-guerre qui est remis en cause
la Russie a menti à la face du monde
violer les lois internationales et agite
aujourd'hui la menace suprême
l'Europe n'est plus une terre de paix et
les armes ils font à nouveau des morts
des blessés des déplacés
certaines nations montrent qu'elles sont
prêtes à tout dans leur quête de
puissance et si nous laissons faire le
nouvel ordre mondial qui s'ouvrira sera
celui de la loi du plus fort
cette guerre c'est une lutte pour nos
valeurs
vendredi dernier Vladimir Poutine la
lui-même reconnu c'est notre modèle
démocratique qu'il attaque ce sont les
droits de l'homme qu'il remettent en
cause
Poutine n'accepte pas de voir la
démocratie s'imposer peu à peu à ses
frontières alors il veut intimider et
écraser ce qui aspire le message du
Kremlin est clair gare à ceux qui
voudraient s'émanciper de son joue gare
à tous ceux qui croient en autre chose
qu'à l'hégémonie russe
alors quand la liberté et la démocratie
sont sous les bombes nous n'avons pas le
droit de faiblir pas le droit de
louvoyer la France et l'Europe doivent
être au rendez-vous
cette guerre c'est une leçon de
solidarité
l'agression violente et délibérée d'un
état contre un autre en violation de
toutes les règles internationales et de
ses responsabilités particulières de
membres permanents du Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU et seul responsable de
cette guerre et de ses conséquences
mais dans notre réponse face à la Russie
nous devons être solidaires
solidaire des Ukrainiens qui risquent
leur vie pour leur liberté
solidaires car pour être fort pour être
efficace nous devons avancer unis avec
l'Europe avec tous ceux qui partagent
nos valeurs
le président de la République l'a dit ce
conflit engage notre responsabilité à
tous
c'est un membre de la famille européenne
qui est agressée ce sont nos valeurs qui
sont attaquées
c'est notre détermination face aux
nouvelles impérialisme russe qui est
éprouvé
ce conflit dure et durera ses
conséquences sont concrètes et
perceptibles dans toute l'Europe et dans
notre pays
aussi comme je m'y étais engagé je
reviens aujourd'hui devant vous 7 mois
après le premier débat sur la guerre en
Ukraine dans cette émission pour un
débat sur le fondement de l'article 50-1
de notre Constitution
mais avant toute chose je voulais avoir
un mot pour le peuple ukrainien
les Ukrainiens répondent à la Saurus
depuis 7 mois il subissent les tirs les
bombes il y a des blessés des morts
certains ont tout perdu mais ils n'ont
jamais renoncé jamais baisser la tête
leur courage est exemplaire
le résistance leur héroïsme même force
le respect avec le président Zelinski
avec le président zeninski avec le
Premier ministre Dennis chemial avec les
forces ukrainiennes le peuple ukrainien
combat pour sa liberté et je veux avec
vous le rendre hommage et devant vous
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur leur dire notre
indéfectible soutien
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
souhaite commencer par vous faire un
point sur la situation opérationnelle
la graission Russe était illégale sur le
plan du droit international et les
méthodes employées par la Russie sur le
terrain le sont également
chaque jour avec le plus grand sinistre
la Russie repousse les frontières de la
barbarie elle fait usage des armes 11
discernement en ciblant les civils en
visant des écoles des hôpitaux des
centres commerciaux des convois
humanitaires dans les territoires
occupés on assiste à des transferts
forcés de population y compris des
enfants
leur libération s'accompagne de la
découverte de nouvelles atrocités comme
un bout de chat en avril ou à isium plus
récemment
ces images nous indignent nous choque
nous révoltent
elle témoigne de la réalité des
opérations russes et de ce que risque le
peuple ukrainien ce sont autant de
violations des lois de la guerre autant
d'actes qui justifient d'agir autant de
monstruosités dont la Russie devra
répondre
on note par ailleurs sur le front la
présence de Wagner société de
mercenaires qui prend ses ordres
directement du Kremlin société qui
emploie aujourd'hui des criminels russes
pour venir combattre sur le front
société dont les méthodes sont bien
connues comme en témoignent ces
exactions documentées en République
centrafricaine et au Mali
enfin les frappes sur la centrale
nucléaire de sud-ukraine et l'occupation
militaire de la centrale de vaporiccia
par les Russes font courir des risques
inconsidérés à l'Ukraine à l'Europe et à
la Russie elle-même
nous sommes extrêmement préoccupés par
la situation asaporigia l'arrivée sur
place d'une mission de l'IA est une
première étape nous avons désormais des
informations en temps réel sur la
situation et le risque nucléaire
cependant l'information n'exclut pas le
danger et nous soutenons la proposition
du directeur général de l'auia d'arrêt
des tirs et de retraits du matériel
militaire de la zone notre objectif
c'est la démilitarisation
nous sommes déterminés à ce que les
crimes commis par la Russie soient
documentées jugés et puni c'est une
condition essentielle pour le retour
d'une paix durable
nous voulons y prendre part nous avons
décidé d'une contribution exceptionnelle
à la Cour pénale internationale nous
avons fait don d'un laboratoire ADN
mobile à l'Ukraine des experts de la
Gendarmerie nationale ont été dépêchés
sur place pour collecter des preuves
notre ambassade qui n'a jamais fermé
depuis le 24 février et pleinement
mobilisé pour faciliter ce travail
essentiel
au-delà des lignes de front la Russie
agit sur tous les champs
je pense aux cyberattaques je pense à la
multiplication des fausses informations
et au moment où nous parlons la Russie
brandit la menace d'utiliser toutes les
armes à sa disposition
n'ayons aucun doute la Russie est
susceptible d'aller plus loin dans l'île
d'égalité et dans l'escalade
mais malgré les méthodes inacceptables
de la Russie l'Ukraine tient bon
l'Ukraine est parvenue à arrêter la
Russie dans les homblastes de Donetsk et
de Louhansk elle a entamé aussi une
contre-offensive qui montre des
résultats on compte plusieurs personnes
ukrainiennes dans les régions de querquy
et de Liman et des avancées plus lentes
mais notables au sud de la région de
Kerson
ces résultats militaires montrent que le
courage des forces ukrainiennes et la
livraison de matériel militaires
occidentaux produisent leurs effets sur
le terrain
en reprenant l'initiative sur le front
bousculant les Russes et provoquant le
repli les soldats ukrainiens ont
enregistré de véritables succès
militaires qui doivent maintenant être
consolidés
il ne fait aucun doute que le dispositif
russe et fragilisé
la mascarade des référendums truqués
menés dans certaines régions de l'est de
l'Ukraine montrent que la Russie se rend
compte de sa propre fragilité et cherche
à donner un vernis démocratique à son
offensive
le président de la République l'a
rappelé nous ne reconnaîtrons évidemment
pas les résultats de ses prétendus
référendum ni l'annexion illégale de
Vladimir Poutine ce n'est rien d'autre
qu'une nouvelle provocation
l'appel à la mobilisation partielle de
Vladimir Poutine est un double aveu de
faiblesse
d'une faiblesse militaire inattendue
mais aussi d'une faiblesse interne alors
que cette mobilisation entraîne des
contestations et des départs massifs
vers l'étranger
mais nous nous trompons pas il est bien
trop tôt pour espérer la fin des combats
la mobilisation russe apportera de
nouveaux soldats sur le front la Russie
est déterminée et prête à tout les
combats vont encore durer et l'issue du
conflit ne doit pas être militaire mais
bien diplomatique
mesdames et messieurs les députés en
attendant que les conditions d'une
sortie du conflit soit réunies nous
avons un devoir aider l'Ukraine autant
que nous pouvons sans rentrer en guerre
avec la Russie
dès le début du conflit en s'adressant
aux Français le président de la
République avait prévenu cette guerre
aura des conséquences durables des
conséquences de nous n'avons pas fini de
mesurer l'ampleur
pourtant avec nos voisins européens avec
les alliés nous n'avons pas hésité
laissez faire la Russie aurait été
accepté un ordre mondial brutalisé où
tous les moyens sont bons et toutes les
exactions possibles
l'histoire nous a appris ce qu'il en
coûté de détourner le regard en croyant
se protéger
ne rien faire aurait montré à la Russie
qu'elle pouvait aller plus loin encore
et prolonger sa volonté d'impérialisme
ne rien faire aurait été perçu comme un
blanc un blanc sain à toutes les nations
qui veulent affirmer leur puissance et
nous mettre devant le fait accompli
ne rien faire aurait planté les germes
de nouveaux conflits qui nous auraient
menacé plus directement encore
défendre nos valeurs ça n'est pas un
idéal romantique c'est prouvé que la
démocratie n'est pas faible c'est
défendre un modèle qui nous protège
c'est affirmé que nous croyons en un
monde de paix et de stabilité
alors depuis le début du conflit avec
les alliés et les autres nations
européennes nous avons multiplié les
livraisons de matériels militaires à
l'Ukraine nous l'assumons nous devons
donner à l'Ukraine les moyens de se
défendre face à l'invasion
dès la fin du mois de février notre pays
a donné des missiles antichard des
missiles entières des équipements de
protection et de l'armement légers aux
forces armées ukrainiennes dans un
second temps nous avons si nous avons
fourni des systèmes plus lourds et plus
complexes des véhicules légers des
blindés et surtout des systèmes
d'artillerie César avec leur munitions
nous continuons nous avons formé les
soldats ukrainiens et des sessions de
carburant sont actuellement en cours
nous continuons à agir en européen nous
soutenons le lancement d'une mission
d'assistance militaire de l'Union
européenne sa création a été actée cet
été et nous y contribuerons dès qu'elle
sera effective
au-delà de l'Ukraine nous agissons en
alliés fiable et crédible
dès les premiers jours du conflit à la
demande du Président de la République
nous avons renforcé notre dispositif sur
le flanc Est de l'OTAN dans le cadre des
missions de réassurance de l'Alliance
régulièrement nous avions de combat
surveillent et protègent l'espace aérien
de l'Est de l'Europe nous avons pris la
tête de la mission de l'OTAN en Roumanie
en tant que nation cadre et de la
Baltique à la mer Noire nous sommes
présents d'un bout à l'autre du flan est
la Russie pensait trouver le temps
faible et divisé elle a ressoudé
Moscou est désormais que les alliés sont
unis près et ce qui lui en coûterait si
elle prolongée ses volontés guerrières
notre soutien militaire n'est qu'un
désaspects de notre action
dès les premiers jours de la guerre avec
l'Union européenne nous avons donc nous
avons donc pris des sanctions fortes
là encore Vladimir Poutine pensait
diviser l'Europe elle a fait face et
montrer son unité et sa détermination
face à la crise
je dirais même plus bien malgré lui le
président Poutine a renforcé l'Europe
le premier paquet de sanctions a été
adopté en moins de 24 heures cette
paquets ont été adoptés jusqu'à présent
et le 8e est en cours de négociation
notre objectif est le même depuis le
début rendre le coup de la guerre
insupportable pour la Russie frapper
durement son économie pour l'empêcher de
financer son offensive
nous avons pris des sanctions massives
et de tous les ordres des sanctions
financières qui limitent les capacités
de financement de l'État russe et des
entreprises
des sanctions bancaires comme
l'exclusion de nombreuses banques russes
du système Swift des sanctions
commerciales avec des restrictions à
l'importation et à l'exportation des
sanctions contre la désinformation russe
en empêchant la diffusion de la chaîne
Rush chatouday et de l'agence Spoutnik
dans l'Union européenne des sanctions
politiques contre les dirigeants les
oligarques les propagandistes avec le
huitième paquet sur la table ce sont
près de 1300 personnes directement
touchées par des gels d'avoir ou des
interdictions de voyage en Europe
les Russes misaient sur notre peur et
notre division
l'Union européenne a montré qu'elle
était forte et savait réagir l'Europe
n'a pas reculé devant les décisions
courageuses je pense notamment à
l'embargo sur les importations de
charbon de pétrole brut et de produits
raffinés russes
et ses sanctions n'en déplaisent à ceux
qui massent que leur fascination pour
l'impérialisme russe par un prétendu
patriotisme elle fonctionne
l'économie russe c'est qu'on
considérablement rétracté avec une chute
de 6% de son PIB pour cette année
l'inflation russe a explosé et la Russie
a perdu l'accès à des matériels de haute
technologie nécessaire pour moderniser
le pays et assurer sa croissance
avec les prix élevés de l'énergie Moscou
tente pour l'instant de maintenir
l'illusion mais les faits sont là la
propagande russe ne doit pas nous berner
l'économie russe est à l'asphy par son
obstination Vladimir Poutine hypothèque
l'avenir de son pays il jette des
millions de citoyens russes dans la
pauvreté car c'est son peuple le premier
qui ressent l'effondrement de l'économie
russe hépatie de sa volonté guerrière
les sanctions continueront tant que
Poutine s'évertura dans la spirale du
conflit et de la confrontation
abandonnez les sanctions ce serait
abandonné l'Ukraine ce serait renoncé à
nos valeurs ce serait nous soumettre à
la Russie la France le patriotisme ça
n'est pas l'abandon ça n'est pas le
renoncement ce n'est pas la soumission
mesdames et messieurs les députés la
fournitures de matériel militaire et les
sanctions sont les deux piliers de notre
soutien à l'Ukraine dans sa riposte face
à la Russie mais notre accompagnement ne
s'arrête pas là nous aidons l'Ukraine
par un soutien humanitaire plus de 200
millions d'euros ont été mobilisés et
2500 tonnes de matériel livrés ce
soutien se fait dans tous les domaines
il se déploie sur place et dans les pays
frontaliers il est coordonné avec nos
partenaires avec les ONG et les
organisations internationales
ce soutien continue en ce moment même et
un quatrième convoi humanitaire a quitté
Marseille par bateau la semaine dernière
nous sommes organisés aussi pour
accueillir les réfugiés plus de 100 000
ukrainiens ont été accueillis et près de
19000 enfants ont été scolarisés cela
s'est fait rapidement
efficacement dignement
cela s'est fait une fois de plus grâce à
la réaction exemplaire de l'Europe
dès le 3 mars l'Union s'est accordée
pour que les réfugiés Ukrainiens
puissent bénéficier de la protection
temporaire c'est-à-dire de l'accueil de
l'accès à l'éducation à la santé à
l'emploi à l'hébergement
c'était une première c'est un acte
décisif et plus de 4 millions
d'Ukrainiens en bénéficient aujourd'hui
en Europe
je veux saluer ici toutes celles et ceux
qui participent à l'élan de solidarité
remarquable envers l'Ukraine depuis 7
mois je pense à nous ONG à nous
entreprises je veux rendre hommage aussi
et remercier toutes les collectivités
qui se mobilisent organise la solidarité
et permettent l'accueil et la
scolarisation des réfugiés Ukrainiens
leur engagement est précieux et
déterminant
je pense enfin à tous nos concitoyens
qui se sont engagés nous devons les
soutenir et je vous confirme la mise en
place à partir de fin novembre d'une
aide pour nos compatriotes qui
accueillent des déplacés Ukrainiens chez
eux
notre soutien à l'Ukraine est également
diplomatique
l'Ukraine fait pleinement partie de la
famille européenne
lors du Conseil européen de juin le
statut de pays candidat à l'adhésion lui
a été accordé à l'unanimité il s'agit
d'une décision historique mais que nous
avons jugé indispensable dans le
contexte de profond changement
géopolitique qui affecte notre continent
le chemin de l'adhésion est long
exigeant il n'y aura pas de procédure
accélérée ou de critères au rabais ce ne
serait dans l'intérêt de personnes ni de
l'Union européenne ni de l'Ukraine et
cette dernière le sait mais je veux
saluer ici l'action des autorités
ukrainiennes qui ont entamé malgré la
période la mise en œuvre des
recommandations de la Commission
sans préjudice de ce processus
d'adhésion la communauté politique
européenne proposée par le Président de
la République tiendra sa première
réunion ce jeudi à Prague
elle permettra à ses membres dont
l'Ukraine de renforcer leur encrage
européen et de bénéficier de coopération
concrète dans le domaine des
infrastructures de la sécurité de
l'énergie ou bien encore en matière de
mobilité
enfin soutenir l'Ukraine ses pensées sa
reconstruction
on évolue on évalue aujourd'hui après de
350 milliards d'euros les besoins du
pays pour sa reconstruction
c'est un défi colossal et un défi
collectif
la France il prendra sa part
à court terme nous nous sommes engagés à
concentrer nos efforts sur la
reconstruction de la région de tchernie
Yves dans le nord du pays
nous suivons en cela le mécanisme de
parrainage proposé par le président
Zelinski
les Européens sont engagés après la
conférence de Lugano cet été une
conférence sur la reconstruction sera
organisée le 25 octobre prochain en
Allemagne
pour notre part je vous annonce que nous
organiserons dans les prochains mois à
Paris une conférence économique avec les
autorités ukrainiennes pour mobiliser
les entreprises françaises
nous soutenons enfin les initiatives de
la Commission européenne pour
accompagner et organiser le financement
de la reconstruction de l'Ukraine
mesdames et messieurs les députés nous
le savons tous les conséquences de la
guerre dépassent largement les
frontières de l'Ukraine
aussi depuis février le gouvernement
agit sans relâche pour limiter l'impact
du conflit sur notre pays
notre premier enjeu est énergétique
avec la reprise post covid les prix de
l'énergie avec considérablement
considérablement augmenté avant même le
début de la guerre
le conflit et l'arrêt quasi totale des
livraisons de gaz russe vers l'Europe
ont entraîné des tensions
d'approvisionnement et une nouvelle
hausse des prix
et je veux ici rappeler les choses
fermement
l'inverse pas les rôles c'est la Russie
qui a lancé cette guerre c'est elle qui
nous pousse à agir c'est elle encore qui
choisit de faire du gaz un objet de
chantage
ces derniers jours des explosions ont
été constatées sur les gazeux ducs Nord
Stream 1 et 2
tout indique qu'un acte de sabotage
grave et irresponsable a été comme lui
comme il
je ne tirerai pas de conclusion ici une
enquête internationale indépendante doit
être conduite et nous répondrons avec
l'Union européenne de manière ferme et
unie à cette attaque sur des
infrastructures énergétiques européennes
quoi qu'il en soit nous sommes prêts à
affronter cet hiver nous avons anticipé
cette situation en amont nous avons
porté nos stocks de gaz au maximum au
niveau national comme européen nous
avons augmenté les capacités
d'importation de nos terminaux
métalliers nous avons diversifié notre
approvisionnement
cet été le président de la République a
annoncé un plan sobriété et si chacun
prend sa part nous traverserons les mois
à venir sans risque de coupure
nous y parviendrons aussi grâce à la
solidarité européenne nous livrerons du
gaz à nous partenaires qui nous
livreront de l'électricité en retour
arrêtez la solidarité serait prendre le
risque de manquer d'électricité
une fois de plus le simplisme et les
propos d'estrade nous mènent dans
l'impasse
protéger les Français c'est aussi
limiter l'impact de l'inflation sur leur
pouvoir d'achat très tôt nous avons pris
des mesures extrêmement fortes les plus
pop les plus protectrices d'Europe
le bouclier tarifaire a bloquer les prix
du gaz et limiter la hausse des prix de
l'électricité
sans cela les priorités comme en
Belgique en Allemagne ou au Royaume-Uni
il y a deux semaines j'ai annoncé le
maintien du bouclier tarifaire à compter
de début 2023 les prix auraient dû être
multipliés par plus de 2 au lieu de ça
la hausse sera limitée à 15%. c'est une
économie moyenne de 175 euros par mois
pour les Français qui se chauffent au
gaz de 160 euros par mois pour ceux qui
utilisent l'électricité c'est une mesure
efficace elle s'accompagne d'un chèque
énergie exceptionnel de 100 ou 200 euros
pour 12 millions de foyers les plus
modestes c'est 40% des Français
nous devons aussi protéger toutes les
entreprises et les collectivités face à
la hausse des prix notamment ceux de
l'électricité nous avançons au niveau
européen pour traiter le problème à la
racine lors du Conseil énergie de
vendredi dernier nous avons progressé
vers la mise en oeuvre d'un plafond du
prix du gaz et vers l'extension à toute
l'Europe du mécanisme
ibérique qui a permis de ramener les
prix de l'électricité à des niveaux 2 ou
3 fois plus faibles que dans le reste de
l'Europe en parallèle nous travaillons
pour protéger les entreprises et les
collectivités face à la flambée des prix
de l'énergie le gouvernement présentera
prochainement des dispositions à cet
effet
en complément nous continuons à
renforcer simplifier l'aide mise en
place pour les entreprises les plus en
difficulté notre objectif est de limiter
au maximum la baisse d'activité voir les
fermetures d'usine
mais au-delà des réponses d'urgence
cette guerre nous montre la nécessité de
conquérir rapidement notre souveraineté
énergétique et de sortir de notre
dépendance aux énergies fossiles nous y
parviendrons par une stratégie
ambitieuse autour du nucléaire et du
renouvelable nous aurons l'occasion d'en
discuter plus longuement à l'occasion du
débat sur notre politique énergétique
que j'ai proposé de tenir devant le
Parlement
protéger c'est aussi agir pour nos
agriculteurs et notre alimentation
l'Ukraine et la Russie sont parmi les
plus gros producteurs de céréales et
d'oléagineux la guerre a eu pour effet
de rompre certaines chaînes de
production et d'augmenter les prix des
céréales et des engrais dès le mois de
mars des mesures ont été prises avec
l'appui de l'Union européenne pour
protéger les agriculteurs et les
consommateurs une enveloppe de près de
500 millions d'euros d'aide a été
débloquée des mesures spécifiques ont
été prises au niveau européen comme au
niveau français pour les secteurs les
plus touchés je pense en particulier à
l'élevage par ailleurs une plus grande
part des aides directes de la PAC seront
versés en avance aux agriculteurs
nous agissons également en français et
en européen pour faciliter
l'acheminement des exportations
agricoles ukrainiennes avec l'aide de la
Commission européenne nous avons créé
des colis corridors de solidarité
notamment via la Roumanie grâce à cette
action 14 millions de tonnes de céréales
ukrainiennes ont pu être sortis du pays
et contrairement aux affirmations
mensongères de Moscou parmi les céréales
exportées vers l'Europe 70% ont ensuite
été envoyés vers l'Afrique ouvert l'Asie
là encore ce conflit nous montre
l'importance de bâtir une souveraineté
alimentaire française et européenne nous
y œuvrerons notamment grâce aux
investissements de France 2030 et elle a
future loi d'orientation et d'avenir
pour l'agriculture
cette guerre enfin fait planer une
menace grave sur la sécurité alimentaire
de nombreux pays en développement une
crise alimentaire mondiale est possible
aussi le président de la République a
été à l'origine de l'initiative
internationale Pharm qui organise la
solidarité vis-à-vis des pays les plus
menacés
mesdames et messieurs les députés
protéger les Français c'est aussi tiré
tous les enseignements stratégiques de
cette crise ce conflit montre une fois
de plus l'importance du multilatéralisme
nous sommes forts quand nous avançons
unis entre-européens entre liés entre
nations qui aspirent à la paix et à la
sécurité internationale
cette guerre a prouvé la nécessité de la
souveraineté et de l'autonomie
stratégique européenne
l'Union Européenne s'est construite
autour de l'idée de paix et de la
défense des valeurs l'État de droit le
plus réaliste les droits de l'homme
c'est ce modèle qui est attaqué par
Vladimir Poutine c'est ce modèle que
nous devons être en mesure de défendre
ensemble
ces derniers mois sous présidence
française du Conseil européen ont été
l'occasion d'avancer historique la
facilité européenne de paix a été a été
utilisée pour aider directement un pays
attaqué à se défendre c'est une
véritable révolution copernicienne pour
l'Europe
nous avons acté notre volonté de muscler
les investissements européens en matière
de défense avec l'adoption de la
boussole stratégique en mars dernier
nous sommes engagés collectivement lors
du sommet de Versailles de mars à lutter
contre nos dépendances stratégiques à
commencer par l'énergie
aujourd'hui nous ne sommes plus isolés
quand nous parlons de souveraineté
européenne c'est désormais une ambition
largement partagée dans l'Union
ce conflit a marqué le réveil
géopolitique de l'Europe nous savons
désormais qu'il nous faut peser pour
faire valoir nos valeurs et notre modèle
enfin la guerre justifie les choix que
nous avons réalisé lors de la précédente
loi de programmation militaire nous
devons maintenir des capacités
opérationnelles fortes être prêt à agir
dans tous les milieux et à faire face au
retour de la guerre de haute intensité
c'est l'objet même de la revue nationale
stratégique demandée par le Président de
la République et sur laquelle s'appuiera
la prochaine loi de programmation
militaire
cette revue stratégique vous sera
partagée mi-octobre et je souhaite que
le Parlement soit associé au travaux des
laboration de la LPM
mesdames et messieurs les députés cette
guerre dure mais elle aura un lendemain
dans ce monde l'Ukraine sera debout et
maîtresse de son territoire
la Russie aussi sera présente elle est
et reste une puissance majeure elle sera
toujours demain notre voisin nous ne
pouvons pas l'ignorer
l'avenir s'écrira autour d'une table de
négociation et non pas sur un champ de
bataille c'est pourquoi le président de
la République a choisi de maintenir des
échanges avec le président russe
c'est négociations devront se tenir en
permettant à l'Ukraine de faire
pleinement entendre sa voix c'est
pourquoi l'heure est au soutien de sa
contrefensive et nous appuierons
l'Ukraine jusqu'à ce que ces dirigeants
estiment le moment des négociations
venues
mesdames et messieurs les députés ce
débat ouvrent la nouvelle session
parlementaire cela s'imposait avec la
guerre en Ukraine beaucoup de nos
certitudes ont été ébranlées beaucoup
d'urgences se sont fait jour et beaucoup
de transitions doivent être accélérées
cette guerre nous a rappelé que la
démocratie est fragile et qu'il ne
fallait jamais cesser de la défendre
elle nous a prouvé une fois de plus que
l'unité est la solidarité européenne
sont des armes puissantes pour peser
dans les équilibres internationaux et
protéger nos concitoyens
elle a confirmé qu'il était urgent de
reconquérir notre souveraineté
énergétique industrielle alimentaire
alors je vous le dis nous ne faiblirons
pas ni face à l'agresseur russe ni pour
protéger les Français ni pour préparer
l'avenir de notre pays la guerre en
Ukraine va durer mais nous sommes prêts
la résistance du peuple ukrainien nous
oblige nous serons au rendez-vous nous
serons à la hauteur je vous remercie
madame la Première ministre je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Louis Thieriot pour le groupe les
républicains
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
évoquèrent ici notre politique étrangère
est toujours un exercice délicat notre
hémicycle est scruté par les
chancellerie étrangères mais lorsque
l'autocrate du Kremlin annexe les
territoires d'un pays souverain après
des parodies de référendum et usent de
la menace nucléaire comme il le fait
depuis le 24 février on invoquant le
précédent d'Hiroshima notre parole doit
être toute de gravité
rappelons trois vérités d'abord il y a
un agresseur la Russie et un agressé
l'Ukraine
le narratif russe est une imposture le
traité 4 + 2 ne comportait aucun
engagement de ne pas étendre le temps si
cela avait été si important cela aurait
été évidemment couché sur le papier
la Russie bafoue les droits humains el
Bafou aussi sa signature dans le
mémorandum de Budapest de 1994 elle
garantissait les frontières de l'Ukraine
c'est si vrai que même un pays comme la
Turquie qui s'efforçait de respecter un
équilibre ambigu affer les référendums
d'annexion
quant à l'adhésion à l'OTAN des nations
d'Europe centrale et orientale c'est le
choix de peuple libre que rien ne
justifie d'empêcher le temps n'a jamais
envahi personne et les erreurs
américaines je pense à l'Irak n'ont pas
été commises sous la bannière de
l'Alliance
quant aux États-Unis si leur complexe
militarro industriel et leur industrie
pétrolière profiteront évidemment de ce
conflit c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour
leur grande stratégie de pivot vers
l'Asie Pacifique cette guerre est une
tragédie pour tous l'Occident n'est sans
doute pas sans défaut mais il importe de
discerner l'essentiel de l'accessoire
rappelons aussi qu'il est chez nous une
cinquième colonne
à l'extrême gauche par atavisme
stalinien par anti-américanisme primaire
et par anticapitalisme furieux alors que
l'économie russe en a le pire visage
celui du capitalisme de connivence et de
prédation
à l'ultra-droite par fascination pour le
culte de l'homme fort et la défense de
prétendu valeur le conservatisme à sa
grandeur le préserver ce qui vaut
changer ce qu'il faut de d'israëlie
n'est pas sans noblesse
mais Vladimir Poutine l'ami de Kadirov
ne défend pas les racines chrétiennes et
le message d'amour universel des
Béatitudes il en est leur caricatures
grimaçante celle de la parabole du Grand
Inquisiteur de Dostoïevski qui ne sert
qu'à couvrir le pas des bourreaux dans
la nuit de boucha
enfin ne nous y trompons pas la guerre
déclarait à l'Occident comme un tout est
une guerre contre l'homme occidental
l'homme du libre arbitre et de la
délibération démocratique qui refuse les
assignations à résidence même s'il
n'oublie ni les limites de la condition
humaine ni son appartenance un tout
organique qui s'appelle la communauté
nationale
cette guerre est aussi une guerre contre
la France regardons ce qui se passe au
Mali avec Wagner ou semble-t-il au
Burkina Faso
alors que faire
continuer avec sang froid ne pas céder
aux bluff Beaba de la grammaire
stratégique de la dissuasion maintenir
et renforcer les sanctions d'autant que
les difficultés énergétiques qui
s'annoncent sont au moins autant les
conséquences de la crise en Ukraine que
des erreurs de politique énergétiques
commises depuis 2012
refusaient la facilité de l'égoïsme et
du pacifisme bêlant avoir en tête les
mots de Churchill vous aviez le choix
entre la guerre et la honte vous avez
choisi la honte et vous aurez la guerre
rappeler enfin et vous l'avez fait
madame le Premier ministre que nous
n'avons rien contre le peuple russe il a
toujours balancé entre le courant
occidentaliste et le courant slavophile
nous sommes hélas dans un moment ils
vend le terrible pas dans un moment
Pierre Legrand mais nous nous retrouvons
un jour sur l'année 20 j'en suis certain
négociant si nous le pouvons bien sûr
mais à la date et aux conditions fixés
par l'Ukraine car elle sait elle seule
qui paye le prix du sang pour ramener à
la raison
imperturbateur de l'ordre international
alors la France puissance d'équilibre
pourra jouer tout son rôle stratégique
concrètement cela signifie d'abord armée
l'Ukraine mais sans nous démunir car nul
ne sait de quoi demain sera fait la
décision dont s'est fait l'école après
de livrer des canons César prévus pour
l'exportation ou des véhicules Arceus
est excellentes et qu'on ne vienne pas
dire que c'est prolongé la guerre
heureusement que le Royaume-Uni n'avait
pas dit cela à la France Libre ayant en
tête les appels déchirants et désespérés
des maquisards du Vercors qui demandait
en vain des livraisons d'armes se disent
sont pour nous les frères de ceux du
Vercors
ensuite donner des signes de notre
résolution
notre prochaine LPM on sera un et notre
groupe mais monsieur le ministre je le
sais aussi sera très vigilant à ce que
nos armées soient dotés de tous les
moyens nécessaires pour répondre au
tumulte du monde
la référence aux années 30 est souvent
une paresse de l'esprit mais qui sont à
la rhétorique du diktat occidental au
coup de bluff réussi de Géorgie ou de
Crimée à l'obsédant une question des
minorités et durée découpage des
frontières celui-là ne peut échapper au
parallèle vertigineux de la
remilitarisation de la Rhénanie de l'âne
schluz et de Munich il est peut-être
plus tard que nous ne le pensons qui lui
mieux valu réarmer en 36 que d'attendre
1938 le temps du quoi qu'il en coûte de
l'économie est terminée celui du quoi
qu'il en coûte de la sécurité à hélas
commencer
enfin
promouvoir l'unité du monde libre
aujourd'hui rien ne peut remplacer le
temps sans l'aide américaine qui fournit
70% de l'assistance militaire les chars
russes tromperaient probablement leur
chenille dans le Bougue aux frontières
de la Pologne
notre présence dans le commandement
intégré notre meilleur assurance pour
peser auprès de nos amis d'Europe
centrale qui savent hélas que sans les
États-Unis leur protection serait bien
fragile
et qu'on invoque pas à tort et à travers
les mânes du général de Gaulle quand il
s'est retiré du commandement intégré il
s'agissait de se repositionner dans le
concert des nations face à des
États-Unis englués dans le bourbier
vietnamien la France consacrée près de
4% de son PIB à la défense alors que ce
n'est que 2% aujourd'hui alors de grâce
pas d'anachronisme ne faisons pas parler
les morts retenons de lui qu'il n'est
pas de politique qui vaille en dehors
des réalités qu'elle est toujours
contingente mais causeurs cruciales il
faut choisir son camp comme il le fit
avec l'ambassadeur du RSS qui le mettait
en garde au moment de la crise de Cuba
et bien Monsieur l'Ambassadeur lui
répondit-il nous allons mourir ensemble
c'était la meilleure manière d'éviter la
guerre et de sauver la paix
l'Europe notre Europe a également tous
son rôle à jouer dans la sortie de crise
l'idée d'une communauté politique
européenne est à saluer dès lors qu'elle
permettra de rassembler
utilement sans provoquer des adhésions
prématurées ni opportunes ni souhaité en
l'état par les peuples de l'Union
quand les canons se seront tu il sera
temps de travailler à notre autonomie
stratégique car rien ne dit que le
tropisme asiatique de notre allié
d'outre Atlantique ne nous laissera pas
un jour fort démuni en attendant
l'unité de l'Occident et notre meilleur
garantie notre division sur l'aide à
l'Ukraine ou sur les sanctions seraient
en fait la seule arme entre les mains de
Moscou alors
en ces heures décisives
notre groupe sera comme il l'a toujours
fait aux avant-postes de la Défense de
l'Occident à vos côtés quand il s'agit
d'intérêt national
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Frédéric petit pour le groupe moderne
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre ministre mes chers collègues le
24 février dernier jour de l'invasion
j'avais à cette tribune utilisait les
termes de guerre culturelle
d'anti-europe je voudrais revenir sur ce
point pour commencer mon intervention
je représente les Français d'Europe
centrale au premier loge de ce conflit
mais je représente aussi le
franco-allemand le franco-allemand
profond
le franco-allemand ancien et en plein
renouveau le franco-allemand solide le
franco-allemand citoyen il y a bientôt
80 années des ennemis héréditaires quand
les ruines sont encore fumantes à
certains endroits
quant au sortir de l'horreur des villes
entières ont encore faim et froid
l'hiver
quand la région de La Sarre est
française et le sera encore 12 ans en
proie des tensions communautaires
parfois violentes quand le bas de
Würtenberg n'est pas l'Allemagne mais
zone d'occupation et bien c'est à ce
moment dans ces tensions que ses ennemis
héréditaires par un contre-pied génial
au déterministes au nationalismes
étriqués que ses ennemis héréditaires
font une communauté du charbon et de
l'acier et fondent un modèle unique de
réconciliation par le faire ensemble sur
les terres belligènes de notre cher
Europe
oui
oui nos territoires sont belligènes et
il le resteront comment serait-il
autrement sur un isme assez contraints
tant de nations de peuples de religion
de système administratif de langue
d'alphabet même temps de système de
valeurs de nostalgie contradictoires se
sont entrecroisés s'entrecroisent encore
temps de migration parfois lente parfois
rapide parfois récente parfois ancienne
parfois spontanée parfois contraintes
tant de migrations qui enchante qui ont
rendu chacun aussi différents mais aussi
légitime que son voisin voir que son
colocataire
deux modèles face à cette question posée
depuis des siècles à notre Europe un
modèle impérialiste rétrograde souvent
violent la domination de l'une des
nations ou alors un modèle coopératif
qui prône l'unité dans la diversité
tournée vers les défis communs et
supérieures à partir d'une gestion
humanisme humaniste des conflits
indispensables à la diversité européenne
où l'histoire est un des bas
scientifique et un outil de
rapprochement où l'avenir de la planète
est un outil est un sujet commun et
urgent
aujourd'hui les masques sont tombés
l'histoire devient une arme au service
de l'état-major de l'agresseur les
soldats ne sont plus des citoyens
avertis
la langue devient à nous case
quand l'impérialisme moscovite se
concentre sur sa propre survie alimente
sa nostalgie comment pourra-t-il
affronter les vrais défis du 21e siècle
la défense de la planète la lutte contre
les inégalités comment pourra-t-il
participer de près ou de loin à un
effort commun
on nous accuse souvent d'utiliser des
grands mots que le terme de valeur ne
veut rien dire face à l'hiver qui arrive
et aux vrais intérêts de nos concitoyens
cette guerre met du concret de
l'évidence du tangible sur cette
confrontation de modèles cette
confrontation de valeur non nos valeurs
ne sont pas une novembre pour cacher
l'anti France une novlangue pour cacher
la guerre sociale
le modèle portait sans masque
aujourd'hui par le régime de Moscou
c'est l'assignation à résidence
permanente assignation à résidence dans
ta langue dans une langue dans une
narration historique et les dernières
parodies de référendum l'ont prouvé ces
assignés à résidence n'ont même plus
besoin d'être chez eux pour que
l'empereur leur impose son choix nous
sommes revenus au temps de Google ce ne
sont plus les âmes mortes que l'on fait
participer ce sont les amants fuis les
familles réfugiées et déplacées dont on
nous explique qu'elles ont bien voté
dans notre modèle à nous nous battons
pour émanciper nous nous battons contre
l'assignation à résidence l'Union
européenne n'est pas un arrangement
tranquille quand tout va bien ce n'est
pas une vieille idée avachi de fin de
manquer électorale et cette guerre nous
le rappelle l'Union européenne c'est une
méthode permanente de règlement
humaniste des conflits inhérents voire
nécessaire à nos territoires européens
c'est une idée jeune parfois incomprise
c'est une organisation qui se trompe et
qui fait des fautes parfois oui c'est
vrai mais c'est une idée vitale
indispensable à notre diversité
européenne et qui aujourd'hui nécessite
de notre part de la vaillance dans les
agressions qu'elle subit dans l'escalade
de violence dans le tourbillon de bas
instinct qui la menace
non défendre cette ligne ce n'est pas
être vate en guerre c'est être lucide
sur ce qu'une paix durable exige de
vaillance ce n'est pas être va ton
guerre mais être Battois pour la paix
ce n'est pas notre guerre c'est notre
confrontation
alors quelles conséquences pour nos
concitoyens pour notre rôle de
parlementaire français
chers collègues gardons nous d'abord de
l'arrogance nous avons besoin d'un
langage de vérité et non de certitudes
et de division ce n'est pas l'arrogance
qui permettra la lente construction
d'institutions démocratiques fiables
mais l'entraide la franchise est
toujours le respect
Poutine est en difficulté sur le plan
militaire il est encore efficace sur le
plan politique et il m'est à l'épreuve
notre constance notre constance à
défendre nos valeurs notre constance à
défendre notre modèle et notre avenir
alors que l'hiver s'annonce difficile et
que des pâtes cafards politiques par
calculer électoral ou par soumission
intellectuelle voudront mettre un terme
aux sanctions et à l'aide à l'Ukraine il
faudra tenir notre cap et nos
engagements il faut clairement poser la
question au rassemblement national
devons-nous abandonner des sanctions
économiques contre un régime qui par
exemple des portes des milliers
d'enfants et de civil Ukrainiens pour
les russifier ce n'est ni conforme à nos
valeurs ni même dans notre intérêt
nous nous députés démocrates depuis le
1er jour nous sommes très clairs sur
notre position et nous n'avons jamais
tergiverser nous sommes pour le
renforcement des sanctions à l'encontre
du régime de Moscou
nous devons nous plus nous engager dans
la reconstruction de l'Ukraine qu'est-ce
que cela veut dire bien entendu du dur
des bâtiments bombardés souvent sans
raison tactique des maisons des hôpitaux
des écoles des routes des ponts des
infrastructures
cela veut dire aussi remettre en place
des administrations fragiles depuis
longtemps à cause de la bureaucratie
ancienne ou de la corruption cela veut
dire recréer des circuits de finances
publiques et collective oui nous devons
commencer à reconstruire participer
aujourd'hui de façon assumée à cette
reconstruction tout d'abord parce que
les Ukrainiens nous le demandent en plus
des moyens militaires et il nous demande
même plus que de la reconstruction dans
tous les contacts les nombreuses visités
rencontrent que j'ai pu effectuer mais
interlocuteurs Ukrainiens parlent plus
de modernisation que de simples
reconstructions ils assument la
fragilité de leur démocratie récente
leur dysfonctionnement leur division et
ils ne veulent pas reconstruire à
l'identique dans un brand grand
bricolage plus ou moins humanitaire ni
reprendre les mêmes processus
ils veulent que nous les aidions à
moderniser à transformer à rendre leur
pratique publique plus transparentes et
plus efficaces je l'ai entendu de
gouverneur de régions de responsables
d'associations de maire de directeurs
d'école et d'hôpitaux nous avons des
outils en France et en Union européenne
nous avons des outils pour lutter contre
la corruption et pour la libre et juste
entreprise contre l'endotructrices et
pour la citoyenneté éclairée contre
l'embrigadement et pour l'émancipation
dans les écoles nous n'allons pas aider
des gentils contre des méchants nous
allons développer et construire sur un
territoire de conflits anciens et
récents nous allons construire avec
vaillance le seul modèle qui garantira
si nous y arrivons que la fin de la
guerre d'aujourd'hui ne sera pas
l'origine de celle de demain
il y a au coeur de notre action un enjeu
critique aujourd'hui dramatique les
enfants du crâne sont l'avenir de
l'Ukraine nous devons aider le système
scolaire à rester simplement en vie
reliés garder les enfants Ukrainiens que
nous avons accueillis les ramener dès
que possible aider à les éduquer
multiplier les échanges scolaires comme
nous l'avions fait entre Français et
Allemands et nous devons réussir à faire
revenir de captivité ce que le régime
russe a kidnappé et déporté il n'y a pas
d'autres mots
ce ne sera pas le geste d'un grand frère
à un petit frère de nations dominante à
des soi-disant esclaves ou colonisés
mais la lente construction d'une
coopération oui lucrée l'Ukraine
apportera la communauté s'efforce celle
que l'on connaît son agriculture mais
aussi la décarbonation de l'énergie
auquel on pense moins ou la numérisation
de l'état civil qui est une réussite
chez eux
c'est notre manière de faire c'est notre
mode de coordination notre boussole
européenne dans le fracas du monde
planifiée structuré et faire ensemble
dès aujourd'hui pour vivre en paix
durable et souveraine demain les
ukrainiens et les Ukrainiens se battent
pour leur liberté et la nôtre nous
devons les soutenir nous devons avec
vaillance et courage prendre la main
aujourd'hui sur la reconstruction pour
notre souveraineté et la leur je vous
remercie je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Boris Vallot
pour le groupe socialiste
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres Mesdames et Messieurs les
présidents de commission mes chers
collègues
les démocratie gagne les guerres et dans
cette hémicycle la raisonnée il y a plus
d'un siècle de nombreux débats les
commissions de la chambre ont questionné
parfois rue de loyer le gouvernement y
compris sur la conduite des opérations
militaires alors il est toujours
nécessaire de débattre et
particulièrement dans ces circonstances
voilà pourquoi nous vous remercions
Madame la Présidente d'avoir engagé une
coopération entre notre assemblée et
l'assemblée ukrainienne voilà pourquoi
nous vous remercions Madame la première
ministre d'avoir répondu par ce débat
notre interpellation du 12 juillet
dernier
la guerre qui gronde à l'est de l'Europe
n'est pas un simple conflit territorial
cette guerre est celle d'un régime
politique autoritaire et brutal qui
depuis des années déjà a servi son
peuple pour mieux organiser la
servicement de ses voisins proches et
moins proches cette guerre est celle
d'un autocrate Vladimir Poutine
rappelons-nous déjà l'occupation de la
Crimée l'infiltration au dos basse près
de 16000 morts Ukrainiens déjà
la guerre qui compte à l'est est une
guerre contre les libertés
contre le droit contre la démocratie
contre l'universalisme de ses valeurs
une guerre en Europe et contre l'Europe
capable parfois dans l'unité de montrer
le meilleur d'elle-même elle sourde
depuis longtemps déjà de cyberguer en
ingérence électorale d'élimination
ciblées en guerre idéologique via des
chaînes de désinformation il faut être
avec les dictateurs sans naïveté et son
complaisance et les tenir pour ce qu'ils
sont des ennemis de la démocratie
depuis le 24 février l'Ukraine est en
arme pour faire face avec un courage qui
force l'admiration
aux forces militaires et paramilitaires
russes bras armés d'une idéologie qui
nie son existence bras armée d'un
pouvoir qui ne connaît que la force et
le cynisme en défendant sa vie le peuple
ukrainien défend le droit et en l'aidant
nous donnons de la force aux droits et
nous nous défendons nous-mêmes alors que
pointe la stratégie de la mer brûlée
après la stratégie bien connue de la
terre brûlée le droit exige le
rapatriement des centaines de milliers
d'Ukrainiens déportés en Russie dont
plusieurs milliers d'enfants exposés à
des adoptions forcées
le droit oblige à regarder en face les
charniers les salles de torture les
exécutions sommaire et les viols que
subissent les populations des zones
occupées et mettre les mots sur ces
faits enivrant à l'éprouvante
documentation des crimes de guerre et
des crimes de l'humanité le droit
commande que c'est bourreaux soient
traduits devant les tribunaux
le droit ne connaît j'insiste mais chers
collègues que les frontières
internationalement reconnues de
l'Ukraine celle de 1991 et aucun et en
aucun cas les référendums potamines qui
viennent de se dérouler la moindre
ambiguïté sur ce point laisserai planer
l'ombre de l'abandon de millions de
personnes dans ces zones de non-droit
aux mains de leur bureau le don-basse
c'est l'Ukraine la Crimée c'est
l'Ukraine
le droit c'est l'interdiction de
collaborer de quelques manières que ce
soit avec le régime criminel russe et de
soutenir même indirectement son effort
de guerre c'est la raison pour laquelle
est députés socialiste déposeront un
amendement pour que soit saisi et verser
à l'Ukraine les dividendes et autres
gains que les entreprises auraient
obtenu en demeurant en Russie
c'est la raison pour laquelle Eutelsat
doit cesser de diffuser les chaînes
russes en dehors de l'Europe c'est la
raison pour laquelle totale énergie qui
a continué d'exploiter des hydrocarbures
au risque de fournir même indirectement
des moyens à l'aviation russe qui
bombarde à Mario Paul doit quitter la
Russie et ne serait sans état d'âme
recevoir les 440 millions d'euros de
dividendes pour le premier semestre 2022
de sa participation dans Novatech
le droit c'est légitime défense du
peuple ukrainien des démocraties ont le
devoir de s'engager à leur côté en
livrant des armes la France l'a fait
elle doit plus encore continuer de le
faire nous appelons madame la Première
ministre tous les députés républicains à
rester unis pour convaincre nos
compatriotes de la nécessité des efforts
accomplis et des efforts à venir le
débat aujourd'hui était nécessaire il
convient de le prolonger et d'offrir un
autre assemblée nationale la possibilité
de s'unir dans une religion de soutien à
l'Ukraine net et la plus large possible
c'est le sens de la résolution que les
socialistes déposent aujourd'hui je vous
le dis à chaque fois qu'il en ira de la
liberté et du droit le gouvernement nous
trouvera à ses côtés
oui les démocraties doivent gagner cette
guerre par le rétablissement du droit et
de la souveraineté ukrainienne ce n'est
qu'à cette condition qu'il y aura un
jour nouveau pour le peuple ukrainien
pour les peuples d'Europe et pour le
peuple russe je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Laurent Marc
angélique pour le groupe horizon
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
avec la déclaration de guerre de la
Fédération de Russie à l'Ukraine et la
violation de son territoire par l'armée
russe
le 24 février dernier
l'impensable est revenu en Europe
par cet acte la Russie a enfin toutes
les règles du droit international et
bafouer les valeurs de paix et de
liberté sur lesquelles le continent
européen a construit son équilibre
depuis plusieurs décennies
depuis ce 24 février le peuple ukrainien
se bat sans relâche pour préserver son
indépendance et sa démocratie les forces
ukrainiennes ont ardemment résisté
privant les autorités russes d'une
victoire rapide le courage des
Ukrainiens force le respect l'objectif
de la prise de Kiev a été abandonné et
l'armée russe a été contrainte de se
regrouper vers l'Est et le Sud du pays
la récente contre-offensive ukrainienne
dans les régions de carquif et Kerson a
permis la reprise d'une part importante
du territoire
si le peuple ukrainien peut espérer et
entrevoir un avenir de paix préservant
sa démocratie et son indépendance c'est
aussi grâce à l'action résolue de la
France de son président et des Européens
oui dès le début du conflit nous avons
fait preuve de fermeté
et nous avons réaffirmé des valeurs nos
valeurs
nous avons agi avec fermeté face aux
mensonges du pouvoir russe et ses
menaces contre la sécurité
internationale nous avons montré que nos
institutions étaient fortes et pouvaient
réagir rapidement
par une résolution de la semblée
générale des Nations unies une large
majorité des pays du monde à un effet
condamné l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la
Russie dès le début du conflit l'Ukraine
a pu bénéficier d'une aide financière
militaire et humanitaire
nous avons aussi réaffirmé nos valeurs
elles ont d'ailleurs été rappelées à la
communauté internationale par le
Président de la République lui-même lors
de son allocution aux Nations Unies le
20 septembre dernier un ordre
international fondé sur la défense des
droits humains un respect de la
souveraineté de chacun et une
coopération renforcée tels sont les
principes fondateurs du système
multilatéral seul garant de la paix
le président de la République a
également réaffirmé lors de cette
intervention de choix diplomatique
partagé avec nos partenaires européens
mettre fin à la guerre sans devenir
belligérant
mettre fin à la guerre pour le peuple
crânien nous devons au peuple craignant
de mettre face à cette guerre et à cette
crise humanitaire aux conséquences
dramatiques de nombreuses
infrastructures ont été touchées et les
bombardements des zones de conflits font
constamment de nouvelles victimes déjà
plus de 5000 civils femmes hommes et
enfants ont été tués arrachés à leur
famille et à leurs proches les exactions
sont nombreuses les images du massacre
de boucha le bombardement d'une
maternité à Mario Paul la découverte de
fosses communes aux abords d'izum
ravivent les heures les plus sombres de
notre histoire toute la lumière devra
être faite sur ses crimes en particulier
dans le cadre de l'enquête ouverte par
la Cour pénale internationale
mettre fin à la guerre c'est aussi un
gage de stabilité pour notre continent à
cet égard le discours du président russe
vendredi au ton messianique et
violemment antioxydantal nous démontre
qui ne reculera malheureusement devant
rien pour autant nous devons pas être
des belligérants le peuple russe ne nous
le pardonnerait pas nous ne pouvons
entrer en guerre contre un peuple
victime d'un régime autoritaire qui
l'isole du reste du monde et le mobilise
de force dans un conflit d'un autre
temps il est primordial comme tente de
le faire la France de poursuivre le
dialogue avec la Russie il s'agit là
d'une condition essentielle pour établir
durablement la paix sur le continent
européen
ma conviction est la suivante refuser la
belligérance ne nous condamne nullement
à l'impuissance avec ses partenaires
européens la France a imposé à la Russie
de multiples sanctions et ses sanctions
sont efficaces elles ont en effet privé
le régime de ressources majeures pour
financer et approvisionner ses efforts
de guerre les importations de la Russie
ont chuté des composants essentiels de
son industrie d'armement sont manquantes
son matériel militaire est devenu
défectueux souvent à l'abandon au bord
des routes sur le front
j'entends dire ici ou là que ces
sanctions seraient plus dur à porter
pour nous que pour les Russes
s'agit là d'un mensonge malheureusement
répandu au moyen de campagne de
désinformation successives non seulement
ces sanctions fonctionnent à l'endroit
du régime russe mais en plus leur effet
sur l'économie française reste marginale
d'une part parce que la crise
alimentaire est économique que nous
subissons n'est pas due au seul fait de
la guerre en Ukraine et de ses
conséquences d'autre part parce que les
promesses du Président de la République
pour protéger le pouvoir d'achat des
Français ont été tenus
outre leurs mensonges les autorités
russes et leur relais médiatique
entretiennent un climat de terreur par
des chantages abjects sur notre
souveraineté et notre sécurité
collective chantage énergétique d'abord
jouant avec la dépendance des pays
européens au gaz russe chantage
alimentaire ensuite les blocus en mer
noirs ont durablement impacté les
marchés céréaliers mondiaux aggravant la
crise alimentaire en Afrique où la
France est directement engagée dans des
opérations de stabilisation et de
développement
chantage nucléaire enfin alors qu'un
régime acculée n'a d'autres solutions
que de rappeler au monde sa capacité
destructrice ultime
nous aurons toujours à cœur d’écouter de
comprendre et de répondre aux
préoccupations des Français mais face au
chantage des autorités russes il ne faut
pas céder et nous ne céderons pas ni au
chantage énergétique ni au chantage
alimentaire encore moins au chantage
nucléaire
pour autant et je le répète notre combat
né et ne doit jamais être dirigé contre
le peuple russe c'est avant tout un
combat pour pour protéger des valeurs
démocratiques jusqu'au bord de l'Europe
pour garantir notre indépendance
énergétique et alimentaire pour défendre
notre sécurité et construire notre
autonomie stratégique trop souvent nos
valeurs démocratiques notre attachement
aux libertés publiques au droit de
l'homme sont mises en danger par ceux
qui veulent les faire passer pour des
marques de faiblesse à cela nous disons
que les démocraties sont fortes et
qu'elles sont capables de surmonter les
crises mes chers collègues il nous faut
donc encore faire preuve de fermeté
restez ferme sur nos valeurs c'est
savoir dire non aux alliances de
circonstances avec les démagogues de
tout bord au sein de l'Union européenne
où le populisme gagne chaque jour un peu
plus de terrain restons aussi
inflexibles que déterminés alors que
beaucoup pensent trouver leur salut dans
les extrêmes rappelons-nous de la place
que l'histoire accordent aux dirigeants
qui oppriment leur peuple
cette fermeté doit s'accompagner de
lucidité sans arrogance la démocratie ne
se décrète pas il ne s'impose elle reste
hélas parfois un régime d'exception en
témoigne le refus de certains pays qui
comptabilisent la majorité de la
population mondiale de condamner
clairement l'agression de l'Ukraine
l'engagement sans fin des ukrainien pour
leur démocratie doit être un espoir et
une source d'inspiration pour tous les
peuples mais c'est aussi la preuve que
ce monde plus ouvert et plus libre
auquel nous croyons n'a rien d'évident
madame la Première ministre nous vivons
des situations de vertige face à eux la
voie tracée par la France et la bonne et
la seule voie possible vous pouvez
compter sur le groupe que j'ai l'honneur
de présider comme vous pouvez compter
sur l'ensemble des députés élus attaché
à la démocratie à la liberté à celle de
nos enfants car nous savons désormais
que la liberté n'est plus anakie elle
est plus que jamais un combat
un combat de chaque instant ce qui se
joue donc en Ukraine est essentiel nous
ne voulons pas la guerre avec la Russie
mais ne nous pouvons pas la laisser
gagner cette guerre l'Ukraine c'est la
France c'est la démocratie c'est la
liberté je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Aurélien taché
pour le groupe écologique
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues je
souhaite débuter mon intervention
hommage au peuple ukrainien qui fait
preuve d'un courage sans faille face à
la version russe qui a débuté le 24
février dernier et saluer la délégation
aujourd'hui présente pour assister au
débat de notre assemblée
le 21 septembre dernier le ministre
russe de la Défense a affirmé qu'il ne
combattait pas tant l'Ukraine que
l'Occident ce message très direct envoyé
aux Occidentaux ainsi que la nouvelle
loi sur la mobilisation partielle
décidée par Vladimir Poutine doivent
nous conduire à ne plus tergiverser sur
l'attitude que nous devons adopter
vis-à-vis du régime russe et des
sanctions que nous prenons contre lui
elle doit aussi nous conduire à un
profond questionnement sur notre
incapacité à trouver des alliés au sud
laissant ainsi l'opportunité au chef du
Kremlin de se présenter comme
l'hypothétique chef d'un axe non aligné
soudainement ressuscité en s'appuyant
notamment sur les échecs et manquements
de la France en Afrique mais a-t-on déjà
oublié que depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir
de Vladimir Poutine la Russie a en effet
cessé et peut-être y avons-nous une part
de responsabilité de s'éloigner des
idéaux démocratiques et de
l'inalliénable droit des peuples à
disposer de même elle s'affirme
désormais comme une autocratie
impérialiste fondant son pouvoir sur
l'expansion militaire au plan extérieur
et sur un nationalisme autoritaire
écrasant les opposants et les minorités
sur le plan intérieur dont l’invasion en
Ukraine n'est que le terrible et dernier
avatar
Poutine réalise ainsi les rêves les plus
fous de l'extrême droite russe et
notamment de l'idéologue Alexandre
doughin partisan d'une Eurasie qui
écraserait l'Orient comme l'Occident mes
chers collègues il ne s'arrêtera plus
aussi et sans nul doute l'appui
militaire apportée aux forces
ukrainiennes à fonctionner il convient
donc de poursuivre et renforcer cet
effort madame la Première ministre
monsieur le ministre des armées les
canons César attendus par les Ukrainiens
ainsi que de nouvelles défenses entières
aériennes à même de protéger les
populations les populations civiles des
bombardements doivent être livrées sans
plus attendre mais nous devons aussi
être beaucoup plus clair sur notre
positionnement quant à la présence des
entreprises françaises restantes en
Russie
notre économie ne doit pas devenir une
partie de l'arsenal du criminel de
guerre Vladimir Poutine au début de ce
conflit la France était le deuxième
investisseur étranger en Russie et les
entreprises françaises présentes sur ces
territoires se sont retrouvés confrontés
à un dilemme business où éthique profit
ou humanisme argent ou principe dès le
début du mois de mars Emmanuel Macron a
choisi je cite de laisser les
entreprises décider pour elle-même
une analyse récente de la kiffe School
of économics révèle que les entreprises
françaises emploie 123642 personnes en
Russie
si la position de libre choix laissée
par le Président de la République
française au début du conflit pouvait
déjà interroger elle n'est désormais
plus tenable l'appel à la mobilisation
partielle du 21 septembre nous oblige à
ouvrir les yeux sur le rôle que pourrait
désormais jouer ces plus de 123 000
salariés dans le conflit
que dit en effet la loi russe sur cette
mobilisation elle oblige toutes les
organisations y compris les entreprises
internationales à procéder à
l'enregistrement militaire du personnel
si au moins un des employés est
susceptible d'effectuer son service
militaire
elles doivent également aider à remettre
les convocations de l'armée à leurs
employés assurer la livraison
d'équipements au point de rassemblement
ou aux unités militaires et fournir
moyens et renseignements
madame la Première ministre cette
nouvelle donne doit nous conduire à
établir une position claire sur le sujet
la semaine dernière le collective le
collectif before Ukraine a lancé une
campagne accusant les sociétés
étrangères en Russie de participer à la
mobilisation criminelle du Kremlin en
aidant la conscription de soldats et à
l'équipement de l'armée nous ne pouvons
y rester insensible et la France doit
désormais être exemplaire dans ce
domaine fin août le président du Medef
Geoffroy route Bézieux prenait la
défense des entreprises françaises qui
ont choisi de maintenir des activités en
Russie affirmant que ce ne sont pas les
sanctions qui feront changer le régime
une étude de l'université de Yale parue
au début du mois d'août dément pourtant
ses allégations ainsi que celle de
toutes ceux notamment à l'extrême droite
de cette hémicycle qui affirme que les
sanctions économiques infligées à
Vladimir Poutine aurait en effet
contribué à la prospérité de l'économie
russe
pour nos entreprises la situation a donc
en effet radicalement changé les chances
de voir certains de leurs certains de
leurs salariés partir faire la guerre
pour leur pays et de nous mettre dans
une position nous participerions à
l'effort de guerre russe à travers la
collaboration que la loi de mobilisation
partielle impose à toutes les
entreprises internationales et
manifestent le journal nemonde nous en
effet récemment appris qu'une ancienne
française qu'une ancienne française du
sud de la Russie a vu partir 150 de ses
employés au front si on en croit cet
article aucune entreprise hexagonale
n'en revanche était sommet de fournir
matériel ou assistance à l'armée mais
cette possibilité est bien prévue par la
loi par la loi russe alors madame la
Première ministre qu'en sera-t-il demain
vous savez de plus qu'il est très
difficile d'obtenir des informations en
provenance de la Russie tant ce régime
impose une forme de terreur qui pourrait
aussi bien nous en toucher nos
entreprises présentent là-bas et que
c'est donc peut-être déjà le cas une
dernière question se pose pour nous
entreprises quelle attitude adopter avec
leurs employés binationaux il serait 200
à être inscrit sur les listes
consulaires si la loi interdit d'envoyer
au service militaires des hommes
naturels naturalisés de plus de 27
aucune restriction semblable n'existe
quant à la mobilisation avons-nous envie
aujourd'hui de retrouver dans les rangs
russes des soldats possédant la
nationalité française que se
passerait-il si les Russes venait à
considérer que les binationaux
travaillant dans les entreprises
françaises sont avant tout de la chair à
canon mobilisables pour leur entreprise
de destruction madame la Première
ministre cette nouvelle situation va
nous amener à réagir il est urgent de
faire un état des lieux précis des
entreprises exerçant toujours une
activité sur le sol russe et de pouvoir
connaître leur niveau de participation
volontaire ou non à la mobilisation
décrétée par Vladimir Poutine merci à
vous
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Paul Lecoq
pour le groupe Gauche démocrate et
républicaine
la première ministre madame monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
présidente de commission mes chers
collègues
quelle prise avons-nous aujourd'hui sur
le conflit en Ukraine si ce n'est par
notre responsabilité d'État membres
permanent du Conseil de sécurité des
Nations unies cette responsabilité nous
oblige face à cette résurgence de
l'impérialisme russe et face à cette
guerre de conquête guerre réactionnaire
par essence
il est de notre responsabilité
collective de lutter contre cette fuite
en avant de Poutine ensemble nous devons
arrêter ce torrent de violation du droit
international de crime de guerre voire
de crimes contre l'humanité
référendum dans les régions occupées
annexion de quatre régions ukrainiennes
menace d'une nucléarisation de la guerre
mobilisation partielle l'escalade se
confirme jour après jour avec le
sentiment que la diplomatie
internationale est un puissante et pour
cause le désordre des relations
internationales interrogent notre
capacité d'action surtout lorsque l'on
évoque la crédibilité des états dit
occidentaux et des alliés de l'OTAN
organisation sortie elle aussi d'un
autre âge au sein de notre communauté
internationale
comment entraîner une vague de
solidarité et de condamnation contre la
Russie lorsque les États-Unis la France
et d'autres ont passé 30 ans à mettre à
feu et à sang le Moyen-Orient et
l'Afrique prenant tant de liberté avec
le droit international la Libye la
Palestine l'Afghanistan l'Irak le Sahel
mais aussi le font monétaire
international la Banque mondiale
l'époque n'oublie pas les attaques les
reniements et les trahisons la géométrie
variable des engagements des pays riches
et le poison qui a détruit la confiance
des peuples dans les Nations Unies et
dans le droit international c'est la
raison pour laquelle on ne peut pas
s'étonner de la tiédeur du soutien
international notamment des pays les
plus fragiles aux résolutions proposées
par les États-Unis et leurs alliés sur
l'Ukraine les pays du Sud n'acceptent
plus de s'aligner systématiquement sur
une Bastille qui les observe du haut de
ses remparts le président français ne
semble pas l'avoir compris lui qui a
préféré accuser à la tribune des Nations
Unies la semaine dernière des
partenaires indispensables à la
recherche de la paix je le cite ceux qui
se taisent aujourd'hui servent malgré
eux et secrètement avec une certaine
complicité la cause d'un nouvel
impérialisme d'un cynisme contemporain
qui désagrège notre ordre international
sur lequel la paix n'est possible fin de
citation avec ses discours accusateurs
les mots ont perdu leur sens pour
beaucoup les termes comme démocratie et
d'humanitaire ou droits de l'homme
prononcé par le camp occidental ne
veulent plus rien dire ils ont trop
souvent été synonyme d'intervention
militaire ou financière
mais ne nous y trompons pas Vladimir
Poutine a compris cette faiblesse et
tente de créer un contrepoids en créant
une hégémonie reposant sur un
nationalisme exacerbé et sur la force
brute son ordre mondial est fondé sur
des valeurs de n de la démocratie de
mépris des peuples et de violation des
libertés élémentaires comme le droit du
travail et la liberté d'expression la
liberté de manifestation ou encore de la
presse
ces deux camps sont détestés par tous
les états qui observent ce triste
spectacle pendant que chez eux les
famines se multiplient la montée des
eaux menaces et les guerres nourries par
l'appétit du capital font rage en
silence car n'oublions pas toutes les
autres guerres actuelles le Sahel
Arménie le Congo Kinshasa le Sarah
occidental l'Éthiopie et j'en passe les
autorités et les médias les ignorent
comme elles n'impacte puisqu'elle
n'impacte pas la vie quotidienne des
Européens et des Français d'autres
débats ne sont-ils se sont-ils déjà
tenus dans cette hémicycle à propos de
guerre où nous nous sommes pas
directement belligérant quoique
cette guerre pose les questions de la
mondialisation de la souveraineté de
l'Europe et de la France à travers
l'énergie l'alimentation l'industrie et
le choc qu'elle crée dans notre société
est terrible mais il le sera d'autant
plus pour les plus précaires si nous
n'agissons pas pour agir il y a les
leviers des politiques publiques mon
groupe est la nupes dans son ensemble
seront là pour vous proposer des
amendements visant à améliorer le projet
de loi de finance en ce sens mais sans
obtenir la paix en Ukraine rien ne sera
possible et pour l'obtenir que peut
faire un pays membre permanent du
Conseil de sécurité des Nations unies
comme la France il faut prouver la
volonté de notre état à soutenir le camp
de la paix coûte que coûte et c'est là
que l'urgence réside pour cela madame la
ministre changer radicalement de
diplomatie
les députés du groupe de la Gauche
démocrate et républicaine ne cessent de
le dire pour allier les États membres
des Nations Unies contre la guerre en
Russie il faut retrouver l'humilité nous
devons plus être ce pays qui vend des
armes aux tortionnaires et obélixérant
pour des milliards d'euros par an ni
être ce pays disposant de l'arme
nucléaire et qui refusent comme les
autres de la démanteler définitivement
nous ne devons plus être non plus ce
pays qui donne des leçons à tout va
alors qu'il n'est pas capable de
respecter lui-même le droit
international sur son sol pensant à
l'île de Mayotte que la France a arraché
des Comores pour son propre intérêt en
violation de la Charte des Nations Unies
la France a encore un très grand travail
pour changer pour abandonner la course
aux intérêts économiques en prenant le
chemin de l'universalité du droit
car c'est le seul chemin à emprunter
pour retrouver une crédibilité et une
légitimité au sein du Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies et pour
gagner la paix il nous faut devenir ce
pays qui se tient aux côtés de tous les
peuples qui souffrent et qui et qui
combattent pour l'application de leurs
droits légitime alors souveraineté
territoriale le peuple ukrainien lutte
par les armes pour sa liberté et pour
préserver cette souveraineté comme c'est
autorisé par l'article 51 de la Charte
des Nations Unies qui dit il faut leur
rappeler ici qu'aucune disposition de la
prise en charge ne porte atteinte au
droit naturel de légitime défense
individuelle ou collective dans le cas
où un membre des Nations Unies à l'objet
d'une agression armée jusqu'à ce que le
Conseil de sécurité ait pris des mesures
nécessaires pour maintenir la paix et la
sécurité internationale
pour trouver la paix possible le courage
n'est donc pas militaire il doit être
diplomatique l'important c'est de poser
des jalons d'un dialogue comme cela
était le cas pour l'initiative
céréalières de la mer Noire grâce aux
Nations Unies depuis le premier août un
couloir a été aménagé dans la mer Noire
auprès après après des négociations avec
les belligérants entre les belligérants
plus d'une centaine de navires battant
pavillon nusiens qui transporte des
millions de tonnes de blés Ukrainiens
sont escortés par la marine russe pour
être déchargée notamment en Afrique de
l'Est ou la famine menace des dizaines
de millions de personnes cet exemple
d'optimisme réaliste a été pris par le
Secrétaire national le secrétaire
général pardon des Nations Unies lors de
son discours d'ouverture de l'Assemblée
générale des Nations unies il voulait
démontrer à travers cet exemple que des
solutions existent si les diplomaties
discutent même contre vents et marées
depuis 2014 et l'annexion de la Crimée
ukrainienne par la Russie le Parti
communiste français appelle à une
conférence européenne pour la paix et la
sécurité sous l'égide des Nations Unies
cette étape serait essentielle pour
repenser et apaiser les relations
internationales à l'est de l'Union
européenne et pour prendre en compte les
aspirations des peuples qu'ils soient
Ukrainiens polonais biélorus ou russe
l'Ukraine devra retrouver son territoire
souverain et un violet tandis que les
responsables russes au premier rang
desquels Vladimir Poutine devront payer
pour leurs crimes aucun peuple ne devra
payer l'addition de la victoire ou de la
défaite seuls les profits de guerre ou
qu'ils soient devront être
réquisitionnés pour financer la
reconstruction
cette paix juste respectera la
résistance héroïque du peuple ukrainien
qui meurt et qui souffre au quotidien
cette paix respectera le peuple russe
elle lui permettra d'en finir avec la
conscription et avec la terrible
répression du Kremlin sur son peuple le
groupe de la Gauche démocrate est
républicaine envoie sa totale solidarité
à ces femmes c'est à ces hommes qui
luttent de part et d'autre de la
frontière ukrainienne au péril de leur
vie pour voir cette situation se
terminer et qui tiennent tête par leur
bravoure au Kremlin de nombreux
militants de la paix en Ukraine et en
Russie risque leur vie pour témoigner de
ce qu'ils vivent ce sont eux qui
permettront une réconciliation entre les
peuples pour anéantir le risque d'un
éternel recommencement ce dont les
Français et les Allemands peuvent
témoigner
comme le dit le responsable du mouvement
pacifique ukrainien que peut-être vous
avez rencontré à l'occasion de vos
voyages je le cite mettre fin à la
guerre passe par la réconciliation
mettre en avant des valeurs de paix et
de justice un mouvement mondial pour la
paix pourraient changer cela en
préconisant un cesser le feu des ports
entre l'Est et l'Ouest ainsi qu'entre la
Russie et l'Ukraine le discours de paix
est souillé aujourd'hui les militants
anti-guerre et les objecteurs de
conscience au service militaire sont
persécutés mais aucun appétit pour la
gloire et les profits tirés de
l'effusion de sang ne changera le fait
que la paix et non la guerre est une
norme de la vie humaine fin de citation
il était bon de donner la parole au
pacifiste ukrainien je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Bertrand
pencher pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outre-mer et territoire
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres monsieur le Président cher
collègue au moment où nous débattons de
la guerre en Ukraine je voulais aussi
adresser au nom de mon groupe et plus
largement je le sais notre soutien aux
femmes iraniennes et aux hommes engagés
à leurs côtés pour lutter contre une
effroyable dictature islamiste en Iran
la France
la France ne pourra
la France ne pourra rester forte que si
elle continue à incarner son humanisme
et défendre les droits de l'homme et des
libertés partout dans le monde menacé y
compris comment Ukraine aux frontières
de l'Europe
depuis 222 jours le peuple ukrainien
résiste héroïquement à l'agression
unique de la Russie Poutine beaucoup
estimaient pourtant que le pays
tomberait en trois jours nourrit à plein
par la propagande russe renvoyant une
image de superpuissance de son armée de
ses dirigeants il n'en n'a rien été
cette résistance ukrainienne a
évidemment un coup humain d'abord
effroyable en Ukraine ou la Russie ça
donne à des massacres de civils et des
crimes de guerre tous les jours les
dirigeants russes devront rendre des
comptes
la guerre est également bien évidemment
un coût économique et social l'Ukraine
voit une bonne partie de ces
infrastructures totalement détruites une
chute drastique de ces productions et
des millions de réfugiés internes
externes pour faire face à cette crise
que nous demande les Ukrainiens
outre des armes lourdes pour pouvoir se
défendre de l'aide humanitaire et de
l'accueil dans les meilleures conditions
possibles des auxiliés sur notre sol les
Ukrainiens nous demandent face à leur
sacrifices des programmes d'aide à long
terme pour la reconstruction l'emploi le
logement la santé c'est bien la moindre
des choses ils ont besoin de dons plutôt
que de près pour éviter de laisser une
dette insurmontable à un pays victime
d'une agression barbare
l'armée russe et maintenant sur le
reculoir elle enchaîne les défaites et
Poutine multiplient les provocations et
menaces si la guerre a des répercussions
économiques jusqu'en France et dans le
monde cela ne doit pas nous détourner de
nos engagements encore moins maintenant
la propagande russe a voulu instiller le
poison de la division en France et en
Europe elle a fait en retournant la
responsabilité du déclenchement de la
guerre et ses conséquences sur le temps
et sur les gouvernements européens aux
Français qui se posent encore des
questions légitimes rappelons que le
coupable du déclenchement de cette
guerre et de ses répercussions c'est la
Russie le Poutine et elle seule et que
l'Ukraine ne défend pas seulement son
territoire mais aussi le modèle
occidental démocratique que Poutine
désormais annonce vouloir détruire le
combat des Ukrainiens c'est aussi notre
combat
raison de plus de faire également notre
autocritique sur un certain aveuglement
d'un large spectre de notre classe
politique française oui il y a bien eu
un aveuglement d'une certaine extrême
gauche qui par réflexe anti-américain
n'a jamais voulu voir la menace que le
dictateur russe au discours
authentiquement fasciste faisait peser
sur les fondamentaux démocratiques
européens oui les propos de l'extrême
droite ont été troublants on se demande
toujours comment peut-elle à ce point se
lever dans les bras d'un dirigeant
citron à vouloir détruire le monde
occidental si ce n'est par accointance
idéologique j'espère que le soutien de
Poutine d'une certaine partie de notre
classe politique et maintenant
clairement derrière nous
des patriotes ou des pseudos
révolutionnaires qui se soumettent à une
puissance étrangère qu'elle farce sans
ce sans parler de tous ceux qui pour
quelques prébendes allez en pèlerinage à
Moscou espérons que cela servira de
leçon face à la Chine de plus en plus
agressive et particulièrement face à
Taïwan
aveuglement enfin teinté de naïveté
parfois des services de l'État
reconnaissons le ou de responsables
politiques de tout bord et au plus haut
niveau qui n'ont pas su ou n'ont pas
voulu voir le danger que représentait la
Russie de Poutine et de l'imminence
d'une invasion de l'Ukraine nous étions
pourtant prévenus par les précédents de
la Georgie en 2008 et de la Crimée en
par pitié n’appelons plus à ne pas
humilier la Russie alors que
d'effroyable massacre de civils ont lieu
en Ukraine
une fois encore si le diagnostic de la
nécessité de l'Europe de la défense et
le bon force est de constater que la
volonté manque pour avancer plus vite il
faut que l'Europe accélère car une fois
de plus cette guerre démontre que nous
ne pouvons pas nous passer de
l'intervention des États-Unis
Vladimir Poutine est dans une offensive
de propagande au long cours pour
déstabiliser nos sociétés en l'aidant en
s'aidant de notre dépendance énergétique
et des effets sur l'inflation il joue la
division de nos opinions publiques ne
cédons pas la pression russe et assez
relais en France continuons à livrer
davantage d'équipements militaires
affirmant que le soutien de l'Ukraine et
le soutien au foyer et aux entreprises
françaises sont compatibles et ne
doivent pas être opposés restons ferme
sur nos Fondements de solidarité de
liberté quelles leçons d'héroïsme et de
bravoure sont en train de nous donner
nos amis Ukrainiens à leur place
pourrions-nous faire vive l'Ukraine
libre pour toujours vive l'Europe
l'Europe de plus en plus fort et vive la
France
la parole est à Madame Aurore berger
pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues mon
premier mot s'adresse aux ukrainiennes
et aux Ukrainiens attaqués blessé violet
et tuer le 24 février dernier Vladimir
Poutine et son gouvernement ont décidé
seuls et délibérément de violer la
Charte des Nations Unies et d'attaquer
un pays libre et souverain
désormais ils prétendait de force aux
dépensier de l'Ukraine nous le disons
ici clairement nous ne reconnaîtrons
jamais les résultats des référendums
d'annexion de quatre régions
ukrainiennes
c'est pour moi purement et simplement un
national
de l'idée de nation
depuis le début le peuple ukrainien se
bat courausement pour son intégrité sa
liberté et son identité dans ce combat
ce n'est pas seulement leur terre qu'ils
défendent ce sont nos valeurs celle de
l'Union européenne de paix de liberté et
du droit des peuples à disposer
d'eux-mêmes ce sont ces valeurs que le
régime de Poutine veut réprimer
mais contrairement à 2014 contrairement
à l'annexion de la Crimée l'Union
européenne a su répondre de façon forte
et unanime face à l'agression prémédité
de la Russie
sous la présidence française de l'Union
européenne nous avons adopté un paquet
de sanctions économiques politique et
financière d'une ampleur inédite notre
président a supporté l'idée de
l'autonomie stratégique européenne nous
avons exprimé sans ambiguïté notre
soutien à l'Ukraine et soutenu son
effort de guerre par des mesures
économiques et des livraisons militaires
conséquentes nous avons accueilli vous
l'avez souligné madame la Première
ministre de manière solidaire en
cohérence avec nos valeurs et dans le
respect de la convention de Genève les
réfugiés de guerre ukrainien affirmons
le cette solidarité avec le peuple
ukrainien c'est l'honneur de la France
nous refusons nous refusons de croiser
les bras devant l'impérialisme russe
désormais certains et nous les entendons
jusque dans cette émission appel à
remettre en cause ses sanctions affirme
qu'elle serait inutile et voudrait ainsi
que l'invasion d'un État souverain et la
mort de milliers de personnes restent
sans conséquence
en sanctionnant la Russie nous
affaiblissons son économie et donc son
effort de guerre le PIB russe est ainsi
d'ores et déjà en récession et la Russie
ne peut plus importer de technologie
pour ces industries ou emprunter sur les
marchés à ceux qui se font le relais de
sa propagande je pose donc la question
si ces sanctions étaient si inefficaces
pourquoi Poutine chercherait-il
désespérément à les faire lever
oui certains ici jouent avec les peurs
de nos concitoyens il trouve alors des
solutions toutes faites considèrent que
la crise que nous vivons serait la
responsabilité de la France et de
l'Europe parce qu'elles ont choisi de
défendre la liberté du peuple ukrainien
et donc nos valeurs la Russie nous
combat sans pudeur en déployant sa
propagande dans les médias et sur les
réseaux sociaux en planifiant des
cyberattaques sur nos installations en
s'attaquant à notre sécurité alimentaire
au prix de l'énergie à la sécurité
nucléaire et c'est donc nous qui serions
les coupables à celles et ceux qui
accament sans cesse l'Union européenne
envoyé plutôt vos doléances au Kremlin
par les directement à vos créanciers
les fesses sont là les fesses sont
documentées illustrées précis
incontestable c'est en Ukraine que les
villes se font détruire à coup de
mortiers Mario Paul en est le triste
symbole c'est en Ukraine que défaire le
des soldats russes avez-vous vu des
troupes ukrainiennes en Russie c'est en
territoire ukrainien que sont dénoncés
chaque jour des exactions de l'armée
russe allant de l'exécution sommaire au
viol ou à la torture et c'est un
territoire ukrainien que l'on déterre
dans des chartiers des dizaines de corps
humain
remettre en cause l'existence de ces
crimes c'est du négationnisme les
autorités russes auront à répondre tôt
ou tard de ces crimes de guerre
il n'y a pas si longtemps encore d'une
extrême part à l'autre de cette émission
on entendait vanter le modèle politique
russe
quel modèle que celui où la population
est embrigadée de force pour une guerre
à laquelle elle s'oppose quel modèle que
celui qui organise des référendums
fantoche pour annexer des terres et des
peuples contre leur gré quel modèle que
celui qui emprisonne qui réprime qui
élimine toute forme de protestation
quelle parodie de démocratie c'est
peut-être votre modèle mais ce n'est
certainement pas le nôtre
vous pouvez continuer à fermer les yeux
et vous boucher les oreilles mais si les
Français ne sont pas en guerre sauf
conflit nous touche dans notre économie
et notre quotidien et pour ceux qui dans
cette émission disent que nous ne
protégeons pas les français des impacts
économiques de la guerre je vous pose la
question qui prolonge les tarifs
réglementés de l'électricité pas vous
qui a versé à des millions de ménages un
chèque énergie pas vous qui a voté la
loi pour la protection du pouvoir
d'achat pas vous alors oui la guerre a
des conséquences mais notre majorité et
le gouvernement sont mobilisés depuis le
début pour y répondre et continueront à
le faire aussi longtemps que nécessaire
nous le disons
nous le disons haut et fort nous ne
céderons jamais ni au chantage ni à la
menace de Poutine et pour ceux qui
continuent encore et toujours de se
gargariser devant son régime je les
invite à se rappeler du premier mot de
notre devise nationale car oui mesdames
et messieurs les députés la liberté
n'est pas en 20 mots que son contente
d'invoquer dans les meetings c'est un
principe à faire vivre et qu'il faut
défendre quand il est en péril c'est
tout le sens du soutien que la France
apporte à l'Ukraine et à son peuple
depuis le 1er jour de la guerre un
soutien sur lequel notre groupe n'a
jamais eu et n'aura jamais la moindre
ambiguïté je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Jérôme buisson pour le rassemblement
national
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues le 24
février dernier Vladimir Poutine a
engagé la Russie dans une guerre
d'agression contre son voisin ukrainien
une nouvelle phase de ce conflit c'est
ouvert le vendredi 30 septembre avec
l'annexion illégale des régions de
Kerson
zapporodia doniesk et Lougansk la plus
grande annexion de territoires en Europe
depuis 1945
le rassemblement national condamne cette
annexion résultant de scrutin ne
correspondant pas aux standard
démocratique les plus élémentaires et
organisés en zone de guerre
le droit des peuples a disposer de même
ne doit en aucun cas se transformer en
armes politique au militaire toute notre
solidarité va au peuple ukrainien nous
réaffirmons notre attachement au respect
des règles qui doivent régir le concert
des nations depuis la chute du mur de
Berlin d'aucun pensait que l'histoire
était finie contrairement au
rassemblement national qui a toujours
fait preuve de réalisme politique
celle-ci revient en portant dans cette
tumulte la naïveté des élites
européennes ne pensant qu'en terme
d'accord de libre-échange d'ouverture à
la concurrence et chérissant un
multilatéralisme ba sous protection
américaine
le monde se conjugue en rapport de force
et non pas en accord Bruxelles lois
nous avons eu tort d'oublier l'adage
romain CIVIS paquet Parabellum car à la
mesure de notre impréparation la guerre
est aujourd'hui à nos portes
cette crise n'est pas conjoncturelle
elle est structurelle ce sont 30 ans
d'un curry de nos politiques de défense
diplomatiques énergétique économique et
budgétaire qui en sont à l'origine tout
d'abord un curry politique
incurie de nos politiques de défense
cela fait des années que le
rassemblement national n'a eu de cesse
d'alerter les gouvernements sur la
faiblesse des moyens alloués à notre
défense Marine Le Pen dans son projet
présidentiel proposé de porter le budget
de la défense à 55 milliards d'euros en
2027 permettant ainsi à notre pays
d'être prêt en cas de conflit de haute
intensité et d'affirmer son statut de
puissance mondiale
enfin une prise de conscience tardive
apparaît dans le projet de loi de
finances avec une augmentation du budget
de nos armées qui restent insuffisantes
pour que la France et les moyens de sa
défense un curry diplomatique aussi
Marine Le Pen a toujours soutenu les
initiatives diplomatiques de d'Emmanuel
Macron car elle correspondait à
l'intérêt national malgré les appels
incessants du président de la République
la voix de la France ne porte plus notre
position de puissance d'équilibre est
sans cesse remise en cause nos alliés
polonais et baltes ne nous font plus
confiance les Russes traitent
directement du destin de l'Europe avec
les Américains nous sommes marginalisés
au sein de l'Alliance occidentale les
initiatives diplomatiques sont désormais
sous-traités à la Turquie et à la Chine
c'est pourquoi le rassemblement national
a toujours revendiqué la place
singulière de la France dans le concert
des nations proche de nos alliés mais
non alignés nous laissant libre de
proposer une autre voie pour la paix
un curry énergétique surtout votre
gouvernement après avoir mené une
politique antinucléaire et contraint et
forcé de retrouver la raison
rattrapé par le réel vous êtes bien
obligé de reconnaître que la politique
de développement de notre parc nucléaire
défendu par Marine Le Pen et vitale
Emmanuel Macron a fermé ce Fessenheim
sous la pression de l'Allemagne mais il
reste muet face à la Belgique qui ferme
encore aujourd'hui ses réacteurs
nucléaires une baisse massive de la
production d'électricité belge mais en
danger l'ensemble du système électrique
européen déjà fragile un réseau
interconnecté européen implique une
coordination l'Europe a consciemment
affaibli le modèle français au lieu de
son inspirer si la France fait preuve de
solidarité avec ses voisins
n'acceptons pas de nous tirer une balle
dans le pied au nom des obsessions
d'idéologues antinucléaires
l'incurie économique parlons-en une
politique mondialiste nous a conduit à
perdre notre souveraineté après trois
décennies de désindustrialisation de la
France la Russie est le premier
producteur mondial de matière première
et la Chine et l'usine du monde la
France en est dépendantes la
réindustrialisation et la relocalisation
des productions est indispensable à
toute politique de puissance la guerre
en Ukraine est un révélateur
supplémentaire de la nécessité d'un
patriotisme économique les Français
l'attendent le rassemblement national le
défend le localisme est un
protectionnisme naturel qui permet de
défendre notre tissu industriel et
économique
un curry budgétaire enfin votre
gouvernement présente un budget 2023
lourdement déficitaire creusant la dette
de notre pays qui devrait atteindre les
3000 milliards d'euros notre autonomie
financière on est durement touché et
nous mettre à la merci de la montée des
taux d'intérêt de la dette française un
phénomène que nous ne contrôlons pas
face à la guerre et à la crise
financière qui arrive les seules
solutions que vous nous proposez c'est
de baisser le chauffage et de mettre des
cols roulés
s'il est légitimes de sanctionner la
Russie il faut agir avec efficacité et
responsabilité jamais au détriment des
français tel est notre rôle le
rassemblement national défend les
sanctions ciblées sur les oligarques et
sur les exportations de bien utiliser
par l'industrie de l'armement russe
comme les semi-conducteurs elle
entravent la capacité de production
militaire de la Russie ces sanctions
fonctionnent en revanche nous ne voulons
pas de sanctions contre les Français
nous avions exprimé nos réserves sur les
sanctions énergétiques et encore une
fois nous avions raison la simple
annonce des sanctions sur l'énergie ont
provoqué une hausse du cours des
hydrocarbures permettant même à la
Russie d'augmenter ses bénéfices
ces sanctions sont contre-productives et
vous voudriez continuer avec des
sanctions sur le gaz ne l'oublions pas
ces matières premières sont
indispensables à l'industrie à
l'économie européenne le travail les
transports le chauffage des Français en
dépendent nous voyons tous le coût de
l'énergie augmentée dans des proportions
irraisonnables les chèques énergie ne
résoudront pas la crise cela reportera
de quelques semaines le problème mais à
quel coût mais surtout ce sont les
entreprises qui sont en danger dépend
entier de notre économie sont menacés
sidérurgie metallurgie agriculture
industrie du verre pour densité que
quelques-uns les prix de l'électricité
ou du gaz deviennent si prohibitifs que
vous obligerez les usines à fermer cet
hiver tandis que d'autres risquent de
voir leur électricité coupée pour
soulager un réseau en extrême tension
pour la septième puissance économique du
monde quelle réussite
madame la Première ministre comme vous
le savez déjà cette problématique
énergétique hypothèque toute velléité de
ressuscité notre appareil industriel le
marché européen de l'électricité est
encore une fois un mécanisme qui
pénalise la France et annule l'avantage
comparatif de notre parc nucléaire nous
députés du rassemblement national si
nous soutenons le peuple ukrainien dans
sa défense contre l'invasion russe nous
nous faisons l'écho de l'inquiétude
grandissante des Français qui demain ne
pourraient peut-être plus se chauffer
risque de voir leur entreprise mettre la
clé sous la porte ou encore perdre leur
emploi à cet égard nous ne pouvons que
regretter que la France et l'Union
européenne se soient engagée dans une
guerre gaziaire contre la Russie sans
avoir au préalable sécurisé des
approvisionnements en hydrocarbures à
des prix convenables notamment auprès
des États-Unis
par contre cela ne vous pose pas
problème d'acheter du gaz à
l'Azerbaïdjan un des pays les plus
corrompus du monde qui agresse l’arménie
dans notre indifférence
notre présidente Marine Le Pen proposait
des mécanismes pour maintenir bas les
prix des matières premières et vraiment
sanctionner les tarus et ainsi aider le
peuple craignant je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
la parole est à Madame Mathilde panot
pour le groupe la France insoumise
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre collègue
222 jours de trop
222 jours de trop au terme duquel nous
mesurons provisoirement le désastre le
jeudi 24 février 2022 à 5h30 du matin
sur ordre du gouvernement de Vladimir
Poutine la Russie envahissait l'Ukraine
faisant basculer l'histoire de notre
vieux continent depuis ce jour les
horreurs de la guerre ne cessent de
retentir jusqu'à nous de la ville de
Bucha théâtre d'un massacre où il y a
quelques mois encore des familles avec
leurs enfants enjambées des corps de
civils gisant sur le sol aux
bombardement d'un hôpital et d'une
maternité à Mario Paul en passant par
rizum ville devenu un immense cimetière
dans lequel plusieurs centaines de
sépultures de civils ont été découvertes
quand les vivants survivent à l'heure où
nous parlons sans sans gaz sans
électricité depuis plus de six mois les
dépêches successives nous parviennent
rendent compte de l'état des combats en
même temps qu'elle trace une géographie
funeste alors que l'humanité a donné à
voir la plus cruelle version d'elle-même
nous formons ce vœu que ces crimes de
guerre soient jugés et punies la semaine
dernière
Vladimir Poutine faisait le choix de
l'escalade précipitant un peu plus
l'humanité au seuil d'une guerre totale
pour justifier l'annexion des
territoires du don-basse son
gouvernement a organisé des référendums
illégaux Vladimir Poutine a déclaré la
mobilisation partielle de sa population
il a brandit la menace nucléaire pour
couvrir sa guerre d'agression nous le
disons avec force ces décisions sont des
provocations inacceptables la communauté
internationale doit faire bloc pour
refuser le chantage nucléaire et
s'abstenir de faciliter l'engrenage
lorsque l'on fait primer la force brute
et la terreur nucléaire
ni la paix ni la sécurité internationale
ne sont garanties pour les puissances
nucléaires seule la négociation peut
permettre de sortir de l'impasse de la
guerre totale celle-ci a d'autant plus
de chances d'aboutir si le peuple russe
refuse son enrôlement dans une guerre
illégale notre groupe parlementaire la
France insoumise nupaise salut la
résistance de celles et ceux qui avaient
courage manifeste contre la décision de
guerre de leur pays
les foyers de contestation qui se
forment en Russie doivent nous rappeler
une chose nous ne confondons pas le
peuple russe avec le gouvernement de
Vladimir Poutine le rôle de la France
dans cette crise est devrait aux côtés
de l'Ukraine pour le respect bike du
droit international la protection des
civils et le retour de la paix dans cet
objectif la poursuite du dialogue avec
la Russie était nécessaire le rôle de la
France est également d'alerter pour
éviter qu'une tragédie ne s'ajoute à la
souffrance le 4 mars dernier des Tyrus
frappaient la centrale nucléaire de
zaporigia
nous alertons depuis des mois sur le
risque que les centrales nucléaires
deviennent des cibles de cette guerre et
Jean-Luc Mélenchon appelait dès mars
2022 à l'envoi de casque bleu pour
sécuriser les centrales ukrainiennes la
catastrophe dans la catastrophe c'est
également la prise pour cible des
conditions même d'habitude du territoire
ukrainien les attaques contre des dépôts
pétroliers le désastre industriel de
louange qu'en avril ou 4 tonnes d'acides
nitrique ont été déversés la
contamination de l'eau et des sols
mettent en péril la santé humaine des
Ukrainiens sur plusieurs générations la
guerre produit aussi un effet d'aubaine
pour des oligares qui se positionnent
sur de grands projets industriels nous
joignons notre voie à celle de la
résistance ukrainienne qui refuse que la
guerre soit un prétexte à la prédation
sur leurs ressources naturelles pour
finir notre groupe encourage à ce que
tous les moyens de la diplomatie soient
mis en oeuvre afin d'éviter l'escalade
le seul chemin rationnel est celui de la
paix madame la Première ministre je le
réaffirme ici pour en groupe la France
sonnerait à organiser à accueillir une
conférence pour la sécurité et la
négociation d'un plan de paix et de
garantie mutuelle
telle sont les pistes prioritaires que
nous identifions mais puisque ce débat
porte également sur les conséquences de
la guerre en Ukraine sur la France il
nous faut alors redoubler de rigueur qui
compte affirmerait que la guerre en
Ukraine serait l'unique source de la
situation économique que nous
connaissons dans le pays s'exposerait au
mensonges au commencement la pandémie de
covid-19 disloquait les chaînes
d'interdépendance et des organisé les
chaînes de production mondialisées la
distorsion du marché entraînait une
folie spéculative et l'explosion des
prix la guerre en Ukraine a fait
cachever ce chaos pour prendre seulement
l'exemple de la crise énergétique
celle-ci a pour origine un choc gazier
d'abord européen puis un choc
d'électricité lié à l'organisation de
notre marché européen les sanctions
contre la Russie ont même aggravé la
hausse des prix des hydrocarbures et
permis à la Russie de voir ses bénéfices
commerciaux exploser cette année dans ce
contexte
comment ne pas s'interroger sur leur
pertinence quelle est l'efficacité des
sanctions quand elles échappent à leur
cible et se retournent contre nous notre
cible et le régime de l'oligarchie russe
cette certitude doit nous servir de
principe d'action pour frapper le
système en son cœur madame la première
minute en toute circonstances et ne vous
en déplaise la faillite du marché de
l'énergie avec commencé avant la guerre
en Ukraine ces conséquences sont vécues
de plein fouet par les Français en un an
les prix du gros de l'électricité sur le
marché européen ont été multipliés par
10 et les prix du gaz par vin
concrètement les factures des Françaises
et Français augmenteront en moyenne de
200 à 300 euros par an alors lorsque
Emmanuel Macron évoque la fin de
l'abondance au sujet des bouleversements
énergétiques comment ne pas voir
l'impréparation flagrante dont votre
gouvernement a été coupable
cela fait plusieurs mois que RTE vous
alerte dans le vide sur la sécurité de
notre approvisionnement en énergie notre
dépendance à un parc nucléaire
vieillissant et à l'importation
d'énergie fossile ne date pas dire son
exposition a des problèmes de corrosion
est connu depuis janvier 2022 des avril
2022 des pays européens ont pris des
mesures l'Italie limite la température
dans les bâtiments publics interdit les
publicités lumineuses et réduit
l'éclairage nocturne l'Allemagne conçoit
un plan de sobriété et annonce la
nationalisation de son premier
producteur gazier tandis qu'en France
c'est seulement en juillet 2022 que le
mot sobriété affleure à la bouche du
président de la République madame la
Première ministre la situation
internationale ne serait destinée
d'elle-même un modèle d'action à suivre
ce que vous faites à chaque étape de la
période de chaos et de pénurie que nous
connaissons ce sont des choix politiques
la guerre en Ukraine ne peut servir
d'arguments commode pour dissimuler les
dysfonctionnements du marché et votre
allégeance la logique néolibérale qui la
guide baissez l'indemnisation des
chômeurs raboter les retraites refuser
d'augmenter les impôts sur les plus
riches fermez une d'oublier la
définition d'un super profit refusé de
taxer les profiteurs de crise d'une part
lancer un concours Lépine de la tenue
vestimentaire d'autres parts ce sont des
choix politiques ce sont les vôtres
ne nous faites pas croire qu'il n'était
pas possible de faire autrement faire
payer au précaire de ce pays votre
désinvolture à l'égard des poches les
plus remplies ne relève pas de la
nécessité notre groupe parlementaire n'a
cessé de plaider pour une taxe sur les
profiteurs de crise cette proposition
est désormais portée par un alliage
étonnant de représentants puisqu’après
la Commission européenne le rapporteur
de l'ONU le FMI c'est désormais le chef
économiste de la Banque centrale
européenne qu'ils ont qui joint sa voie
à la nôtre mais vous la refusez non vous
lui préférez votre générateur de demande
monsieur Bruno Le Maire qui enjoint
poliment les multinationales à
contribuer à hauteur de leurs moyens
vous applaudissez dès demain les miettes
distribuées par les uns et les autres
tandis que les PME et les TPE sont
étranglés par la hausse des prix et
contrainte de réduire leur production
votre isolement sur le sujet n'a d'égal
qu'un attachement absurde au mécanisme
de spéculation du marché les plus
insensés total énergie après avoir
dégagé un bénéfice net record de 16
milliards de dollars l'année dernière
s'apprête à distribuer un acompte sur
dividendes d'exceptionnels de 2,62
milliards d'euros à ses actionnaires
sont seuls mérite sur la période et de
tirer injustement profit d'une rente de
situations là encore vous aviez la
possibilité de tabler sur ce type de
marge juteuse pour bloquer les prix à la
baisse mais vous ne l'avez pas fait les
français payent leur café 15% plus cher
leurs potes 29% plus cher leur huile
137% plus cher mais vous vous retranchez
derrière l'inflation pour refuser
d'augmenter les salaires pourtant vous
savez que nous ne faisons pas face à une
boucle salaire prix mais une boucle
pénurie profit vous avez au moins le
mérite de la clarté ce sont les plus
pauvres qui paieront l'inflation et
c'est eux comme les 12 millions de
personnes en précarité énergétique que
vous exhorter à faire des petits
pourquoi la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale a proposé un
référendum d'initiative partagée visant
à taxer les super profits en croire
votre entêtement irresponsable seul le
recours à la démocratie serait de nature
à vous faire réviser vos priorités c'est
aussi pourquoi nous organons le 16
octobre prochain une marche contre la
vie chère l'inaction climatique et
contre la réforme des retraites marche à
laquelle nous invitons le plus grand
nombre à se rendre
j'achève sur ces mots
vous nous ne ferez jamais croire que vos
choix politiques sont le produit d'une
nécessité qui s'imposerait à vous la
guerre en Ukraine ne peut servir
d'arguments pour mener une guerre
sociale aux Français compter sur nous
pour montrer à chaque étape qu'une
alternative est possible
merci
la parole est à Monsieur Fabien Lainé
pour le groupe démocrate
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères cher
collègues
depuis la fin de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale nous pensions la guerre de
haute intensité inenvisageable sur le
sol européen mais la guerre que mène
aujourd'hui la Russie en Ukraine nous
ramène inexorablement à la réalité
la réalité d'un monde que nous avons
trop longtemps plus ou moins ignoré un
monde multipolaire aux intérêts de plus
en plus divergents un monde multipolaire
dans lequel se mêle hostilité et
affrontement entre état un nouvel ordre
mondial se dessine sous nos yeux parfois
contre nos peuples et en total
opposition aux valeurs humaniste
démocrate que nous Français défendons
une réalité qui nous oblige aujourd'hui
plus que jamais à privilégier le
multilatéralisme face à l'isolationnisme
cette perspective des relations
internationales et celles que la France
a toujours privilégié et que le groupe
démocrate considère plus que nécessaire
pour la sécurité des Nations
chers collègues le 24 février dernier
Vladimir Poutine a décidé de s'engager
dans une guerre illégale emportée par sa
volonté arbitraire de vouloir redessiner
les frontières il a autre passé toutes
les règles du droit international de
manière collective et immédiate les pays
membres de l'OTAN ceux de l'Union
européenne ont apporté leur soutien
militaire au peuple ukrainien dès lors
par l'intermédiaire de l'Alliance
atlantique la France a participé à ce
soutien et au renforcement défensif des
pays comme la Pologne la Roumanie et les
pays baltes qui redoutent les volontés
expansionnistes de la Russie la Suède et
la Finlande jusqu'à présent notre en
matière d'alliance militaire on rejoint
l'OTAN afin de s'inscrire notamment dans
l'obligation d'assistance des alliés au
cas où l'une ou l'autre ferait l'objet
d'une attaque russe
ces deux nouvelles adhésions à un moment
critique pour la sécurité européenne
marque tout non géopolitique avec un
nouveau paradigme sécuritaire notre
groupe salut les actions de l'OTAN et de
l'Union européenne car ces actions
confirment le rôle de garant de la paix
et de la sécurité la légitimité de
l'OTAN relativement décrit et ces
dernières années et renforcer la défense
commune européenne est relancée la
France doit aussi faire entendre sa voix
au sein de l'OTAN il jouait un rôle
actif dans la construction d'une
véritable défense européenne la
présidence française de l'Union
européenne a impulsé une dynamique
remarquée permettant à l'Europe de
poursuivre ses avancées significatives
vers une réelle autonomie stratégique
européenne en pleine complémentarité
avec le temps chers collègues la guerre
en Ukraine a mobilisé l'Union européenne
en soutien d'un peuple illégalement
agressé sur son territoire outre les
volets diplomatiques humanitaires
l'Europe a répondu présente sur un plan
militaire
ainsi un montant de 2 milliards d'euros
a été alloué afin d'aider les États
membres du lieu à fournir des
équipements militaires à l'Ukraine dans
l'ensemble des mesures d'assistance la
France a su apporter sa spécificité tout
d'abord et plus de 100 millions d'euros
de matériel militaires défensifs qui ont
été cédés gratuitement à l'Ukraine
ensuite notre pays a contribué avec des
formations en accompagnement de
l'équipement et de l'armement fourni la
France a cédée à Kief 18 canons César a
formé plus de 150 spécialistes
militaires Ukrainiens à l'utilisation de
ses obusiers notre groupe tient
d'ailleurs à saluer cette technologie
française
issue de notre butd qui comme nous le
voyons à une influence opérative nette
dans ce conflit l'Union européenne ne
prendra ainsi toute sa part dans la
formation à destination de l'armée
ukrainienne avec la mise en place d'une
mission d'assistance et de formation
européenne dans le cadre de ce projet la
France pourrait former les soldats
Ukrainiens directement sur le sol
polonais
chers collègues Vladimir Poutine a
choisi l'escalade militaire et
l'annexion forcée d'une partie de
l'Ukraine l'annexion d'un territoire
souverain notre groupe soutient
l'engagement de la France aux côtés du
peuple ukrainien et la ferme volonté du
gouvernement de rester inflexible face à
Vladimir Poutine face à l'autocrate du
kremelin à sa volonté arbitraire des
gemoni dans la région notre groupe est
resté mobilisé dans la poursuite de leur
action engagée par le Président de la
République en 2017 visa redonner de la
crédibilité à la France en matière de
défense en effet nous devons être prêt à
relever les défis de l'histoire qui se
dressent devant nous et l'AS à répondre
à des guerres de haute intensité de plus
en plus évolué dans leur fonctionnement
et de plus en plus global dans leur
effet et dans le répercussion en
conséquence il nous faut aujourd'hui
renouer avec l'idée de puissance afin de
rendre plus efficace et plus dissuasif
le multilatéralisme solidaire
indispensable au retour de la paix en
Ukraine et à partout dans le monde je
vous remercie merci beaucoup
la parole est à Madame Valérie rabot
pour le groupe socialiste
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères mes
chers collègues ce 3 octobre marque le
222e jour de l'agression russe en
Ukraine depuis 222 jours les Ukrainiens
vivent dans un pays en guerre depuis 222
jours ils vivent au gré des sirènes et
des alertes depuis 222 jours il
subissent bombardement et attaque depuis
222 jours ils vivent des horreurs des
viols de femmes d'enfants des tortures
des morts des blessés qui se comptent
par milliers l'enlèvement de plus de
6000 enfants
ukrainien vers la Russie des crimes de
guerre l'enfer de bout de chat Mario
Paul ou de Cardiff
en même temps que nous découvrons ces
horreurs nous prenons conscience du
courage incroyable du peuple ukrainien
qui s'est uni dans un esprit de
résistance hors norme
cette guerre nous l'avons modestement
approché la semaine dernière en nous
rendant à Kiev et à Cherif ville de 300
000 habitants attaqué dès le 24 février
pilonner et bombardé pendant tout le
mois de mars mais qui s'est libéré le 4
avril dernier au prix de multiples
souffrances
allez dans un pays en guerre est une
expérience qui marque
par les situations de détresse par les
destructions que l'on voit par les
regards qui disent parfois beaucoup plus
que des paroles par les silences qui
laissent entrevoir des horreurs qui
dépassent l'entendement humain
mes chers collègues derrière l'Ukraine
ce sont les principes fondateurs de
l'Europe de l'Union européenne elle-même
qui sont attaquées derrière l'Ukraine
avec le piétinement du mémorandum de
Budapest de 1994 c'est l'ordre mondial
qui est attaqué alors mes chers
collègues ne comment ne pas voir que
cette guerre est aussi la nôtre
il me semble que la seule question qui
se pose pour nous aujourd'hui serait
celle-ci la France en fait elle assez
pour soutenir l'Ukraine oui la France
est un soutien reconnu de nos amis
Ukrainiens que ce soit pour la livraison
d'armes ça a été dit et notamment des
canons César que ce soit pour l'accueil
de réfugiés que ce soit pour le soutien
financier que ce soit pour l'influence
décisive de notre pays pour les
sanctions décidées par l'Union
européenne contre la Russie ou encore
pour le vote le 1er juillet qui a permis
d’accorder à l'Ukraine le statut de pays
candidat à l'Union européenne que ce
soit pour les missions de police
scientifiques qui visent à déterminer si
des actes de torture ont été perpétrées
mais depuis quelques jours la situation
évolue de manière décisive d'un côté
nous voyons le recul de la ligne de
front avec la reprise par les Ukrainiens
de ville précédemment occupées par les
Russes comme isium ou Liman de l'autre
nous voyons une escalade une escalade le
monde d'un cran avec la menace de
l'utilisation d'armes nucléaires
l'enlèvement du directeur qui depuis a
été libéré la centrale nucléaire des
aporidja ou encore les conséquences de
pseudo référendum d'annexion des quatre
régions
ukrainiennesque face à ces menaces
madame la Première ministre nous pensons
que la France doit renforcer son soutien
à l'Ukraine nous l'avons écrit dans une
proposition de résolution qui a été
déposée ce jour nous pensons que la
France doit significativement augmenter
sa fourniture d'armes aujourd'hui
évaluée autour de 300 millions d'euros
nous demandons qu'à l'étendre sa
fourniture aux missiles solaires que
seuls cinq pays au monde ont la capacité
de fournir à l'Ukraine la livraison
d'armes aujourd'hui très majoritairement
assurée par les États-Unis il faut que
l'Europe monte au créneau beaucoup plus
et prennent sa part sinon elle ne sera
jamais un acteur crédible en matière de
géopolitique
la France doit augmenter son soutien
financier en cumulant ce qu'elle donne
en direct et ce qu'elle donne via
l'Union européenne on arrive à un
montant équivalent à 0,14 points de PIB
ce qui est moins que beaucoup d'autres
pays dans l'Union européenne la France
doit avoir une démarche très offensive
et proactive au sein des Nations unies
comme elle a su faire dans d'autres
conflits pour isoler encore plus la
Russie elle doit être déterminée pour
appliquer des sanctions exemplaires pour
tous les acteurs notamment les
entreprises qui permettraient à la
Russie de contourner les sanctions elle
doit par exemple exiger de telsat ça a
été dit tout à l'heure par Boris Vallot
l'arrêt de tout diffusion sur le
territoire des chaînes de télévision qui
ont fait l'objet d'une interdiction par
l'Union européenne au sein de l'Union
européenne elle doit être celle qui
prend des sanctions renforcées contre la
Russie
j'ai bien conscience que renforcer notre
soutien à l'Ukraine constitue un effort
et c'est un effort pour toute notre
nation en réalité cet effort mes chers
collègues nous le faisons pour
nous-mêmes pour ce que l'histoire dira
de nous face à cette guerre je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup
la parole est à présent Monsieur Hubert
Julien Laferrière pour le groupe
écologiste
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres sur
le président de la commission frères
étrangère mes chers collègues voilà de
déjà depuis plus de 7 mois que l'horreur
a resurgi à l'est de notre continent des
dizaines de milliers de pertes civiles
des millions de personnes contraintes à
l'exil des centaines de milliards
d'euros de dégâts matériels le bilan
c'était froidable guerre décidé par un
seul homme est évidemment une tragédie
pour l'Europe et pour le monde et la
mégalomanie du régime de Vallières
Poutine vient encore cela était bien sûr
rappelé de monter d'un cran avec les
référendums unilatéraux et illégaux dans
les quatre roblastes que l'est de l'Est
ukrainien une véritable mascarade qui ne
servira qu'à justifier l'occupation et
la violation de l'intégrité territoriale
de l'Ukraine que jamais nous ne
reconnaîtrons
je veux ici rendre hommage à tous les
formidables mouvements de solidarité qui
depuis le début du conflit se sont
organisés aux quatre coins du monde pour
aider la population
ukrainienne j'en ai moi-même été témoin
en mars dernier en me rendant à le vivre
en Ukraine ainsi que à l'est de la
Pologne au côté de ONG françaises mais
pas que françaises qui effectue sur
place un formidable travail de
mobilisation humanitaire médicale et
sociale et notre assemblée doit aussi
être en rendez-vous et je voudrais
saluer à mon tour madame la Présidente
votre initiative commune de coopération
avec le Parlement ukrainien à l'occasion
de votre déplacement du Crès de avec nos
collègues la France est aujourd'hui
active dans le soutien militaire à
l'Ukraine
nous devons également déjà penser à
préparer la paix et donc à la
reconstruction de ce pays meurtrier à la
notre pays avec l'Union européenne devra
participer vous l'avez dit madame la
Première ministre ce sujet n'est
évidemment pas prématuré un processus de
reconstruction qui devrait être inclusif
qui devra intégrer les sociétés civiles
ukrainiennes les mouvements sociaux les
syndicats Ukrainiens avec lesquels j'ai
changé il y a quelques jours en vision
conférence un processus qui devra
intégrer bien sûr les dimensions
sociales écologiques alors que la
situation autour de la centrale de
zaporigga fait courir le risque d'une
nouvelle catastrophe nucléaire
puisque vous nous invitez avec ce débat
à nous interroger sur les conséquences
de ce conflit pour notre pays et qu'il
besoin de rappeler les répercussions sur
notre sol et ce qu'il nous impose la
crise énergétique que nous connaissons
va fortement impacter nos concitoyens et
concitoyens cet hiver mais organiser la
sobriété énergétique rénovée nos
passoires énergétiques investir
massivement dans les énergies
renouvelables l'urgence climatique que
nous vivons nous l'impose depuis bien
avant ce conflit tragique et les
gouvernements précédents n'ont pour ceux
qui nous concerne en tout cas hélas
jamais su prendre la pleine mesure de la
situation nous espérons que cette fois
les actes seront au rendez-vous et la
représentation nationale aura très
bientôt l'occasion d'y veiller
nous interroger sur les conséquences du
conflit c'est également prendre la
mesure d'un danger qui a interroge la
gestion diplomatique française et
européenne de cette crise une question
qui a également évoqué Jean-Paul Le Coq
c'est pas encore le choc des
civilisations
d'une Clinton mais lorsqu'on Afrique on
s'en prend à la France et qu'on glorifie
la Russie quand en Amérique latine au
nom de l'anti impérialisme américain on
en vient à soutenir Poutine contre
l'agresseur américain et l'OTAN il y a
là je pense un sujet d'inquiétude majeur
en particulier mais pas seulement bien
sûr pour celle des pour ceux qui pour
qui les luttes anti impérialistes en
Amérique latine en particulier ont forgé
leur engagement politique en Afrique en
Amérique latine au Moyen-Orient pour
certains le dictateur impérialiste
Poutine deviendrait le héros d'un
nouveau mouvement des non alignés
comment n'avons-nous pas pu empêcher
cela ce risque évidemment interroge
notre diplomatie cela ne doit évidemment
rien enlever au contraire à notre
détermination à soutenir l'Ukraine
aujourd'hui comme demain mais cela nous
impose de convaincre partout de qui est
l'agresseur qui a l'agressé et par
conséquent d'être exemplaire dans notre
ainsi mais cela relève d'un autre débat
que nous aurons l'occasion d'avoir
madame la ministre d'affaires étrangères
car s'il existe un impérialisme c'est
bien celui du régime russe c'est bien la
Russie impérialiste et dictatoriale qui
s'en est pris à un pays démocratique et
qui tente d'annexer aujourd'hui laisse
de l'Ukraine quand la Crimée en 2014 et
qui envoie sa ministre Wagner
composé de repris de justice en Ukraine
comme en Afrique ou qui intervient au
Proche-Orient pour soutenir des
dictatures comme celle de Bachar
el-Assad mes chers collègues à l'heure
ouvrent Poutine et son allié de
tchétchène Ramzan Kadirov agite la
menace nucléaire la priorité absolue
réside dans la escalade plus que jamais
les défenseurs de la démocratie doivent
continuer à afficher leur unité pour
s'opposer à la spirale de la guerre et
de l'impérialis je vous remercie je vous
remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Laurent
panifous du groupe liberté indépendant
outre-mer et territoires
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres chers collègues c'est une
lourde responsabilité que d'intervenir
sur ce sujet majeur qui marque un
tournant historique pour notre continent
et qui s'impose comme un défi pour toute
la communauté internationale
depuis le début de la guerre force est
de constater que le président russe ne
recule devant aucune provocation et
entraîne l'Occident dans une escalade
qui ne peut que nous inquiéter
après 7 mois de guerre ni la mort de
soldat russe par milliers de civils
Ukrainiens ni les sanctions qui pèsent
lourdement sur l'économie russe ne
semble entamer la volonté de Poutine de
gagner cette guerre à tout prix
avec l'organisation de référendum locaux
et la mobilisation partielle assortie de
menaces nucléaire Vladimir Poutine
poursuit sa fuite en avant et fait
entrer la guerre dans une nouvelle phase
encore plus dangereuse guidé par une
haine viscérale du régime ukrainien et
de l'Occident nous devons nous y
préparer
ce qui soutenait encore hier le
président Poutine presque aveuglément
doivent s'interroger aujourd'hui
alors comment comprendre et répondre
collectivement à cette surenchère nul
doute qu'il s'agit là pour Poutine
d'accentuer la pression sur une
communauté internationale stupéfaite car
il le sait pour nous autres pays
européens la ligne de crête est
difficile depuis le début de ce conflit
à nos portes dans les conditions
d'escalade imposées par Poutine cette
équation sera de plus en plus difficile
à tenir et nous devons prendre
conscience que le risque d'une
confrontation potentielle directe entre
la Russie et l'Otan n'a jamais été aussi
élevé
alors mes chers collègues quel doit être
l'attitude de la France face à ces
risques immédiats dont nous pensions
être protégés
d'abord il nous semble madame la
Première ministre que face à cette fuite
en avant les alliés de l'Ukraine au
premier handical la France ne doivent
pas relâcher un effort qui produit des
résultats sur le terrain du fait de la
combativité exceptionnelle des troupes
de Kiev car la gesticulation auquel nous
avons pu constater le 30 septembre
consacrant l'annexion unilatérale de
territoire Ukrainiens conquis par la
force cachema les revers importants que
rencontre l'armée russe en Ukraine
sous la pression des troupes
ukrainiennes Vladimir Poutine a été en
effet contraint de précipiter le
calendrier de ses votes devenu d'autant
plus grotesque il a été également acculé
à une mobilisation partielle à laquelle
les Russes un âge de combattre ont
souvent répondu par les skis ou la fuite
à l'étranger
la France doit continuer à dialoguer
avec l'ensemble des acteurs de ce
conflit à agir de manière concertée dans
le cadre de l'Union européenne du G7 et
des institutions financières
internationales afin d'être
collectivement à la hauteur des besoins
de l'État ukrainien face à la
catastrophe de cette guerre
depuis l'agression russe contre
l'Ukraine nous ne pouvons que saluer la
réponse que l'Union européenne apportait
au fur et à mesure de la progression de
ce conflit la France n'a pas ménagé ses
efforts pour répondre à une exigence
sans précédent de fermeté avec la Russie
de solidarité avec le crâne la recherche
permanente du dialogue associée à des
sanctions économiques et financières
d'une sévérité sans précédent ont permis
d'isoler et d'affaiblir la capacité de
la Russie à poursuivre cette guerre et
faire subir aux dirigeants russes le
coup politique et économique de
l'agression qu'ils ont décidé
l'Union européenne et ses États membres
ont également joué un rôle moteur dans
la mobilisation de la communauté
internationale pour dénoncer les
violations multiples du droit
international par la Russie
pourtant et nous le constatons au regard
de ces derniers développements nous
devons aller plus loin
l'Ukraine a besoin d'un soutien massif
et nous devons être à la hauteur de
cette solidarité qui passe d'abord par
une aide financière accrue de l'ensemble
de la communauté internationale la
France en tant que Prince principale
puissance militaire de l'Union
européenne a également un rôle
particulier à jouer en matière de
livraison d'armes
là encore il n'est pas possible de céder
à la pression et aux intimidations de la
Russie qui reprochent à notre état ses
livraisons d'équipements militaires qui
apparaissent même essentiels à ce moment
précis du conflit
l'heure est à la mobilisation au soutien
d'un peuple assiégé privé de liberté
sans oublier le peuple russe lui-même
prisonnier de la brutalité de ses
dirigeants nous devons faire front
commun pour la défense de la paix cette
mobilisation cette démerde détermination
nous la devons au peuple crinien mais
aussi aux nouvelles générations pour
lesquelles nous avons le devoir de
préparer l'avenir je vous remercie merci
beaucoup mon cher collègue
la parole est à Madame Anne jeantais
pour le groupe Renaissance
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues en mars
dernier je me tenais ici même à ce
pupitre pour dénoncer la décision
unilatérale de la Russie d'envahir
l'Ukraine 7 mois plus tard et revenons
tout juste de Kiev je veux vous dire
avec insistance et avec la plus grande
émotion
ne nous habituons pas à cette guerre
elle qui a déjà volé des milliers de vie
brisés des familles ukrainiennes et
russes qui laissera derrière elle des
millions de déplacés et de réfugiés et
un pays à reconstruire alors liberté je
veux dire ton nom car au cœur de cette
guerre inique se dresse un combat pour
la liberté liberté bafouée des citoyens
ukrainiens liberté voler de leurs
enfants libertés muselée des
journalistes activistes et manifestants
en Russie et liberté ignorées de leurs
frères concernés par la mobilisation
forcée enfin liberté
usurpée de population et de territoires
qui dans un simulacre de démocratie ont
été récemment annexées
égalité je dis ton nom en envahissant
l'Ukraine le 24 février dernier la
Russie a agressé nos valeurs les plus
chères consacrées notamment par la
Charte des Nations Unies la première
puisqu'il faut encore le rappeler
l'égalité souveraine de toutes les
nations grandes et petites mais c'est
aussi la défense de l'égalité des
peuples à disposer d'eux-mêmes qui doit
tenir la représentation nationale et
tous ceux en France et dans le monde qui
porte l'idéal universelle de la
démocratie et de la paix et je veux
penser ici à nos communautés françaises
en Ukraine mais aussi en Russie qui
vivent au plus près de cette tragédie
fraternité je dis ton nom fraternité de
la France d'abord lorsqu'elle décide de
conduire l'une de ses plus larges
opérations humanitaires en affrétant un
bateau pour l'Ukraine avec notamment des
éléments d'un pont qui sera reconstruit
par la France dans le blast de
tcherniville
fraternité de la France encore
lorsqu'elle envoie une nouvelle mission
de gendarmes enquêteurs pour documenter
les crimes commis is you et car kiff
j'ai pu échanger avec eux et je salue
leur très grande expertise
fraternité de notre Parlement et de
notre gouvernement renouvelé lors de
fréquentes visites et échanges avec nos
amis je craignais
fraternité de nos concitoyens enfin
français établit en Ukraine en Pologne
en Roumanie et jusqu'en Australie je les
ai rencontrés corps et à m'engagés dans
la solidarité avec les Ukrainiens c'est
de cela dont je peux témoigner de mon
récent déplacement en Ukraine avec la
président de notre assemblée je choisis
de retenir cette image forte celle de
nos peuples unis fraternelles et
solidaires face à ce drame absolu
aussi à nos élus et à nos associations
françaises présents sur les territoires
Ukrainiens polonais et des pays
limitrophes tous au cœur des dispositifs
d'aide et d'hébergement merci à notre
réseau culturel français et à nos
alliances françaises avec une pensée
particulière pour celle de Cardiff et
zapporizia toutes deux ouvertes
aujourd'hui merci à notre lycée Anne de
Kiev qui a rouvert ses portes en
septembre passant de 500 à 67 élèves
seulement merci à notre lycée Alexandre
Dumas de Moscou courage au conseiller du
commerce extérieur à nos 160 entreprises
présentent encore en Ukraine dont
beaucoup ont pu se mobiliser et aider de
multiples manières merci à nos
journalistes qui continuent d'effectuer
un travail exceptionnel dans des
conditions particulièrement difficiles
et un autre compatriote qui a payé de sa
vie la nécessité d'informer sur la
réalité et la vérité de cette guerre
merci à nos diplomates en première ligne
animée par l'un d'effectible désir de
rétablir la paix et de protéger nos
concitoyens et je veux ici saluer
l'admirable Étienne de pont-saint merci
oui merci à eux tous de faire vivre
notre devises merci à tous d'avoir fait
de la sincérité de leur engagement le
relais de nos valeurs au début du siècle
dernier le président Raymond Poincaré
nous prévenait la paix est une création
continue alors permettez-moi de former
le vœu que notre assemblée madame la
Présidente soit actrice de cette
création pour soutenir reconstruire
l'Ukraine et ouvrir la voie à la paix
que vive l'Ukraine libre vive la
république et vive la France
merci beaucoup madame la députée la
parole est à Monsieur Alexis jolie pour
le rassemblement national
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre chers collègues la
guerre frappe à la porte de l'Europe
l'accélération du conflit à l'est et les
derniers événements nous oblige à
regarder la situation avec lucidité
l'Europe connaît déjà la guerre depuis
la fin de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
avec le conflit en exogoslavie cet
épisode tragique doit nous servir de
piqûres de rappel alors qu'est-ce que la
guerre en Ukraine et bien c'est d'avant
d'abord et avant tout un conflit au
sujet du statut des populations
russophone d'Ukraine en rupture avec le
gouvernement de Kiev et sur lesquels
Moscou revendique la souveraineté par
cette agression violente et sans
précédent sur le territoire
ukrainien les puissances alliées
soutenant l'Ukraine sans entrer dans une
guerre ouverte générant une déflagration
mondiale
sous ce prisme nous devons bien
comprendre quels sont les enjeux les
grandes tendances politiques propres à
chaque nation traverse les siècles et se
prolonge dans ce conflit à travers cette
guerre et les annexons brutales des
régions de l'est de l'Ukraine la Russie
cherche à rétablir par la force
l'ancienne sphère d'influence de l'Union
soviétique
c'est dans un contexte si dangereux que
la France doit aujourd'hui plus que
jamais défendre son rôle de médiatrices
et de grandes nations diplomatiques
chers collègues la France est
aujourd'hui affaiblie à l'international
car elle ne parle plus par sa propre
voie et parce qu'elle a renoncé à ce qui
fait sa spécificité
quand en 2003 le président Jacques
Chirac avait refusé d'embarquer la
France dans la guerre d'Irak il a posé
alors le choix présidentielle le plus
responsable et le plus juste de toute sa
longue carrière politique
c'est ce choix de l'équilibre et de la
troisième voie que doit faire la France
pour retrouver sa place dans le concert
des nations
la politique de sanction sur les
produits énergétiques n'a pas produit
les fruits attendus la Russie n'a pas
renoncé et les exportations de
combustibles fossiles de la Russie
s'élève à 158 milliards d'euros sur les
premiers mois de la guerre
l'ensemble des puissances asiatiques
sud-américaines et africaine continuent
de commercer de façon habituelle avec la
Russie et pire encore nous sommes les
dindons de la farce d'un jeu en triangle
où la Russie vend ses hydrocarbures à
d'autres pays qui s'empressent en suite
de nous les vendre trois fois plus cher
ces décisions affaiblissent ces
économies des pays d'Europe et nous en
sommes qu'au début depuis des années les
Français subissent les conséquences de
plus en plus dures de politiques
incohérentes inadaptées et contraire à
leurs intérêts mesdames et messieurs les
députés vous ne voyez pas les
souffrances effroyables qui sont
infligées aux Français et celles plus
terrible encore qu'il est menacent dans
les prochaines semaines qu'allez-vous
dire à nos concitoyens qui se gèleront
de froid cet hiver allez-vous leur dire
allez-vous devoir leur expliquer qu'ils
doivent mourir de froid uniquement pour
le symbole
sur les bancs de la gauche vous êtes les
responsables également de cette
situation parce que vous avez détruit
notre autonomie énergétique en faisant
disparaître le nucléaire si nous nous
retrouvons coincé aujourd'hui c'est par
votre faute et si la France connaît
demain un blackout et un effondrement
industriel et bien vous en serez les
premiers responsables et croyez bien que
nous au rassemblement national nous
saurons lors du français
contre à l'extrême centre représentée
ici par la non majorité présidentielle
les Français se rappelleront que vous
avez foncé tête baissée et appliquer une
politique internationale de sanction sur
l'énergie aussi
inutile que contraire à nos intérêts
nationaux vous n'avez obtenu aucun
résultat sur le plan diplomatique tout
en coupant en nous coupant de notre
approvisionnement énergétique après
avoir organisé notre dépendance aux
importations en soutenant avec la gauche
le démantèlement de nos centrales
nucléaires
je me suis rendu la semaine dernière en
Roumanie au camp de cinku qui sert donc
de base avancée malotents à l'est et
j'ai senti sur place les tensions et
l'inquiétude une crainte de voir la
guerre s'étendre et dégénérer à court ou
à moyen terme et je salue aujourd'hui
avec émotion nos soldats qui sont
engagés sur ces théâtres d'opérations
pour contrer une menace susceptible de
se transformer à tout moment en une
catastrophe majeure pour l'Europe et
pour le monde dans un contexte si tendu
nous donnons nous devons avoir qu'un
seul objectif éviter l'extension d'un
conflit que les Français a commencé par
nos familles on tente à craindre il est
temps de mettre un terme à l'escalade
l'heure est au dialogue réel et à
l'apaisement pour permettre à l'Ukraine
et à la Russie d'en finir rapidement et
de penser les blessures je vous remercie
je vous remercie monsieur le député
la parole est à Madame Emmanuel Ménard
madame la présidente madame le Premier
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues
nous sommes en guerre
par procuration si j'ose dire mes en
guerre le peuple ukrainien se bat pour
nous meurt pour nous pour ces valeurs
que nous mettons sans arrêt en avant et
qui prennent aujourd'hui le visage de
ceux qui sont tués là-bas à l'est de
l'Ukraine
tout dans les mots et dans la rhétorique
de Vladimir Poutine nous renvoie aux
années 30 écoutez-le il parle d'une
Europe dégénérée il fustige les
homosexuels il nous accuse d'être
ruissophobe colonialiste il dénonce
notre satanisme il flatte le pire des
nationalismes son invasion de l'Ukraine
nous rappelle l'annexion des Sudètes et
de l'Autriche
il faut prendre le dictateur du Kremlin
utilisons les bons mots il faut le
prendre au sérieux il dit ce qu'il va
faire ce ne sont pas des rhodontades il
est capable d'utiliser l'arme nucléaire
les Américains ont créé un précédent
a-t-il averti des armes nucléaires de
faible puissance précise Ramzan Kadirov
le président tchétchène l'Allier le plus
sanguinaire que l'on puisse trouver sur
cette planète
et certains ici continuent à lui trouver
des excuses en renvoyant dos à dos la
Russie et l'Occident en votant contre ou
en s'abstenant à Bruxelles quand il
s'agit d'aider l'ukraines ou à Paris
quand la Finlande est la Suède frappe à
la porte de l'OTAN quel indécence les
mêmes dénoncer les vatangers face à
l'Allemagne nazie décidément il
n'apprendront rien par anti-américanisme
ils sont prêts à tout au lâcheté au
petit
aux abandons au déshonneur
seul génitsine disait que dans la vie de
chaque homme il y a un événement qui le
détermine tout entier qui détermine
aussi bien son destin que ses
convictions et ses passions c'est la
même chose pour les pays pour les
nations serons-nous à la hauteur de
l'enjeu sommes-nous capables des audaces
mais aussi des sacrifices que la
situation exige aujourd'hui nous
participons à aider militairement
l'Ukraine et nous avons raison le
faisons-nous suffisamment
fournissons-nous tout le matériel
nécessaire alors ou sur le front le
rapport de force semble s'inverser je
l'espère n'oublions jamais les exactions
et les horreurs que connaît la
population
ukrainienne pas plus d'ailleurs que seul
exercée par les mercenaires de Wagner de
Vladimir Poutine ailleurs dans le monde
elles ne pourront elles ne devront pas
rester impuni
le président Zelenski et le fer de lance
d'une certaine idée de l'Europe de la
démocratie de la liberté il est comme le
Churchill de cette guerre présent sur
tous les fronts incarnant la résistance
galvanisant ces hommes et son peuple il
est cette lance qui s'est dressait
lorsque la Russie a envahi l'Ukraine
cette lance qui a fait reculer l'armée
russe cette lance qui donne toute sa
fierté à ce peuple ukrainien dont
Poutine allait jusqu'à nier l'existence
faut-il encore du cire les sanctions je
réponds oui quant à ceux qui les jugent
inefficaces et nous incite à les
suspendre qu'ils aillent voir du côté de
l'industrie automobile russe oui il faut
maintenir les sanctions et les accentuer
même si elles ont des conséquences
négatives sur notre vie au jour le jour
cela s'appelle l'effort de guerre
quant à ceux qui veulent nous faire
croire que l'on peut aider l'Ukraine
sans que cela ne coûte rien il nous
manque
c'est le prix à payer pour la liberté la
liberté des peuples faisons seulement en
sorte que ce prix soit le moins lourd
possible pour les plus faibles les plus
démunis de nos concitoyens au fond que
découvrons-nous que la guerre n'est pas
la panache de quelques contrées éloignés
la guerre est là à deux pas de chez nous
et oui elle bouleverse nos habitudes
elle chamboule notre quotidien mais
c'est si peu à l'aune des malheurs qui
frappe le peuple ukrainien
quelques degrés de moins à la maison ou
au bureau ce sera notre part du fardeau
il y a des mots qui prennent tout leur
sens aujourd'hui ces mots que nous
réservons habituellement pour les
discours au pied des monuments aux morts
ces mots qui peuvent sembler quelque peu
ronflant au plus jeune d'entre nous qui
n'ont jamais connu la guerre des mots de
chair et de sang des mots qui ne vous
font pleurer quand sur la place de
Turquie ville jumelles de Béziers le
maire appelle une à une ces femmes
habillées tout en noir qui ont perdu un
mari ou un fils pour elle il nous faut
soutenir de toutes nos forces les
combattants Ukrainiens les argusies de
certains pour le refuser ne sont au
mieux que de la lâcheté au pire de la
trahison
merci beaucoup madame la députée
la parole est à monsieur Adrien Gomis
pour le gros Renaissance
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres monsieur le président de
la commission des affaires étrangères
mes chers collègues pour commencer
permettez-moi de saluer le déplacement à
Kiev de Madame la Ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères madame
Colonna
c'est encore une fois le symbole que la
France et ce depuis le début de
l'agression russe se tient aux côtés de
l'Ukraine
comme vous l'avez indiqué madame la
ministre toutes les compétences de
l'État français sont mobilisés pour
l'Ukraine dans la durée y compris dans
la phase de reconstruction
sans m'apesantir sur la jeunesse de ce
conflit ou ces derniers soubresauts je
tiens cependant à marquer à nouveau
notre opposition totale devant les
référendums fantoche organisés par
Moscou et l'annexion contraire au droit
international des territoires
Ukrainiens occupés
c'est un fait ce conflit bouleverse
l'ordre géopolitique mondial nous voyons
ainsi avec inquiétude les régimes
dictatoriaux se taire complaisamment
devant les actions de la Russie
désireux sans doute de substituer au
respect du droit la loi du plus fort
aussi nous observons tous comment ce
conflit alimente un choc énergétique et
alimentaire d'une ampleur inédite et qui
se répercute dans le quotidien de tous
les Français car oui pour paraphraser le
président de la République les temps ont
changé pour la première fois l'énergie
et la production agricole sont devenues
des armes de guerre dont c'est
parfaitement se servir la Russie
dans le domaine de l'énergie les prix de
l'électricité ont connu une montée qui
fait courir des risques à notre
industrie et augmente la facture des
foyers français mais disons-le
clairement la facture pour les ménages
aurait été bien plus lourdes sans les
mesures prises pour protéger le pouvoir
d'achat et ce avant même le début du
conflit vous l'avez rappelé madame la
Première ministre
faut-il que certains dans et à
l'extérieur de cette émission et la
mémoire courte pour ne pas se rappeler
que dès la fin de l'année dernière nous
avons institué le bouclier tarifaire que
démarre devant l'impact sur les matières
premières le gouvernement a pris des
mesures de soutien avec le plan de
résilience économique et social et que
cet été même ici nous avons voté des
mesures d'urgence pour aider le pouvoir
d'achat des Français
puis au niveau européen nous avons
également agi agit pour réduire la
dépendance de l'Union européenne au gaz
russe avec le plan ripower u sans
sacrifier notre ambition de neutralité
carbone en 2050
c'est cette ambition de sécurisation de
production notamment électrique de
neutralité carbone et de sobriété que le
Président de la République est notre
majorité portons
elle s'incarne encore dans le projet de
loi de finance pour 2023 avec
l'accompagnement des Français dans la
rénovation de leur logement et dans
l'achat de véhicules propres ou encore
avec l'accélération de la décarbonation
de notre mix énergétique en soutenant
les deux piliers que sont les énergies
renouvelables et le nucléaire
oui nous agissons pour protéger les
Français et notre souveraineté
énergétique mais aussi alimentaire
car si comme pour l'énergie notre pays
peut se targuer de solides ressources en
tant que septième exportateur mondial
d'autres pays se voient profondément
déstabiliser par les conséquences du
conflit
ukrainien
45 pays parmi les plus fragiles de la
planète importe au moins un tiers de
leur blé du crâne ou de Russie la France
en tant que puissance à vocation
internationale ne peut rester sans agir
et sans prêter main forte à ses
partenaires dès le mois de mars le
président de la République a annoncé le
lancement de l'Initiative farm afin de
lutter contre les pénuries une
initiative ambitieuse organisée en
concertation avec nos partenaires de
l'Union européenne du G7 et de l'Union
africaine une initiative qui permettra
d'apaiser les tensions sur les marchés
agricoles d'assurer un accès à prix
raisonnable aux denrées agricoles dans
les pays les plus touchés et de
renforcer les capacités agricoles de
manière durable dans les pays les plus
concernés
sa dotation pour près de 75 millions
d'euros dans le projet de loi de finance
pour 2023 représente ainsi concret de
l'engagement de la France pour la
sécurité alimentaire mondiale je salue
également le lancement par le ministre
de l'Agriculture du processus
d'élaboration du plan de souveraineté
pour la filière fruits et légumes car
sécurisé notre production c'est aussi
prévenir les conflits géopolitiques qui
pourraient notamment apparaître lors de
la répartition de nos surplus agricoles
entre nos différents pays amis du
pourtour méditerranéen
garantir la souveraineté énergétique et
alimentaire de la France et de l'Europe
tout un assurant la transition
écologique et la décarbonation de nos
entreprises doit être le grand défi des
années à venir mes chers collègues je
souhaiterais finir sur ces mots
contrairement à ce que certains
affirment ici ce n'est qu'en européen
que nous pourrons reprendre en main
notre destin productif et industriel je
vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le député la
parole est à Monsieur Benjamin Haddad
pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres monsieur le président de
commission chers collègues nous sommes
réunis aujourd'hui pour débattre du
soutien à l'Ukraine et à travers
l'Ukraine c'est de la France dont nous
parlons aujourd'hui de son rôle dans le
monde de sa mission de son intérêt
national nous souhaitons l'Ukraine parce
que la France est toujours grande quand
elle est avec les nations qui luttent
pour leur liberté le jeune capitaine de
Gaulle le savait quand il combattait en
1920 aux côtés des troupes de pisoulski
pour l'indépendance de la Pologne face à
l'URSS le général de Gaulle qui comme
François Mitterrand était avec nos
alliés dans les grandes crises de Cuba
ou des euromissiles
l'Ukraine a toujours aspiré être libre
disait Voltaire dans son histoire de
Charles XII cette Ukraine qui a connu le
génocide du holo de mort les familles
organisé par Staline sur son sol cette
Ukraine qui vota à 90% pour son
indépendance en 1991 dont les jeunes
sont morts pour le drapeau européen à
Maydan jésus-chrenia se battent
aujourd'hui pour leur liberté face à
l'impérialisme nous soutenons aussi
l'Ukraine parce que nous défendons
sécurité et nos intérêts nous n'avons
pas choisi cette guerre nous avons tenté
de l'empêcher par la diplomatie le
président de la République n'a cessé de
dialoguer avec les présidents Hélène ski
et Poutine il a fait entendre la voix de
la France quand tant d'autres avaient
abandonné c'est le président russe qui a
tourné le dos à la diplomatie c'est le
président russe qui a choisi la guerre
et aujourd'hui l'escalade en mobilisant
son peuple en violant une fois de plus
le droit avec les élections illégales le
territoire
la seule façon d'arrêter cette guerre
c'est d'aider l'Ukraine à se défendre
c'est d'acculé la Russie pour mettre fin
à l'agression c'est d'imposer un rapport
de force soyons clairs si nous ne
soutenions pas l'Ukraine cette guerre
aurait été plus meurtrière plus longue
et plus étendue sur le territoire
ukrainien
si demain nous sédions aux intimidations
de Poutine au chantage nucléaire si nous
imposions un arrêt des combats au moment
où les Ukrainiens contre-attaquent
est-ce que la paix la stabilité
arriverait comme par magie ne soyons pas
naïf la faiblesse invite l'agression
imaginez un cessez le feu demain qui
reconnaît les élections le régime de
Poutine prendrait le temps de réarmer de
profiter de la levée des sanctions pour
se refaire et lancer une nouvelle
attaque contre Kiev parce que ce ne sont
pas les énergissements de l'OTAN ou le
statut d'en basse que conteste Poutine
c'est l'existence même de l'Ukraine il
suffit de lire et l'écouter et
l'histoire nous l'apprend la paix
n'arrive jamais avec la soumission à
l'agression mais les voix de la défaite
s'élèvent toujours les mêmes
une colonne de capitulard toujours prêt
à se coucher devant la force
ce qui les dérange c'est que les
démocraties libérales résistent qu'elles
tiennent eux qui ont répété pendant des
années avec Poutine avec Orban quelles
étaient faibles l'exemple et décadente
ils espéraient que l'Ukraine s'effondre
ils espéraient que les Européens se
divisent ils sont fidèles à ceux qui les
ont précédés pourquoi se battre pour un
petit pays si lointain dont nous savons
si peu distille avec Nevil Chamberlain à
Munich mourir pour Dantzig jamais avec
Marcel da en 1938
si nous les avions écouté nous serions
les alliés de la Russie aujourd'hui
si nous les avions écoutés nous serions
sortis du commandement militaire intégré
de l'OTAN à l'heure où nos Alliés
prennent des décisions majeures sur
cette guerre sans nous est-ce que c'est
cela être souverain
si on les avait écouté nous n'aurions
pas élargi le temps laissant plus de
nations comme les pays baltes en proie à
l'agression
si on les avait écouté nous n'aurions
pas livrés d'armes car la défaite de
l'Ukraine était inéluctable et nous
deviendrions qu'obelligérant comme ils
aiment le répéter 7 mois plus tard nous
ne sommes pas cobelligérants il y a pas
de soldats français sur le territoire
ukrainien qui combat la Russie et
l'Ukraine se défend contre-attaque et
reprend du terrain c'est l'honneur de la
France d'aider les Ukrainiens se
défendre en ayant livré des armes en
ayant formé les soldats Ukrainiens
n'ayant livrés notamment les canons
César c'est l'honneur de la France et de
ses soldats d'être en Roumanie de
prendre ses responsabilités nations
cadres de l'OTAN aux côtés de nos alliés
ils se sont toujours trompés à tous les
tournants si on les avait écoutés notre
continent aujourd'hui ce serait plus
dangereux notre pays isolé et les
Ukrainiens abandonnés et assassinés
alors il faut tenir la guerre n'est pas
finie le président de la République l'a
dit lui libersera dure notre stratégie
fonctionne mais quand l'histoire est
tragique les dénouement faciles et
rapides n'existent pas restons calme
gardons notre sang-froid en difficulté
sur le terrain la Russie voudra nous de
voir céder au chantage elle regroupera
de manipulation et aura ses relais chez
nous qui instrumentaliseront les peurs
des Français la France doit continuer
d'incarner sa voix pour la sécurité du
continent les prochains mois vont être
décisifs face au retour de la guerre
montrant aux Ukrainiens aux Européens au
monde que la France tient son rang et
assume sa puissance quel guide l'Europe
dans ce moment de crise livrons plus
d'armes à l'Ukraine plus d'armes pour
que l'Ukraine se défende reprenne son
territoire et gagne la guerre plus
d'armes pour dire à la Russie pour dire
au monde que l'agression ne paie jamais
plus d'armes pour que nos frères
européens polonais et lituaniens
estonien roumain sache que la France est
toujours avec eux que l'Europe se
protège les protège face aux menaces à
nos frontières chaque jour les
Ukrainiens meurent pour la liberté de
l'Europe nous serons à la hauteur de
leur sacrifice nous ne faillerons pas
nous tiendrons
merci beaucoup
la parole est à Madame constance le grip
pour le groupe Renaissance
madame l'a présidente madame la Première
ministre
mesdames messieurs les ministres
messieurs les prises en commission chers
collègues c'est un acte politique fort
que notre Assemblée nationale débute
cette session automnale par un débat sur
l'Ukraine cet acte politique fort nous
députés de la majorité présentielle et
parlementaire nous avons voulu le poser
pour réaffirmer haut et fort notre total
soutien notre total solidarité notre
engagement sans faille aux côtés de
l'Ukraine de l'Ukraine attaquée de
l'Ukraine agressée l'Ukraine un pays
libre indépendant au destin européen
dont la souveraineté et l'intégrité
territoriale ont été violées par la Méru
au service du régime de Vladimir Poutine
notre débat se tient quelques jours
après les annexions illégales que nous
considérons toujours comme illégal de 4
Oblats
ukrainiens
et après également un discours à charge
violemment belliqueux et antioxydants du
président russe discours au Roland très
souvent nauséabonds et ce alors même que
sur le terrain les forces armées russes
connaissent des déconvenus Sévères recul
battant retraite notamment depuis la
reprise de la ville stratégique de
l'imam par les valeuses troupes
ukrainiennes certains commencent même
envisager un début de débâcle nous
sommes donc à un moment certainement
important peut-être même décisif de
cette guerre cruelle menée en Ukraine
par l'armée russe et les semaines à
venir seront décisives
rappelons-le dès le début dès
l'agression de la Russie le 24 février
la France l'Union européenne unie
déterminée ont déclenché dans seulement
après avoir condamné sévèrement bien
évidemment l'agression brutale mais on
déclenché plusieurs trains de sanction
très lourdes des mesures de rétorsion et
de sanction à l'encontre de la Russie et
contre l'économie russe ne sont pas
moins de 7 trains de sanctions qui ont
été pris la plupart sous présidence
française du Conseil de l'Union
européenne embargo sur l'essentiel du
pétrole russe et sur le charbon russe
exclusion de nombreuses banques russes
du système bancaire Swift gel des avoirs
de la Banque centrale russe en dehors de
l'Union en dehors de la Russie pardon
gel des avoirs de très nombreuses
oligarques et de Vladimir Poutine
fermeture de l'espace aérien européen de
nos ports de nos routes interdictions
des ventes d'avions d'équipement accès
très strictement limité un Centre de
technologie industriel sensibles
interdiction bien sûr également de
diffusion dans l'Union européenne des
médias entre guillemets ou achat today
is Sputnik considérés comme des organes
de propagande du Kremlin un huitième
train des sanctions est en cours de
discussion en réponse au référendum au
référendum fictif fantoche et à la
menace du dirigeant russe d'utiliser
certaines armes nucléaires nous le
savons ces sanctions ont un coût ces
sanctions ont un prix pour nos
concitoyens pour les Européens et plus
globalement pour tous les habitants d'un
très grand nombre de pays dans le monde
les conséquences énergétiques
économiques alimentaires souvent
dramatiques de la guerre déclenchée par
la Russie se font sentir durement c'est
vrai dans le monde mais aussi chez nous
mais ne nous y trompons pas premièrement
les sanctions contre la Russie
produisent leurs effets en Russie elle
produisent leurs effets des pénuries
généralisées d'approvisionnement sont
constatés de nombreuses productions
industrielles s'effondre le départ des
entreprises internationales de Russie a
entraîné des cascades de faillites
entreprises russes le PIB russe est
tombé de - 6% le mythe d'une économie
russe résiliente c'est évanoui ne
confondons pas non plus deuxièmement les
causes et les conséquences qui peut
encore défendre l'idée que l'invasion de
l'Ukraine par la Russie ne justifie
aucune sanction aussi éprouvante la
sanction puisse être pour nos
populations en envahissant l'Ukraine on
y poursuivant sa guerre cruelle la
Russie membre permanent du Conseil de
sécurité de Nations Unies met en cause
les principes plus fondamentaux de
l'ordre international violent la Charte
des Nations Unies et de ce fait méconner
totalement sa responsabilité historique
elle aggrave la logique des
conflictualisations des confrontations
la fragmentation du monde et la menace
des partout dans le monde contre la paix
il n'y a pas de paix sans justice cela
était rappelé par le chef de l'État
français à la tribune des Nations Unies
je voudrais terminer ce propos par
l'engagement sans faille de la France
dans la lutte contre l'impunité il y a
l'âge le C madame la ministre Catherine
Colonna un engagement très fort de votre
part également la France apporte un
homme puis constant aux enquêtes qui
sont menées en Ukraine dépêchent du
personnel des
extrêmement spécialisés il y a là
quelque chose de très important
essentiel pas de paix sans justice nous
le devons à l'Ukraine une
Ukraine libre indépendante et européenne
nous le devons à la paix dans le monde
je vous remercie merci beaucoup ma chère
collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Nicolas
metzdorf pour le groupe Renaissance
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
et maintenant messieurs pourquoi
avons-nous réussi à stopper la guerre au
moment même où elle semblait prête à se
déchaîner parce que nous avons négocié
comme des hommes pour lesquels la
négociation n'était pas seulement une
phase inévitable de ce grand drame
international
mais parce qu'elle était le véritable
chemin de la paix il y a 84 ans en 1938
à cette même place dans cette même
assemblée
Édouard Daladier prononcer ses mots à la
résonance tragique dans l'histoire
il rentrait Dominique ou en guise de
négociation il avait avalisé le
découpage de la Tchécoslovaquie
il pensait avoir sauvé la paix et
l'honneur mais bientôt l'Europe allait
de nouveau s'effondrer
ce rappel des heures les plus sombres de
notre histoire et cette comparaison avec
ce que nous vivons aujourd'hui n'est pas
fortune nous devons en tirer les leçons
et savoir qu'il n'y a de paix possible
que lorsque l'agresseur n'a plus d'autre
choix que de se soumettre
depuis le 24 février la France apporte
son soutien indéfectible à l'Ukraine et
aux Ukrainiens
c'est un défectible soutien qui nous
honore tous
et plus que jamais nécessaire
surtout maintenant que sans vergogne et
au mépris de toutes les conventions
internationales et des valeurs humaines
Poutine pensent pouvoir annexer les
territoires d'une nation souveraine
ce soutien de la France permet à
l'Ukraine de tenir et de résister à
l'agression engrangeant des succès qui
marquent le courage et la détermination
de tout un peuple mais surtout en France
il se levait aussi une armée de l'ombre
une force silencieuse que l'on entend ni
ne voit cette force citoyenne s'est
mobilisée pour aider pour accueillir
pour soutenir celles et ceux qui
enfuient la guerre et leur pays
jamais ce que l'on appelle l'hébergement
citoyen ne s'était autant manifesté que
ces derniers mois en France c'est aussi
notre honneur dans cette crise sans
précédent et il faut le souligner cette
mobilisation a permis d'accueillir sur
notre sol avec humanité plus de 100000
ukrainiens et le chiffre ne s'être de
croître chaque jour
n'oublions pas la mobilisation des
services de l'État qui permet aussi la
scolarisation de plus de 18000 enfants à
l'école de la République
80% des réfugiés sont des femmes avec
leurs enfants et que nous disent-elles
ces femmes ces mères qui ont tout quitté
en réalité elles disent peu de choses
mais la plupart avec une tragique pudeur
qui masque la tristesse
confie que leur mari est mort que le
frère a disparu ou que le fils se
battent encore
nos élus nos fonctionnaires nos
associations et surtout nos concitoyens
ce sont levés depuis la fin de l'hiver
dernier pour subvenir aux besoins de ce
peuple en souffrance et qui trouve sur
notre sol une part de réconfort et
d'espoir
ces Français j'ai pu les rencontrer au
cours de ces derniers mois dans le cadre
de ma mission de rapporteur ces Français
je les salue mais surtout je les
remercie pour leur engagement et pour le
courage dont ils font preuve au
quotidien
la France n'est jamais aussi grande que
lorsqu'elle l'est pour les autres disait
Malraux la France est grande aujourd'hui
résister à Poutine ce n'est pas
seulement repousser l'armée russe
c'est protéger l'Europe c'est permettre
aux Ukrainiens réfugiés sur les sols
européens et surtout sur le nôtre de
garder leur dignité et l'espoir de
retrouver un jour leur foyer
alors désormais il nous appartient à
nous la représentation nationale d'être
à la hauteur de ce que fait le peuple
français
nous tous ici n'avons pas d'illusion sur
les dessins de Vladimir Poutine ces
ambitions folles de grandes Russie et sa
volonté de détruire l'Occident de
détruire ce que nous sommes et les
valeurs humanistes des lumières que nous
portons
face à ce péril nous n'avons qu'une
seule chose à faire
faire bloc faire bloc pour l'Ukraine
faire bloc pour la France faire bloc
pour l'Europe et faire bloc pour le
monde et je sais pouvoir compter sur
vous chers collègues car je sais que sur
ces bancs c'est aussi la France de
Malraux qui siège
merci beaucoup
et la parole est à Monsieur Charles zitz
pour le groupe Renaissance
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mesdames et messieurs les
députés chers collègues
des conséquences pour la France de la
guerre en Ukraine permet de nous
questionner sur notre propre débat
démocratique comme nombre de Français je
m'interroge maintenant depuis longtemps
sur ces femmes et ses hommes politiques
dont certains sièges parmi nous qui se
disent patriote
défenseur de l'indépendance nationale et
qui depuis des années ont prêché un
catéchisme étranger conçu au Kremlin et
déclamer sans aucune limite leur
administration pour un chef d'État
étranger Vladimir Poutine dirigeant d'un
régime autoritaire belliciste et
anti-européen
dirigeants qui souhaitent affaiblir par
la force et la subversion nos
démocraties
c'est bien il se reconnaissent tout de
suite eux-mêmes même pas besoin de les
nommer
cette si longue complicité idéologique
de l'extrême droite avec le pouvoir
russe interpelle pourquoi tant
d'éblouissement pour le régime poutinien
pourquoi tant de haine de notre modèle
démocratique européen pourquoi passer
son temps à vomir sur la diplomatie
française vomir sur la politique
étrangère française remettre en cause
les décisions du chef de l'État français
critiquer les décisions du Conseil
européen et se montrer toujours si
Clément s'y compréhensive si
bienveillant avec Moscou
nous le savons tous et il faut le redire
un parti politique le Front national
devenu rassemblement national et ces
deux précédents successifs Jean-Marie Le
Pen puis Marine Le Pen ont été pendant
des années des promoteurs du régime
russe chez nous qui ce pavanait à Moscou
dans les années 90 et 2000 avec des
leaders nationalistes russes proches du
Kremlin Monsieur Le Pen qui déclarait en
2011 dans la presse russe j'admire
Vladimir Poutine je ne peux qu'être
inquiète quand je vois que notre
président il s'agissait Nicolas Sarkozy
à l'époque tourne le dos à la Russie
Madame Le Pen qui a écrit dans son livre
en 2012 notre intérêt national est de
renouer l'alliance traditionnelle avec
la Russie pour contrebalancer
l'impérialisme exacerbé d'une Amérique
cherchant à obtenir l'endiguement de
cette puissance Renaissance la Russie
Madame Le Pen et puisque madame Ménard a
fait référence tout à l'heure aux années
30 moi je me demande d'ailleurs de quel
alliance traditionnelle nous parlons
avec la Russie de quelle alliance
traditionnel lorsque les Russes
s'entendirent avec l'Allemagne nazie à
l'époque pour laisser envahir notre pays
en 1940 de quelle alliance
traditionnelle avec la Russie parle-nous
quand l'URSS que regrette tant Vladimir
Poutine bâtit le Pacte de Varsovie face
à notre alliance la nôtre l'OTAN dont
nous sommes un pays fondateur qui a
reconnu l'annexion illégale de la Crimée
par la Russie en 2014 Monsieur et Madame
Le Pen qui a dit en 2015 après
l'assassinat de Boris namsov j'ai
confiance en la justice russe Madame Le
Pen qui a déclaré en février 2017 il n'y
a pas eu d'invasion de la Crimée Madame
Le Pen qui a été reçu par Vladimir
Poutine au Kremlin en tête-à-tête en
mars 2017 à un mois du premier tour
d'une élection présidentielle est
déclarée mon point de vue sur l'Ukraine
coïncide avec celui de la Russie Madame
Le Pen et quel génie enfin a affirmé en
février 2022 je ne crois pas du tout à
une invasion russe de l'Ukraine
Madame Le Pen je pourrais chers
collègues continuer ainsi pendant des
heures à citer toutes les références du
catéchisme Russo le pénis il y en a
tellement le RN pourra nier et l'idée se
contorsionner en fumée les débats par
des prises de position hypocrite faire
semblant de pleurer sur le sort du
l'Ukraine comme ils l'ont fait
aujourd'hui le RN pourra essayer de
faire oublier ses turpitudes mais nous
nous serons toujours là pour rappeler sa
si longue et aveugle soumission à la
Russie poutinienne nous ne laisserons
pas le président intérimaire du
rassemblement national proféré des
menaces publics contre les personnes qui
oseraient rappeler ces années de
collaboration idéologiques avec la
Russie si largement documenté par la
presse et les journalistes français ce
qui se joue en Ukraine cher collègue et
bien trop grave pour l'avenir du
continent européen pour que nous nous
taisions le président russe a
aujourd'hui envahi l'Ukraine mais nous
savons tous que c'est bien sur tout
l'Occident démocratique qu'il a placé
une cible oui nous continuerons à
démasquer les faux patriotes et
hypocrites nous serons aux côtés des
Ukrainiens aux côtés des Alliés et des
amis véritables de l'Ukraine et aussi
aux côtés des Russes qui éprouvent
l'entreprise guerrière menée par le
régime domusco chers collègues soyons
fiers de notre modèle démocratique
européen c'est ce modèle qui inspire les
soldats
Ukrainiens qui se battent pour leur
patrie et notre liberté collective je
vous remercie
je vous remercie
donc la parole est à présent monsieur
Jean-Louis bourlin je président de la
commission des affaires étrangères pour
le groupe modem
merci Madame
madame la Présidente
madame la Première ministre
madame la ministre messieurs les
ministres mesdames les ministres pardon
messieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues
le premier qui se réveille
les autres
disent les enfants
les premiers à être réveillés ont été
les Ukrainiens
ils savaient depuis longtemps en tout
cas depuis 2014 ce que nous voulions
ignorer depuis plus longtemps encore
à savoir que les puissances occidentales
n'avaient pas vraiment gagné la guerre
froide même si l'Union soviétique
l'avait clairement perdu nos amis nos
frères du Crêts ont éprouvé dans leur
cœur et dans leur chair ce que nous
avons longtemps
obstinément
inconsidémie inconsidérément refusé de
voir nos triomphes apparents des années
90 n'avait assuré durablement et
universellement ni la souveraineté des
peuples ni la démocratisation des états
ni la liberté des consciences des
opinions et des mouvements l'invasion
arbitraire injustifiée et terriblement
meurtrière de la libre crène par une
puissance impérialiste
la tragiquement montrée aujourd'hui les
souffrances et les victoires de
l'Ukraine nous confirment dans une
conviction que les Français ont été trop
longtemps les seuls à professer dans
l'Union européenne cette conviction
c'est celle qui veut que l'Europe ces
valeurs ses intérêts sa culture et ses
lois ne pourront survivre dans le monde
qui nous attend si les européens
continuent de faire de leur union une
entité simultanément marchande et
éthérés naïve a dit le président de la
République étrangère en toute état cause
à toute logique de puissance nous autres
Français avons de longues dates pensées
que l'universalisme de nos valeurs ne
pouvaient nous dispenser de l'obligation
d'inscrire notre projet dans un
territoire particulier fragile et
menacée ce petit cap de aussi décrit par
Paul Valéry et que personne ne défendra
durablement s'il ne se défend pas
lui-même nous avons passionnément voulu
donner une dimension géopolitique au
projet européen ajoutez la force au
droit la réciprocité à l'exemplarité les
intérêts aux valeurs l'ambition à
l'apostolat la défense et la division
d'une culture à la défense de
l'humanisme les Ukrainiens nous ont
réveillé ils nous ont dit par l'invasion
qu'ils ont subi par la résistance qui
lui ont opposé par les souffrances
assumées par les deuils accumulés où est
notre devoir ce qu'est notre mission
quelles sont nos responsabilités en
défendant sa souveraineté ces libertés
sa démocratie l'Ukraine défauts notre
souveraineté nos libertés nos
démocraties on est dans l'Ukraine à se
défendre les Ukrainiens défendent
l'Europe
nous avons pu mesurer aux côtés de la
présidente de notre assemblée la
détermination du président zen ski et
derrière lui celle de tout un peuple un
peuple inventif mobilisé actifs et
entreprenant un peuple un pavide devant
les provocations les référendums bidon
les mascarattes cérémoniales qui vise au
sublime et une rencontre que le
grotesque nous devons mes chers
collègues être à la hauteur des
responsabilités que nous impose la
situation nous sommes à la veille de
grandes épreuves elles imposent les
sacrifices aux Ukrainiens les Russes ont
pas besoin de recourir à l'arbre
nucléaire pour nous atteindre dans notre
confort et dans notre relatif quiétude à
nous non plus on ne sort pas vainqueur
d'une telle épreuve sans force d'âme
sans énergie sans rejet des divisions
bien sûr nous avons aussi un devoir de
sagesse le souci d'éviter la
généralisation de la guerre le dérapage
vers les armes de destruction la
préservation des chances de la paix le
monde peut compter sur nous pour
travailler dès que ce sera possible et
avec qui ce sera possible au
rétablissement de la paix mais l'issue
du conflit passera par le respect
scrupuleux de la souveraineté et de
l'Ukraine l'établissement de garantie de
sécurité sérieuse et crédible et la
reconstruction d'un pays martyr
aujourd'hui l'heure est à la solidarité
inconditionnelle avec le peuple
ukrainien et que serait notre solidarité
sinon une abject hypocrisie si nous
n'apportun pas aux Ukrainiens les moyens
de se défendre et de vivre il n'y a pas
d'amour sans preuve d'amour il n'y a pas
de solidarité sans preuve de solidarité
l'Europe et pour la première fois depuis
la fin de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
confrontée à une responsabilité
historique majeure ensemble relevons ce
grand défi il en va de notre avenir à
tous que vivent l'Ukraine que vive la
France que vive l'Europe
je vous remercie la parole est à Thomas
gasilou président de la Commission de la
Défense nationale et des forces armées
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mais chers collègues pour
commencer je voudrais remercier c'est
lui et la plupart des orateurs qui se
sont exprimés devant moi et notamment le
président Bourgoin avec beaucoup de de
compétences et profondeur dans le cadre
de ce débat relatif à la guerre en
Ukraine et aux conséquences pour la
France remercier également la prison de
l'Assemblée nationale qui a mené à la
semaine dernière une délégation de si
parlementaires dans le cadre de la
commission de la défense dont les trois
présidents de commission parce que ce
déplacement je pense a été extrêmement
utile dans le cadre pour la qualité de
ce débat alors pour faire simple pour
commencer peut-être un aperçu de la
situation opérationnelle sur place après
l'échec de l'attaque russe en février la
guerre s'installe dans la durée
après une Ukraine fragilisée se
substitue progressivement une Ukraine
fortifiée par le soutien occidental
d'une part mais aussi et surtout par son
propre peuple qui se montre admirable de
courage de ténacité de résilience mais
soyons prudents tout est encore possible
notamment des risques d'escalade au delà
l'Ukraine cette guerre il faut qu'on en
soit tous conscient
est un risque pour le monde nous
observons les prémices d'une guerre
hybride généralisée dans tous les champs
possibles de la conflictualité espace
champ international alimentation énergie
cyberespace résister à la loi du plus
fort ce n'est pas être un va-t-en guerre
c'est comprendre que pour sauver la paix
il faut parfois assumer le coût de la
guerre c'est pourquoi nous pouvons nous
odorer que depuis le déclenchement du
conflit la France ait été au rendez-vous
de ces responsabilités présidente du
Conseil de l'Union européenne au premier
semestre la France a contribué
puissamment à la mobilisation européenne
traduite par l'utilisation massive de la
facilité européenne de paix et des
sanctions historiques contre la Russie
la France a démontré sa solidarité
stratégique au travers d'une aide
militaire directe apportée à l'Ukraine
en lui cédant d'importants équipements
et indirectement en déplorant des forces
sur le flanc oriental de l'Union
européenne dans le cadre de l'OTAN la
commission de la défense est d'ailleurs
allée sur place pour le constater bien
en Roumanie ou en Estonie dès le mois de
juillet mais soyons gens également
conscience le soutien à l'Ukraine
dévoile certaines de nos fragilités en
livrant par exemple 18 importants canons
César ceux qui restent tout de même
modeste à l'échelle du conflit nous
avons cédé près du quart de notre
artillerie même si l'armée française est
probablement la meilleure armée d'Europe
nos démocraties européennes sont de
moins en moins capables de soutenir une
guerre de haute intensité le conflit le
conflit ukrainien démontre cruellement
que nous avons changé d'époque comment
anticiper en 2017 et qu'il faut
continuer à nous y adapter plus
rapidement pour assumer sa part de
responsabilité la commission de la
Défense nationale et des forces armées
c'est fixé trois grands objectifs
d'abord contribuer activement à ce que
notre pays fasse les meilleurs choix
pour son outil de défense les choix
opérés lors du dernier quinquennat avec
une LPM historique et respectée à
l'Europe ont permis d'engager une
réparation
est un projet majeur pour notre pays
enfin la commission de la défense
s'engage pour mettre la diplomatie
parlementaire au service des intérêts de
notre défense nous chercherons la
convergence des cultures stratégiques
afin de contribuer à faire émerger cette
Europe puissance pleinement articuler
avec le temps sans oublier nos
partenaires en Afrique et en adopassifs
mes chers collègues au-delà de l'enjeu
ukrainien la dangerosité du monde nous
impose de construire le modèle de
Défense français européen de demain
ensemble nous serons au rendez-vous de
l'histoire je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
la parole est à Pierre Alexandre Anglade
président de la commission des affaires
européennes
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres messieurs les présidents
de commissions comme ceux de mes
collègues qui se sont exprimés avant moi
je reviens du crâne
comme j'ai vu de mes yeux l'horreur de
cette guerre comme j'ai admiré le
courage et la force d'âme du peuple
craignant et de ses plus hauts
responsables politiques
nous avons rencontré ensemble le cœur
battant de la résistance ukrainienne le
président zélinski et ceux qui
l'entourent des femmes et des hommes qui
dès les premières heures de la guerre
étaient les cibles principales de
Vladimir Poutine des femmes et des
hommes qui auraient pu fuir mille fois
mais qui ont fait le choix de rester aux
côtés de leur peuple et de résister lors
de notre entretien avec le Président
zélinski il nous a remercié pour le
soutien actif qu'apporte d'ores et déjà
la France en Ukraine mais il a aussi
formulé plusieurs requêtes parmi elles
il nous a demandé de dire la vérité sur
ce que nous avons vu et entendu voici
donc là ou plutôt les vérités dont je
souhaite témoigner aujourd'hui en
Ukraine la Russie de Vladimir Poutine ne
se comporte plus comme une nation
civilisée mais comme un état voyou
menant une guerre d'une violence inouïe
niant tous les principes humanitaires
partout où l'armée russe passe elle sème
la désolation la souffrance et la mort
frappant en priorité les infrastructures
civiles ce sont les écoles les hôpitaux
les habitations qui sont visées
les soudards les hommes de mains qui la
composent parce que l'on ne peut plus
parler à proprement de soldats pire
pratique la torture viol femme et enfant
Assassin's sans raison organise les
enlèvements d'enfants la vérité c'est
kizium Mario Paul et Lucia ne sont
malheureusement que des théâtres
d'atrocités parmi bien d'autres et que
dans chacun des villages libérés l'on
trouve des salles de torture la question
ne se pose même plus de savoir s'il y a
eu ou non des crimes de guerre ils sont
pléthore mais les mots décrivant
l'horreur ne peuvent suffire et je veux
vous dire mes chers collègues à quel
point il est important que nous restions
mobilisés que la France et l'Europe
reste mobilisés dans leur soutien à
l'Ukraine ce soutien est d'autant plus
nécessaire que la volonté de puissance
du président russe ne semble plus
connaître de limite car qui peut croire
après son dernier discours transpirant
de haine à l'égard de l'Occident qu'il
arrêtera ces velléités impérialistes à
l'Ukraine en organisant des simulacres
de référendum en faisant placer en
faisant planer la menace nucléaire la
Russie affranchi une étape supérieure
dans sa volonté de semer la terreur et
de s'emparer par la force des
territoires qu'il n'y appartiennent pas
mais ne nous y trompons pas c'est
annexion en grande pompe c'est menaces
ne font que révéler l'échec du projet de
Vladimir Poutine sur le terrain et sur
le théâtre du monde car la Russie est de
plus en plus affaiblie et isolé preuve
si l'en fallait que les livraisons
d'armes permettent aux Ukrainiens non
seulement de résister mais de
contre-attaquer et de gagner des
batailles preuve que les sanctions
européennes affaiblissent
considérablement l'effort de guerre
russes
quelle sera l'issue de cette guerre
odieuse nul ne le sait encore mais de
retour du crâne je reviens avec une
conviction forte l'Ukraine peut gagner
cette guerre elle en a la détermination
absolue et le courage c'est la raison
pour laquelle il est nécessaire de
poursuivre les livraisons d'armes et les
sanctions avec nos partenaires européens
et chez nous d'opposer un front uni en
faveur de l'Ukraine sans rien céder au
valet de Poutine qui jusqu'au saint de
cette hémicycle se font les relais
honteux de sa propagande ou qui le
soutiennent sans le dire ce qui est pire
encore mais chers collègues la France
avec ses partenaires européens a eu
raison d'opter pour le soutien à
l'Ukraine si nous avions écouté Marine
Le Pen et Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui en
février dernier main dans la main
refusait ce soutien les Russes se
réaquief depuis longtemps et lorsque
nous entendons cet après-midi encore les
représentants du rassemblement national
et de la France insoumire réécrire
l'histoire de cette guerre inverser les
responsabilités pour des données
Vladimir Poutine l'on ne que ressentir
un sentiment de honte et se réjouir
qu'il ne soit pas en responsabilité
s'opposer aux livraisons d'armes levez
les sanctions comme il demande ce n'est
pas favoriser la paix ce n'est rien
d'autre que d'abandonner l'Ukraine aux
mains de la Russie et mettre en péril
toute la sécurité de l'Europe et n'en
déplaise au président du Rassemblement
national non seulement le rassemblement
national entretient des liens avec la
Russie mais pire encore il en est le
soutien oui défendre nos valeurs
démocratiques à un prix il est déjà
élevé les Ukrainiens le P en destruction
et en mort nous aurons à le pays
économiquement cependant si nous ne
sommes pas prêts à payer ce prix
maintenant pour l'Ukraine au nom des
valeurs des nations civilisées qui font
notre pays et l'idéal à européen alors
ce sont les générations futures qui
devront payées un prix infiniment plus
élevé mes chers collègues le Président
zelanski nous a demandé que nous
n'abandonnons pas le l'Ukraine je
souhaite qu'il sache si nous écoutent
que nous sommes à ses côtés et aux côtés
de son qu'il sache aussi que son pays
est également membre de cœur de notre
union par le combat acharné qu'il mène
pour la liberté et la démocratie c'est
pourquoi je suis convaincu que l'avenir
de l'Ukraine de la France et de l'Europe
s'écriront en commun je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
mon cher collègue
la parole est à présent Madame Catherine
Colonna ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
députés
vendredi dernier la première ministre
l'a rappelé après 7 mois d'une guerre
d'agression aussi brutale qu'un
justifiée Moscou franchissait un nouveau
seuil
en s'autorisant des simulacres de
scrutin organisés à la hâte en zone
occupée le Kremlin annexé en toute
illégalité les territoires occupés dans
les régions de louange donnesque
zaboriggia et Carson je le dis sans
ambiguïté le fait accompli ne fera
jamais le droit dans des plaises aux
propagandistes du Kremlin
la France et ses partenaires ne
reconnaîtront jamais ces pseudos
référendum il ne reflètent rien la
volonté de la population ukrainienne sa
résistance héroïque en témoigne il
traduisent tout au plus le cynisme de
l'agresseur russe qui ne recule devant
aucune mascarade pour tenter de
maquiller ce qui est en réalité un
projet impérialiste et expansionniste un
projet de conquête qui vous le savez
porte profondément atteinte à toutes les
règles régissant les relations
internationales et la vie entre les
nations
car on engraissant l'Ukraine la Russie
membre permanent du Conseil de sécurité
qui plus est
à bafouer les principes fondateurs de la
Charte des Nations Unies que sont la
non-agression le règlement pacifique des
différents la souveraineté des États et
le respect de leur intégrité
territoriale
nous avons en conséquence fait le choix
du droit et de nos valeurs comme la
souligner madame la Première ministre
la Russie elle a choisi la guerre
une guerre d'agression une guerre
brutale avec son cortège de meurtre
d'exaction elle a choisi des élections
illégales méthode de sinistre mémoire
nous l'appelons à revenir à un
comportement responsable alors dans ce
moment de bascule nous faisons depuis 7
mois le seul choix qui vaille le seul
choix responsable celui du soutien
l'Ukraine et à nos valeurs comme vous
l'avez dit si justement ce matin encore
madame la Présidente
ce sont le choix de défendre leur
internationale fondée sur la règle de
droit cet ordre que la Russie voudrait
détruire quel pays
pourra s'estimer à l'abri dans ses
frontières si la souveraineté et
l'intégrité territoriale d'un état
peuvent être violées de manière aussi
des complexée si tout est permis en
Ukraine tout le sera davantage ailleurs
cette guerre n'est pas une guerre
régionale elle est l'affaire de tous
nous n'avons pas ménagé nos efforts pour
le faire valoir auprès de l'ensemble de
la communauté internationale et ses
efforts commencent à porter leurs fruits
nous l'avons constaté lors de
l'Assemblée générale des Nations unies à
New York ou de nombreux pays tiers ne
faisant pourtant pas partie des
traditionnels soutiens de l'Ukraine ont
pris leur distance vis-à-vis de la
Russie ont appelé au plein respect des
principes fondamentaux de la charte et
ont rappelé que l'heure n'était pas à la
guerre je pense par exemple à la Chine
et à l'Inde et nous sommes déterminés à
poursuivre dans cette voie
les députés vous avez été nombreux à
évoquer la lutte contre l'impunité nous
faisons aussi le choix de la justice et
refusons l'impunité des criminels je dis
clairement au Conseil de sécurité dont
j'ai présidé le 22 septembre jeudi
dernier la première réunion de niveau
ministériel sur la situation un Ukraine
la première réunion de niveau
ministériel au Conseil de sécurité sur
la situation en Ukraine depuis le
déclenchement de l'invasion il n'y aura
pas de paix sans justice les exactions
et les crimes de guerre devront être
poursuivis
nous y contribuons au sein des
organisations internationales nous y
contribuons également à titre bilatéral
et en ce sens nous avons envoyé certains
d'entre vous l'ont rappelé depuis le
mois d'avril trois équipes spécialisées
de nos gendarmes de l'Institut de
Recherche criminels de la gendarmerie
nationale la dernière d'entre elles est
arrivée mardi
elle aidera la justice ukrainienne à
faire toute la lumière sur les atrocités
découvertes à isomes comme l'on fait ces
prédécesseurs à bout de chat de justice
doit passer
la question des sanctions et de leur
impact a aussi été évoqué comme la
souligner la première ministre nous
faisons le choix de la fermeté face à un
agresseur qui menace la stabilité de
notre continent et la sécurité de
l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale
avec une célérité inédite nous avons mis
en œuvre une politique de sanction d'une
rigueur sans précédent avec nos
partenaires européens et internationaux
ces sanctions ont un but clair
asphyxier l'effort de guerre russe et
appliquez une pression maximale sur les
fauteurs de guerre
d'ores et déjà 1200 individus et plus de
100 entités russes ils sont soumis ces
sanctions sont réfléchies elles sont
appropriées elles sont efficaces et
elles auront un impact massif et durable
sur la machine de guerre russes comme la
rappeler la première ministre
concrètement vous l'avez souligné le PIB
de la Russie va reculer de 6 points en
2022 il va retomber d'ici deux ans à son
niveau du début des années 2000 vingt
ans en arrière ce sont aussi les revenus
des hydrocarbures que nous asséchons
c'est l'accès de la Russie aux
technologies dont elle a besoin qui est
d'ores et déjà profondément affectés
dans des secteurs aussi stratégiques que
l'aéronautique l'automobile ou
l'armement alors nous ne faiblirons pas
la France souhaite vous le savez
l'adoption rapide d'un nouveau paquet de
sanctions européennes qui devrait être
finalisé dans les tous prochains jours
les sanctions le soutien à l'Ukraine y
compris en équipement militaire l'aide
humanitaire massive l'accueil des
réfugiés l'isolement de la Russie les
exportations de céréales sur tout cela
mesdames et messieurs les députés
surtout cela que vous avez cité l'Union
européenne agit vite éclaire et de façon
unie
oui nous sommes au rendez-vous de nos
valeurs humanistes lorsque nous
accueillons au sein de notre union
plusieurs millions de réfugiés
ukrainiens
oui nous sommes au rendez-vous de
l'Histoire lorsque nous croyons à
l'Ukraine le statut de candidat à
l'Union européenne à l'unanimité et lui
donnant ainsi un avenir européen
c'est uneanimité c'est unité fait notre
force collective et elle fait notre
force face à une Russie dont l'isolement
et chaque jour plus manifeste alors nous
sommes unis et nous le resterons
vous êtes exprimé également mesdames et
messieurs les députés en nombre sur le
soutien à l'Ukraine ces différentes
composantes et ses conséquences
et je veux le redire nous avons fait le
choix d'apporter à l'Ukraine un soutien
déterminé et constant
je veux être très clair ni la France ni
aucun pays européen ni aucun État membre
du G7 n'étant guère avec la Russie nous
aidons un pays agressé l'Ukraine à
exercer son droit à la légitime défense
conformément au droit international
conformément à la charte des Nations
Unies
se soutien nous l'avons réaffirmé il y a
quelques jours à l'Assemblée générale
des Nations unies par la voie du
président de la République et nous
l'avons fait également quand cette
sécurité il est à la fois politique
diplomatique humanitaire économique
financier il représente un effort
national de 2 milliards d'euros auquel
s'ajoute notre aide de militaire d'une
part dont le ministre des Armées
exposera l'ampleur et dont une partie
sera prise en charge par la facilité
européenne de paix et l'aide européenne
d'autre part à laquelle nous contribuons
ce soutien je l'ai à nouveau de
témoigner au président zzky à mon
homologue de mitro couliba à Kiev la
semaine dernière à l'occasion de mon
troisième déplacement en Ukraine où vous
êtes plusieurs à avoir accompagné madame
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
je me félicite de ce que la
représentation nationale et l'exécutif
Unis est ainsi peu témoigné sur place de
la solidarité de la France
akief agustomel abucha à irpin j'ai vu
l'ampleur des destructions causées par
les bombardements russes j'ai pu mesurer
la bravoure la détermination l'esprit de
résistance intacte du peuple crânien
nous sommes solidaires de la cause qu'il
défend nous sommes solidaires du combat
qu'il mène pour les valeurs
démocratiques ces valeurs sont les
nôtres pour la paix pour la liberté
nous sommes solidaires de ces
souffrances
nous l'aidons nous l'avons encore montré
le 28 septembre en envoyant un Ukraine
depuis Marseille plus de 1000 tonnes de
fraises humanitaires rassemblés grâce
aux contributions de l'ensemble des
forces de nos sociétés l'état ces
opérateurs les collectivités locales les
acteurs privés les ONG
la France est aux côtés de l'Ukraine
depuis le début de l'agression elle le
sera jusqu'à ce que l'Ukraine retrouve
sa pleine souveraineté et son intégrité
territoriale et elle le restera à ses
côtés elle le restera après la guerre
car il y aura un après
sur le terrain l'armée russe a connu ces
dernières semaines sont 3e échec
tactique en février elle prenait
l'Ukraine en tenaille sur trois axes au
nord à l'est et au sud elle cherchait
clairement à prendre Kiev pour y
renverser le président légitimement élu
par le peuple ukrainien
en avril incapable de prendre Kiev elle
s'était retirée du nord du pays
incapable de s'emparer rapidement de
l'ensemble du don-basse malgré le
concours de ces supplétifs séparatistes
elle a dû reculer dans la région de
kerkiff et elle a mis sa tendre la
contre-offensive ukrainienne la prise de
courant les Ukrainiens regagné 9000 km2
territoire
le constat que nous faisons aujourd'hui
est clair c'est celui d'une triple
impasse dans lequel se trouve la Russie
sur le terrain comme le montre c'est
recul vis-à-vis de la communauté
internationale où elle est de plus en
plus seul et enfin vis-à-vis de sa
population avec la décision de
mobilisation partielle une décision
lourde qui a été prise contre une
population russe qui comprend de moins
en moins pourquoi elle doit subir les
conséquences d'une guerre
inutile illégale et injuste une guerre
qu'elle n'a pas choisi
mesdames et messieurs les députés la
fuite en avant de la Russie a été
soulignée dans ce débat alors il va
falloir tenir ne nous y trompons pas il
va falloir tenir dans la durée la
première ministre nous l'a dit cet
après-midi à plusieurs reprises
Moscou a choisi une fuite en avant
politique les déclarations du président
russe vendredi dernier dans son que le
dernier exemple
elle a pris la responsabilité d'un
chantage à la sécurité alimentaire
auxquelles nous avons réagi en nous
engageant pour permettre à l'Ukraine
d'exporter à nouveau ces céréales
dans l'esprit d'initiative farm que le
président a lancé depuis le printemps
nous venons aussi de participer avec
l'Allemagne au confinement du transport
et de la distribution par le Programme
alimentaire mondial de 50000 tonnes de
céréales donnés par l'Ukraine et destiné
à l'Éthiopie et à la Somalie alors que
la Corne de l'Afrique est
particulièrement touchée par la crise
alimentaire
un chantage aussi à la sécurité
énergétique en coupant les vannes du gaz
tandis que nous sommes par ailleurs
témoins de mystérieuses explosions en
mer Baltique
un chantage à la sécurité du site de la
centrale nucléaire des aporidja qui nous
a conduit à soutenir fortement les
efforts du directeur général de l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie atomique
pour réduire les tensions et le risque
d'un accident nucléaire ces efforts se
poursuivent ce moment même
fuite en avant politique fuite en avant
militaire en annonçant cette
mobilisation partielle de sa population
inédite depuis 1941 la Russie prend un
grand risque
nous y voyons avant tout un aveu de
faiblesse une reconnaissance de
l'incapacité de ses forces armées à
remplir les objectifs fixés par le
Kremlin et d'ailleurs l'impact de cette
mobilisation sur le terrain est très
incertain l'armée russe ayant fait
preuve de graves lacunes logistique
depuis le début du conflit des lacunes
qui ne se résoudront pas en envoyant par
la force au front une population dont
tout le montre qu'elle ne souhaite pas
la guerre on atteste vous l'avez vu le
départ de centaines de milliers de
personnes de Russie ces derniers jours
les scènes de protestation dont nous
avons été témoins dans plusieurs dans
plusieurs régions russes et donc quoi
qu'en disent la propagande non il n'y a
aucun élan patriotique il y a une
mobilisation subie
fuite en avant rhétorique enfin les
menaces irresponsables qui ont été
proférées dans le but de nous intimider
en sont le signe nous ne céderons pas
nous ne tomberons pas non plus dans le
piège nous continuerons pour notre part
à faire preuve de la responsabilité qui
incombe à une puissance dotée
enfin la reconstruction
le premier orateur et d'autres à sa
suite ont évoqué sa nécessité je
voudrais dire que ça n'est pas à nous de
déterminer quand cette guerre prendra
fin il appartiendra à l'Ukraine à
l'Ukraine seul de décider à quel moment
dans quelles conditions et dans quel
terme elle peut envisager un dialogue
visant à l'ouverture de négociation
mais il y aura bel et bien un après j'en
suis convaincu c'est à nous qu'il
appartiendra de fournir à l'Ukraine les
moyens de se reconstruire avec nos
partenaires
nous y sommes engagés et nous commençons
à le faire avec
l'arrivée de l'hiver en perspective
ainsi parmi les biens envoyés dans notre
cargaison humanitaire du 28 septembre
figurer notamment du matériel de
réhabilitation d'urgence et en
particulier plus de 6 ponts de 20 à 60
mètres de long qui participeront la
reconstruction de la région de churchniv
où vous êtes rendu madame la Présidente
Messieurs les Présidents
mesdames et messieurs les députés
je m'arrêterai ici en aidant l'Ukraine
nous faisons notre devoir de solidarité
tout simplement
nous faisons notre devoir d'humanité et
nous le ferons aussi longtemps qu'il
sera nécessaire je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Sébastien
Lecornu ministre des Armées
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs députés monsieur le Président
messieurs les présidents de commission
sur l'autorité même la première ministre
qui me soit permis de compléter quelques
points dans le cadre de ce débat et la
mise de l'Europe des Affaires étrangères
à tracer les grands éléments qu'il ne
soit peut-être permis notamment aussi
dans le cadre du contrôle que le
Parlement effectue sur le gouvernement
de revenir sur l'aide militaire
évidemment que la République française
donne et accompagne depuis le début à
l'Ukraine te rappeler que les trois
éléments qui guident la doctrine au
final de notre soutien militaire sont
assez simples la première c'est de
coller à leur demande je le dis parce
que nous n'avons pas cherché justement à
être trop
diffus dans la manière d'aider par les
titres d'équipements par les natures
même d'équipements et que donc il y a un
dialogue opérationnel qui s'est noué au
fil du temps qui est un dialogue de
confiance avec le ministère de la
Défense
ukrainien avec des expressions de
besoins qui sont mesurées qui sont
clairs sur lequel évidemment nous
apportons des réponses la deuxième des
choses c'est une relative discrétion de
notre manière d'accompagner l'Ukraine
c'est du sont les Ukrainiens eux-mêmes
qui nous le demandent parce que cette
discrétion évidemment est clé et nous
avons pu voir efficacité du système je
reviendrai dans un instant d'artillerie
César et qu'au fond les futurs prises
relatifs en tout cas que nous avons
aussi à créer autour de ces dispositifs
font partie de la clé en tout cas de
leur réussite sur le champ de bataille
et puis troisième élément pour être
clair ce que nous promettons nous le
donnons vraiment je dirais pas plus loin
je verrai peut-être dans un instant mais
il est clair que beaucoup d'annonces
sont faites mais parfois pas toujours
suivi des faits évidemment la France
sonore de remplir scrupuleusement sa
parole peut-être rappeler à la
représentation nationale les trois
grands chapitres d'aide militaire que
nous avons donné à l'Ukraine depuis le
début de la crise le premier chapitre
c'était évidemment des équipements de
protection individuel des armements
individuels des systèmes de missiles en
T-shirt anti-aériens bref c'était la
réaction entre février mars et avril de
cette année le deuxième chapitre a été
davantage plus lourd ça a été évidemment
les pièces d'artillerie les canons César
12 + 6 18 en tout les munitions qui vont
avec cette annonce César mais aussi de
nombreux véhicules dissous blindage
notamment des véhicules de transport de
troupes notamment les vap et le
troisième chapitre dans lequel nous nous
situons depuis maintenant le début du
mois de septembre c'est un chapitre qui
correspond à des demandes précises
formulées par les Ukrainiens notamment
en matière de carburant sur lequel
évidemment l'accès à celui-ci est
absolument décisif y compris d'ailleurs
pour faire rouler les fameux canon César
un calendrier important en matière de
maintenance et de pièces détachées tout
ça est peut-être moins spectaculaire que
de donner des pièces d'artillerie mais
c'est qu'annoncésar et d'autres pièces
nécessitent un entretien des pièces
détachées sur lequel évidemment nous
répondons présents des munitions puisque
la trission évidemment des stocks est
particulièrement importante et peut-être
encore moins spectaculaire mais qui fait
vraiment partie des demandes spécifiques
que l'Ukraine formalise auprès de la
France et bien la formation puisque
malheureusement là aussi il y a
nutrition des artilleurs et que
malheureusement quand un tombe il faut
que l'autre reprenne sa place avec la
formation qui va bien on a un nouvel
agenda sur l'autorité du Président de la
République d'accompagnement militaire à
l'Ukraine qui va se déployer dans les
semaines qui viendront le président de
la République nous a passé un certain
nombre de commandes qui va aussi
beaucoup reposer sur la mobilisation de
notre BITD puisque il faut que notre
industrie de défense soit aussi en
capacité de régénérer les stocks mais
genre l'occasion d'y revenir demain
devant la Commission de la Défense pour
peut-être aussi revenir sur les fameux
classement notamment la présidente rabot
et le président Valo ils sont revenus de
manière très transparence quelques
commentaires sur sur ces classements la
première des choses c'est que ils ne
tiennent compte de ce uniquement des
éléments qui sont en source ouverte
typiquement aujourd'hui ces classements
ne tiennent pas compte d'une partie de
l'aide de la France que nous avons
octroyé et qui n'est pas sur la place
publique pour être très clair la
deuxième des choses c'est que ces
classements AGR parfois des critères qui
sont très différents certains pays ont
par exemple valorisé le coût de la
formation certains pays on valoriser le
coût de transport des munitions chacun
fait ce qu'il veut mais nous nous
l'avons pas fait c'est un élément que je
livre à leur présentation nationale
troisième des choses il ne tiennent
compte en général que ce qui est premier
et non effectivement livré et là une
fois plus j'en dis pas plus pour ne pas
créer d'incident avec nos amis et alliés
enfin il y a une réalité c'est que à
l'unité près ce qui a été promis a été
donné aux Ukrainiens et puis enfin la
ministre coloniale a rappelé ces
classements ne tiennent jamais compte de
la facilité européenne de paix qui
représente pourtant 450 millions d'euros
pour la part française pratiquement 20%
du Fonds européen c'est pas pour dire
qu'on est meilleur ou qu'on est moins
bon c'est juste pour essayer d'éclairer
la présentation nationale sur ces
classements qui sont véhiculés et qui
circulent sur Internet ou dans la presse
et sur lequel à mon avis il aurait
beaucoup de choses à dire et si on
devait remettre à jour je pense que la
France remonterait de manière assez
significative sur les différents pays
européens mais nul ne conteste
évidemment que nos amis et alliés
américains les premiers contributeurs un
mauve pour en terminer sur la
réassurance sur le flanc oriental de
l'Europe par la France dans son cadre de
statut de nation cadre dans le cadre de
l'OTAN c'est pratiquement 900 hommes en
tout qui sont mobilisés défense du ciel
avec des missions qui sont évidemment
importantes un groupe évidemment de
l'armée de terre qui est positionné une
capacité à nous élever au niveau brigade
si malheureusement il le fallait
peut-être un chiffre là aussi pour la
représentation nationale cet
investissement comme nation-card en
Roumanie aura coûté au contribuable
français 700 millions d'euros pour la
seule année 2022 ce sont des crédits qui
n'étaient pas prévus évidemment donc il
faut le souligner ça montre aussi
l'engagement de ce que fait la France et
l'armée française le président Gassi où
est revenu sur les différents éléments
qui nous attendent pour l'avenir oui ce
qui se passe en Ukraine nécessitera un
rétexte profond c'est vrai de lubridité
de l'hybridité c'est vrai sur la
dissuasion nucléaire c'est vrai
évidemment sur les stocks de munitions
mais nous aurons l'occasion d'en
reparler dans le cas la loi de finances
pour 2023 mais aussi évidemment dans le
cadre des travaux pour coproduire
ensemble comme la première ministre
l'indiqué tout à l'heure pour coproduire
avec le Parlement et les différentes
formations politiques la prochaine loi
de programmation militaire merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Roland Lescure
ministre délégué de l'industrie
la Présidente je vais le prendre d'ici
parce que au fond il y a eu assez peu de
questions sur les sujets économiques et
c'est une bonne nouvelle ça prouve que
si ce n'est
l'uniformité l'Universalis la conformité
la l'unanimité derrière les sanctions
économiques on a une ou deux questions
sur lesquelles je reviendrai mais
globalement la représentation nationale
reconnecte nous faisons les efforts
nécessaires pour appuyer l'effort de
guerre de l'Ukraine face à son
envahisseur on a quand même eu une
question du côté de Monsieur buisson sur
la supposer une efficacité des sanctions
alors il y a quelques mois c'était les
sanctions tout court puis les sanctions
sur le gaz puis comme il n'y a pas de
sanction sur le gaz on a maintenant une
remise en doute des sanctions sur sur
l'énergie la réalité c'est que il y a
des sanctions depuis le 31 mai un
embargo sur le pétrole russe qui a eu un
impact important sur l'économie russe et
qui n'a pas eu beaucoup d'impact sur
l'économie française puisque depuis le
pétrole a baissé de 20 à 30 dollars et
qu'en plus on a accompagné cette baisse
vous le savez par des efforts
conséquents le fameux rabais remis à la
pompe en revanche l'économie russe elle
elle fait face à une récession
importante ça a été dit par madame la
Première ministre ça a été rappelé par
madame la ministre des Affaires
étrangères mais quand même vous rappeler
les chiffres moins 6%
en 2022 c'est énorme même le
gouvernement russe admet que l'économie
russe va baisser au moins de 3% en 2022
on s'attend à 4% de plus de récession en
2023 une inflation de 15% et tout ça
avant la mobilisation générale dont je
doute qu'elle est un impact très positif
sur l'économie avec à la fois l'impact
qu'elle a eu sur les sorties du
territoire évidemment j'allais le dire
sur le moral des trous et donc ces
sanctions elles ont un impact il faut le
dire il faut le répéter encore à
l'extérieur trop souvent on nous dit que
l'économie russe n'est pas affectée par
ses sanctions elle l'est et elle est
fortement alors évidemment ce conflit
est notre engagement aux côtés du peuple
ukrainien ne se fait pas sans peine ne
se fait pas sans effort pour notre
économie les industries évidemment dont
j'ai la charge sont extrêmement touchés
par la hausse des prix de l'énergie nous
y travaillons sous la gouverne de la
première ministre avec Bruno Le Maire
qui est ce soir et demain Luxembourg
pour négocier avec ses partenaires
européens des mesures d'atténuation de
l'impact de la hausse des prix de
l'énergie sur l'industrie européenne et
sur l'industrie française
qui était à Bruxelles vendredi qui sera
encore dans quelques jours pour
s'assurer que le marché de l'énergie
fonctionne davantage et que les prix de
l'énergie puissent baisser de manière
durable mais reconnaissons quand même
que les efforts nous les avons fait que
les efforts la plupart d'entre vous
d'ailleurs les ont voté madame panot
vous avez mentionné en passage
l'augmentation des tarifs de
l'électricité ou de l'énergie pour les
Français l'année prochaine vous avez
oublié de mentionner que en moyenne
cette hausse des tarifs elle sera cinq
fois inférieure à celle qu'on a connu à
peu près partout en Europe et vous
n'avez pas mentionné non plus peut-être
le votre et vous que nous avons prévu
d'accompagner les ménages les plus
modestes
pour les aider à absorber cette hausse
soyons en fier vous l'avez voté ici la
France aujourd'hui accompagne son
économie nous n'avons le faire davantage
et c'est le coût aussi à payer pour la
paix et pour le soutien des Ukrainiens
alors on a eu un certain nombre de
remarques et de questions sur les
entreprises françaises qui restent en
Russie
là-dessus je serai extrêmement prudent
et j'éviterai de donner des leçons on
peut tout savoir des idées qui pour
certaines d'entre elles seraient sans
doute anticonstitutionnel parce que
confiscatoire ou en tout cas clairement
ne peuvent s'envisager que dans un cadre
européen
oui et les entreprises citoyennes je
vais y revenir monsieur Lecoq il faut
qu'elle le soit mais attention juste à
des idées qui pourraient je le répète
est anticonstitutionnel éventuellement
affaiblir nos entreprises par rapport à
d'autres entreprises européennes et
surtout tout simplement affaiblir des
entreprises qui le sont déjà vous le
savez nous avons un credo très clair sur
les entreprises qui sont aujourd'hui en
Russie
toutes les sanctions rien que les
sanctions évidemment respect absolu des
sanctions qui ont été engagées par la
communauté internationale et notamment
l'Union européenne on ne peut pas
imaginer aujourd'hui que des entreprises
qui sont aujourd'hui en Russie ne
respectent pas la loi mais au-delà
attention à ne pas montrer des doigts je
le répète des entreprises qui pour
certaines d'entre elles sont fragilisées
qui pour d'autres sont d'ailleurs
peut-être en train d'organiser leur
sortie ordonnées du territoire russe une
chose est claire c'est que celle qui
sont sorties
n'ont pas fait d'argent au passage et on
s'en doutu il essaie un certain nombre
de pertes c'est l'entreprise citoyenne
que vous mentionnez monsieur Lecoq et
que d'autres sont sans doute en train
d'organiser leur sortie en septembre
Capgemini et Air Liquide ont annoncé
leur sortie leur activité russe c'est
des centaines d'employés concernés
Capgemini a même proposé à ses employés
un accord de manière à ce qu'il puisse
aller travailler à Lisbonne au Portugal
et certains employés russes ont accepté
de prendre ce truc cet accord donc
attention ne montrons pas du doigt les
entreprises qui sont présentes qui font
face à une situation extrêmement
difficile et reconnaissons
qu'aujourd'hui c'est leur responsabilité
face à leurs actionnaires face à leurs
parties prenantes face à leur réputation
que de décider de rester là-bas avec
tous les risques que cela comporte
mesdames et messieurs les députés soyons
fiers de ce que la France a fait pour
soutenir Ukraine soyons fiers de ce que
l'économie française fait pour soutenir
l'Ukraine et merci à tous et à tous de
ce beau débat aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
parole pour terminer ta madame la
Première ministre
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés quelques mots
alors que ce débat touche à sa fin tout
d'abord pour remercier les orateurs
intervenus cet après-midi
la guerre en Ukraine a bousculé le monde
elle nous pousse à accélérer des
transitions majeures
elle a des conséquences dont nous
n'avons pas fini de mesurer les effets
nous avons des différences bien sûr
c'est le principe même de la démocratie
et c'est pourquoi ce débat en ouverture
de la session était importante
je veux saluer l'esprit de
responsabilité sur la majorité de ces
bancs la volonté de faire valoir des
idées et pas de faire vivre des
polémiques la situation en Ukraine est
grave nous devions être à la hauteur
je voulais ensuite saluer le large
consensus qui se dégage de nos débats
nous condamnons l'agression russe elle
est illégale brutale violente elle en
fera toutes les règles internationales
la Russie est prête à toutes les
méthodes tous les chantages elle est
seule responsable de cette situation
nous ne pouvons pas l'accepter nous
soutenons collectivement l'Ukraine dans
sa résistance nous partageons un immense
respect pour les autorités les forces et
le peuple ukrainien nous pouvons
débattre des meilleures manières
d'accompagner l'Ukraine mais nous nous
accordons sur la nécessité de l'aider
je regrette bien sûr que certains soient
dans la manifestation d'un soutien
rhétorique qui pourrait ne s'accompagner
d'aucune pression sur la Russie voir
semble vouloir renvoyer deux ados
l'Ukraine et la Russie
je m'étonne également que d'autres
parlent de guerre sociale alors que la
France est le pays qui a le mieux
protégé des effets de la guerre comme
elle l'a fait face au covid
mesdames et messieurs les députés
au-delà de ces regrets je me réjouis que
ce débat était dense et riche il y a des
combats des causes et des valeurs qui
rassemblent tous les républicains ne
l'oublions jamais je vous remercie
je vous remercie madame la Première
ministre donc le débat est clos
prochaine séance ce soir à 21h30 sur le
projet de loi pour ton mesure d'urgence
relative au fonctionnement du marché du
travail en vue du plein emploi merci